hello everyone
welcome to another video tutorial by
simply learn today we are going to learn
python programming in detail if you are
a beginner and have interest in learning
python from scratch then this is the
right video for you we have our
experience instructor anish
who will take you through this video
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to the simply loan channel and
hit the bell icon to never miss an
update from simply loan first
you will get an introduction to python
and understand how to install python and
use anaconda you will then learn the
basics of python such as variables data
types data structures such as list
tuples and dictionaries
moving further
you will get an idea about using
conditional statements if and if else
next you will learn while loops and for
loops you will then see
the concepts of file handling and deep
dive into learning object oriented
programming you will also understand how
to write functions in python
finally you will work on three
interesting python projects to improve
your programming skills so let's get
started hello everyone and welcome to
our course on python programming my name
is anish karan and i will help you learn
the fundamentals of python programming
and what programming in python really
means and what it is all about
i am sure there are plenty of you over
here that are watching this video that
have their own reasons and multiple
reasons to start learning programming
and programming in python in particular
our goal over the duration of this
course is to ensure that you are able to
learn python and learn python
programming to a level in which you can
tackle whatever problems you have and
whatever projects you set out to do in
the future now i'm sure you must have
heard that the some of the most upcoming
fields and some of the high prospect
domains
in the market right now such as data
science ai machine learning require
python programming and our goal in this
course is to get you to a level where
you can start tackling and creating
solutions to whatever problems you may
occur whether it be in your job or in
your studies or anywhere else or any
personal projects that you may
take up in the future now before we
actually get started on the actual
concepts and the fundamentals of python
i want to show you over the next two or
three videos exactly what how python
came to be what was the philosophy
behind creating this language and
basically a brief introduction behind
python and python programming so python
programming was developed first by a
person a dutch programmer by the name of
guido van rossum and python was first
released by him in the year 1991 now the
design philosophy behind python was to
create a language which was much easier
to read and much easier to actually code
in compared to the
or in contrast to the languages that
were prevalent back in those days such
as the language c
now formally python is an interpreted
high-level general purpose programming
and what this means is that uh python is
a it's a language that can be used for a
wide variety of applications as we will
see later uh the high level uh part of
this definition basically tells us that
python is written in a language that is
very abstract at a much higher abstract
level compared to the instructions that
a computer can actually read so in
layman's term you can say that python is
very close to the actual
language that we humans use and that's
the way python has been designed and the
difference between a high-level
programming language and a low-level
programming language is that low level
languages are essentially machine
language instructions that are the
actual instructions that a computer can
actually understand a high level
language like python is something that
we humans understand better and we can
write in it better now the term
interpreted over here
essentially means that we don't need to
compile our instructions that we give in
python now as i mentioned earlier that
the computers or any system that
involves computing needs low level
language to be fed to it so that the
computer can actually understand because
computers cannot understand the way we
write our code and this process of
converting from high level to lower
level called compilation and in most
languages such as c there's a special
process involved called compilation
which we do after we create our blocks
of code or scripts or whatever now when
we say python is an interpreted language
what this means is that we can actually
work on python and see the results right
at the get go we can skip this step of
compilation
because our system that runs python
actually does all of that conversion
from high level to a lower level
language as we type our code and uh this
actually speeds up the process very well
for us and makes programming in python
and other interpreted languages as well
much much easier for us python is of
course an open source language it's uh
the most bare implementation of python
known as c python is actually
even currently being maintained by a
foundation known as the software python
software foundation so essentially
python is being maintained developed by
a group of very talented developers and
it's it's open to pretty much anyone to
work with and to create libraries for
this allows python to be an amazing
language in the in the modern world
because in the modern world we have
different issues and different problems
in different spheres and domains that we
we would need
to update our libraries or update our
packages that we use in our programming
language on a very regular basis and so
python being an open source language
allows us to keep updating and keep up
with the times essentially when it comes
to solving problems now let's go over
some of the features of python and these
features are actually
why it's considered
that using python is advantageous over
using other languages so let's start
with some of these points now as we
mentioned python is very it's a very
readable program code readability is
very important it's one of the design
philosophies behind this when it was
being developed it's very easy to learn
which is why python is an entry point
for many people that are just beginning
to learn programming and as i mentioned
earlier it's a high level language in
python we since python is open source as
as i already mentioned so it gets it
benefits from all the the benefits you
get from any open source technology now
it's also portable so what this means is
that if we create a code in python and
we create in a particular system say on
windows
we don't need to make any changes if we
wanted to use the same script or that
same piece of code on some other system
say on a linux system or
a mac system python itself comes with a
very large standard library this this
facilitates us
a lot because we don't need to
create our own libraries or modules or
have to download very specific libraries
most of the problems that we do
encounter
quite commonly can already be solved by
the standard libraries that have already
been provided by the developers of
python write right from the beginning
now later later on during the course we
will uh encounter what is the meaning of
a data structure a data structure is
essentially a manipulation of a if of an
object of an object of data and
as as you will see later
python has one of the most user-friendly
data structures
that can be found in any language
especially compared to some of its
contemporaries now python is a
dynamically programmed language and this
is very important and what this means is
that in most compiler based languages we
there are certain processes that can
only happen during the compilation stage
so
what a dynamic programming language does
is it takes all those
compilation specific
tasks and processes and
it does it for us as we actually type
the code so we don't need to waste time
or spend extra time to do something that
would otherwise be needed to be only
done in compilation we would have to set
out specific uh run time just for that
so this allows us to create our programs
and solutions much faster and allows us
to debug much easier and
yeah so it's a it's it's a very
important feature about python now
quickly i will just go over some of the
uh areas of python where
like
areas of um or
different domains where python is very
heavily implemented and the first one
the first few ones that come to mind are
like web development and
ai and machine learning so you have
technologies like django and flash that
are
built on top of python that
are used extensively for web development
when it comes to something like
artificial intelligence or machine
learning you have
distributions such as anaconda you have
pandas and many other libraries like
scipy and numpy that are used
extensively to so tackle problems in
this domain and similarly python finds
use in most of the scientific work that
goes on nowadays
because of
again some of the libraries that i have
already mentioned such as scipy
interestingly if you are into game
development or gaming in general you
would see that python actually has
certain libraries and certain
technologies that facilitate game
development very very well one very
popular game in fifth in case you are
into gaming is a world of tanks that is
built on python some of the other
applications are of course desktop uh be
creating desktop gui image processing
graphic design applications and
something that is very relevant to me
and of course you as well is a creation
of education programs and training
courses
there are many technologies in the
environment of python that
were almost designed for the specific
purpose of
being able to present certain concepts
or to be able to
teach certain classes and
i can't think of too many programs or
too many environments outside of python
that are better to solve these education
and training course related
problems and situations so i will show
you how to install python on windows
since i have a windows system however i
will also point out uh the way you you
would have to install python on aim on
mac os or linux or even on mobile so uh
yeah let's get started so to install
python on your windows computer it's as
simple as going to the website
python.org and selecting the downloads
section when you do click on downloads
you get redirected to this website that
this web page that i'm on
out here it by default it will ask you
if you want to download python 3.9 which
is the latest version but of course if
you for whatever reason if you needed a
particular version of python you can
download that as well
by just scrolling down and choosing the
option that you want now it's important
to note that whatever option you choose
of course i would recommend the latest
one but no matter what option you choose
i would recommend you choose a version
of python three point something because
uh previous versions of python namely
python 2.7 and
and basically every version of python
2.0 something has it will not receive
any more maintenance and updates uh
because
the developers have decided that python
will they are trying to shift towards uh
maintaining and updating python
three-point whatever completely right
now so yeah
let's not delay this uh any further and
just download python 3.9 so once you
select the option out here
you'll be you'll get an installer all
you have to do is click on that and
it'll give you two options to customize
installation or install now i would of
course recommend this to install now
since you're a beginner do not worry
about what a custom installation is if
you have multiple drives in your system
by default the python will be downloaded
into
the drive where your windows is actually
installed your your main drive so as you
can see now that once my setup is done
it should give me a pop-up soon so my
setup is done for python and this is
essentially how you would um download
python on your windows system uh but
what if you had mac os or if you were
using linux well for mac it's a it's
actually almost as simple you just go
if you see out here below this download
button python option you get the website
asking you are you looking for python on
a different os and it gives you the
options of linux mac and even other oss
but for mac
if you wanted you would just open this
tab and
just like the windows option you would
choose a version and you would choose an
installer for that version so if i
wanted say python the latest one i would
just download this installer and i would
install in my mac system now when it
comes to linux i cannot show you exactly
how you would install it there are
certain commands that you have to
execute but essentially again if you
just choose the linux option out here it
would take you to a page with different
installers and
essentially packages for linux systems
in specific what i would recommend to
you if you are a linux user and you need
python is to go over to the real
python.com website and they have a very
good uh essentially instructions on how
to install python and since i don't have
a linux system i cannot directly show
you how to install python on linux so
yeah if you do have linux please head
over to this website and this should be
of a lot of help to you now
as i had mentioned you can actually
install python on your mobile devices as
well so if you were say an ios user you
would go to the ios app store and
download an app called the python is the
app for ios it essentially is like a
full-fledged uh python environment where
you can develop in python on your iphone
or even ipad uh and if you were an
android user you could you would go and
download an app called the pi droid 3.
uh there's a free version and a paid
version for this app and of course the
difference between the free and paid is
that the paid supports
code analysis and code prediction that
these are certain details you don't have
to worry about right now and
honestly if i wouldn't worry too much
about installing python on your mobile
devices currently since
i am assuming most people would be
learning programming and programming in
python on their pcs or laptops now that
we've mentioned how to install python
what i had actually shown you was
installing
what is called an implementation of
python on your system an implementation
is essentially a program or a software
or an environment that allows you to
actually work in python so what i showed
you was how to install the by default or
the most basic or reference
implementation that has been created by
the developers which is actually called
c python even though you would not you
would not have seen the word the letter
c or the prefix c uh but yeah that
implementation that i had i had
downloaded myself and i had shown you to
download uh is actually the c python
implementation which is python built
on top of c the the c language
essentially uh there are other
implementations such as iron python
which uses the dotnet framework and
jpython that uses java virtual machines
that you could use if you were
interested but again these are things
that i would not worry about too much
right now so now that we have tackled on
how to install your implementation of
python i want to introduce
what is called a distribution view
this distribution is called anaconda
anaconda is a very important
distribution especially if you are
looking to
use python in data science and machine
learning and ai which i am assuming is
the motivation for many of the people
that are actually watching this video
that they actually want to move into
data science and they need to learn
python as a foundation towards moving
towards data science and if that is your
goal or in any case whatever your goal
may be i would recommend that
you install anaconda distribution now do
not get confused between anaconda and
python their anaconda is python with
i
in the form of a bundle and this bundle
contains not only the basic python
implementation that i had shown you
download but it contains a lot of extra
libraries and technologies and softwares
as well so of course this means that
would you need to download both of
course not if you download a python you
do not need anaconda to work on python
and
if you have already downloaded anaconda
which i will show you how to do it in
some time if you have already downloaded
anaconda you don't need to download
python separately so i'll just speak
about anaconda little briefly so as i
said it's a distribution it it it
contains a bundle uh which includes a
basic python implementation and a lot of
technologies and softwares and
applications
that has essentially helped us
to use python in in in specifically
managing their big data applications and
data science related projects so so now
i will show you actually how to install
python i mean anaconda on your system
it's as simple it was it's actually as
simple as downloading just this thing so
if i did a quick quick google of
anaconda
so the website that i'm looking for is
anaconda.com and i'm looking at products
and i'm looking at individual edition
there are other editions as well like
commercial team edition these are for
companies usually or
for more professional sort of projects
so of course we are looking at the
individual edition and if you selected
this page you would be taken to
this particular webpage where it will
ask you if you want to download and
again there are options depending on
which machine you're using after you're
using a linux you would choose one of
these two if you are using mac os you
would use one of these two and since i
am a windows user and i have a 64-bit
system this is the option i would use so
again it will it will first download and
install it for you and as you can see my
installer has been
downloaded so now upon opening it it
will open up this installation thing
you can just click next on most of these
again if you want to specify your
destination folder you can change it
here mine will be with a default folder
in the c drive and you can leave this
unticked you can you can change these
options much later so
this is how you install an account on
windows and it's pretty much the same on
other systems as well now once it's done
i will show you what exactly what are
some of the things that anaconda
contains that are not there if you uh
installed python like the way i had
shown you earlier just the bare bones
python implementation so as you can see
here my installation is actually
complete
and now i will open anaconda and i'll
show you what how you can actually use
this anaconda so if i search for
anaconda in my system i would look for
something called anaconda navigator to
actually get started with this and when
i open that it should open something
like this so this is what opens when you
click on the anaconda navigator and as
you can see
there are a bunch of applications you
don't need to worry about what these
mean
right now
uh just understand that this this is
essentially a bundle of uh different
applications and technologies that come
along with just the normal installation
of python that you get when you install
anaconda navigator now now that we have
actually tackled
where we've seen how to install and i'm
hoping and i would recommend definitely
that everyone is watching this video
installs anaconda not just the
normal python uh installation or
implementation
now that we have gotten all the
introductions and the basics and the
installations uh regarding python aside
uh let's get right let's get down to
actually creating our first script so
now the question is uh how do we
actually start doing this task of
creating our first python script how do
we
how do we realize uh now that we've
installed a python like uh now let's how
do we start doing something so
the answer to that question is that
typically when you're working on python
the one of the most basic things that
you can do is create a python script and
execute a script a script is essentially
a sequence of commands and instructions
that you give
for python to run and execute to give
you a certain result so i will show you
how you can create a python script now
there are multiple ways of creating a
python script you can create it directly
from command line which is obviously
something i would not recommend because
it is not convenient and easy and it's
not very useful for the beginner another
way is using a text editor such as the
one i have opened right now which is the
notepad plus plus
text editor now it's very important to
not get confused
between notepad plus plus and the
standard notepad that comes with your
windows
or wordpad for that matter in fact text
editors such as notepad and wordpad
that you are more familiar with create
text and files in a form that is called
rich text now rich text is something
is text that
contains formatting and fonts which is
actually a hindrance when it comes to
creating actual code so what we need is
a text editor that creates or writes
text in what we call as plain text uh
plain text is obviously text which does
not contain these fonts and these
formattings and it only respects white
spaces and indentations those two being
actually useful towards creating code
unlike fonts and formatting which are
only a visual thing so notepad plus plus
is obviously a text editor that creates
uh plain text documents uh that is very
that was actually created with
programming in mind
obviously you can use a bunch of other
text editors such as wim and atom and
you can google for these there are
plenty of them so
without any further ado let's create our
first python script so one of the most
common one of the most famous examples
of
a first program in any program for that
matter not just python is creating a
print statement that gives us a
statement saying hello world so in
python this is how you would go about or
this is the syntax you would use to
create the statement
all right
now which is very important when you are
saving your python program that you use
the dot py prefix so if i were to save
this i can choose whatever folder i am
going to choose
yeah this folder seems fine so now i
give the file name over here as say i
want to keep it as test i need to prefix
this with dot py and this uh tells
any uh sort of interpreter or anytime we
need to read the script to know that
it's a python script we need to add a
dot py otherwise it will not be treated
as a python script will be treated as
some normal document sort of a thing so
now that i've stored it as dot py
i have created my first python script
now
obviously the next question is i need to
see
what happens when i execute this line
when i run this script essentially so
to see that
there are multiple ways the first way
that i will show you is the command line
method which is obviously again before
we get into it it's not something that i
will be using to teach you it's not
something i would recommend you just
immediately start using um but for the
sake of showing i will show you how to
execute a script in command line well to
do this you go since i have installed
anaconda in my system and i will be
using anaconda to
work in python what i will look for is
something called the anaconda prompt as
you can see this is the option that i
get anaconda prompt uh this will
essentially open you a command line uh
under the environment of anaconda or
python so in this
now i am already in the folder i believe
that had my script so
how do i call this script or how do i
run the script well the command is
python space the name of my file which
was test of course the prefix is very
important so i enter test.py if you if
this was in a different folder you would
have to change your folders and command
line which is again something that i
might show you later but since my file
is already in the folder that i am in in
my command line i would just have to
enter this command right now so if i
execute this as you can see it's given
me an output of hello world which is
which is what i wanted i wanted it to
print this uh these two words
and of course the command line is now
waiting for the next command for me so
this is uh one of the most simple ways
of or the most rudimentary ways of
executing a python script now another
question would be well this isn't the
most visually appealing or
not the easy to read or easy to use way
of
executing scripts and i would agree and
that's why i'm going to introduce a
another technology or a software called
the ide so the ide in python or in any
programming language stands for
integrated development environment it's
essentially a software that not only
allows us to run scripts but it allows
us to create the scripts it allows us to
debug it allows us to see outputs it
allows us to see intermediary outputs
it allows us to do a wide variety of
tools and tasks and it comes with a
bunch of robust features to enhance our
python programming experience so let's
let's see so i will show you a an ide
called spider which comes bundled along
with the anaconda distribution that i
had mentioned earlier so if i open the
anaconda navigator
as you can see the anaconda navigator
shows me a bunch of technologies and
options and i'm looking for something
called the spyder ide which is over here
as you can see here it's a scientific
python development environment uh this
is exactly what i'm looking for so
i am looking to launch this so now that
i've launched it you can see out here
this is what an ide looks like now this
looks very sophisticated and it's it's a
one and any almost any ide is a
wonderful
software that where you can create your
code you can debug your code you can
check the results you can make
adjustments changes and you can do a
wide variety of tasks and functions with
relation to your programming so this is
the spider id in particular and this is
how it looks don't worry about the exact
details just know that on this left hand
pane is our current script that is open
out here and out here we will get the
results in this this is what we call a
console console essentially
so now that we we have already created
our script in notepad plus plus and i
want to open that script and i want to
see uh how and i how it would uh the
result of that script would look in an
ide so let's just open it so we can
browse for our file and as i had
named it test this is the file over here
i open this and as you can see out here
in the left hand pane
my script has opened and the command
that had given or had written is out
over here now if i want to run this
application i press this green button
and as you can see the result of my my
execution essentially is over here it's
in slightly small font but as you can
see over here uh it says hello world and
it's way and the next line is
essentially it's it's waiting for me to
do another execution of the script and
then it will give me new results so
let's actually give the system new
results so now that i have printed
something called hello world let's let's
change what's written over here
let's say i will perform
basic maths all right and let's actually
perform the basic maths again don't
worry about the details the syntax what
i'm exactly doing these are things that
we will actually cover in the
in upcoming videos and modules so let's
create a variable called a let's store a
a number three let's create a variable b
story number five all right let's create
another variable c
uh which will store the result of what's
in a and b in the addition of a and b
all right and let's print the result or
print what's in uh this variable c or
what's the result of a plus b i will
print a statement saying the result of
the addition of three and five is all
right and i will put my result over here
as you can see uh i should get the
result in this pane so let's execute
this and you can see uh my first line is
executed saying i will perform basic
maths and the next line says the result
of the addition of three and five is
eight so uh this in this script what
i've done is i have performed uh two
print statements and i've performed a
basic expression some variable
assignments uh all of these things we
will be doing later this is what i what
i'm essentially trying to show you is
that ides are a very convenient way of
not only creating the scripts but
actually seeing the results and then
making adjustments as well we can com we
can create a completely new script we
don't need to create a script from some
special file or text editor i can just
create a new file here and this is my
new script essentially so i can start
working on with this new script right
over here from the get go so ides are
very powerful spider ide comes uh
bundled with anaconda there are other
ideas such as the i idle ide it stands
for
indicated development and learning
environment so the ideal
ide comes
as part of the
basic python implementation that i had
shown you in the previous video where if
you just installed a basic uh python
implementation it would come along with
a basic ide known as idle or integrated
development and learning environment but
of course since we are using python and
that's what i would recommend uh it
comes with a more robust ide called
spider
which is actually very very helpful for
scientific
and numeric applications
and was designed specifically with that
in mind
now
this is not the only way we can actually
work with python there's another very
interesting and uh a very educative
method of creating python let's say
python programs and it's something that
i will be using extensively throughout
this course to explain different
concepts so this technology is called or
the software is called uh notebooks
now
before i get into the details i will
state i will just open node a basic
notebook so the notebook that comes as
part of anaconda is called the jupiter
notebook and when i open or when i
launch the jupyter notebook this is what
i get now
a very important
feature or a a feature of notebooks is
that notebooks uh a web browser or a
web-based application so you it's not
something that you can use if you are
offline or disconnected basically if
you're disconnected from the internet it
is something which for which you would
need an active
internet connection however it is way
more robust and it has very very good uh
properties that allow it to be used in
education or for presentations and such
so as you can see this is my jupiter
notebook these are a bunch of folders
don't need to worry about what these are
right now i will show you how to create
a fresh notebook so if you go here now
you go to new and you select under
notebook the python 3
option it will open you your first
notebook
as you can see um this line is
essentially waiting for me to enter some
sort of a command or a statement that i
would give in a normal python thing now
if you would have noticed that
in uh until now everything that we were
doing involved us
creating a script which was the whole
series of commands and functions so if i
go back to my spider ide as you can see
like this is a whole script and this
script contains multiple different
tasks and functions that are
individually
being performed so this is a separate
print function this is a separate
edition another separated print function
and for longer
programs or larger programs you like you
have multiple different tasks being done
and if you were using a script you can
only see the result of something like
this by executing the whole thing at
once you cannot see exactly like what is
the result of just this print statement
or just this
it's not typically
what an ide is used for and this is
where notebooks come in super handy
if i had to break down my previous
script essentially where i first did a
print statement
where i said some random thing say hello
yeah so if i execute this particular
line you can see it gives me the result
now i want to do what is 5 plus 3
it should give me the result over here
eight now the next
another part of your program might be
storing five and three into variables so
i can do this and i can do this so now
this line will store the variables now i
want to do the addition of what is 5 3
but i want to use the variables and i
want to see what's the result as you can
see a plus b means 5 plus 3 which is 8
and i've essentially broken down various
different parts of my previous script
into
into its individual tasks and i'm able
to see what each part of that script
does and this is very good when it comes
to making presentations or
trying to teach a class so i will
personally be using notebooks a lot to
explain different different concepts of
different concepts when it comes to
python and i would recommend that you
get used to
notebooks in general because
it's an amazing way to learn python
programming or programming in general in
fact
and again as i had mentioned earlier
notebooks are something that it's an
online
application it's a web-based application
so i will have to need a active internet
connection to be able to work on a
notebook which could be a disadvantage
if you do not have a consistent internet
connection and in that case you would
probably use your ides or text editor
which you can be used offline as well in
this video we will be introduced to the
concept of variables and expressions
let's start with expressions well an
expression in python is anything that
results in a value its difference
although the difference between an
expression and a standard statement in
python is that a statement in python is
something that results in an action or
an execution of a command there is no
calculation per se or any sort of
manipulation or as i said earlier
calculation
resulting in between two different say
numbers or other objects that results in
a value and this happens in the case of
an expression so for example if i were
to add two numbers say 5 plus 10 this is
an expression which should where two
objects five and ten are being added and
a result is being given to me which is
15. now let's see an example of a
statement well a statement could be
something like a print statement so when
i ask python to print something for me
it's not calculating anything it's not
evaluating anything it's simply
performing an action that i have or a
command that i have given the system
which is to print whatever i have
entered over here as you can see so this
is a statement similarly there are
another type of statement known as
assignment statements which we will
learn actually right in the next section
well let's move on to variables right
now now earlier you might have learned
about objects in python so
objects are essentially data
that we can work with or manipulate in
python now variables are a place to
store these different objects
usually it's much easier to
store objects in python instead of using
the objects explicitly themselves
because objects may be very completely
complicated whereas variables are very
simple to use and very simply very are
named in a very simple manner so that we
can use them quite often in our programs
now it's important to note that in
python we do not have to explicitly
declare or define a variable to create
them in fact variables are created in
the same statement where we assign some
object to that variable in python the
assignment of variables happens using
the assignment operator which is the
equals to sign so if i were to if i
wanted to assign a number say 100 to a
variable say b
well it would be as simple as doing this
now anytime i want to know what is
stored in b i just have to enter b and i
will get the value that is stored in it
and we can store different types of
objects inside any variable let's say i
store i want to store this particular
word in the form of a string now this is
stored in x and if i want to know what
is an x i can just see what is here and
it's a string hello which i had stored
earlier now it's very important that we
follow
certain naming rules when it comes to
naming our variables in python or else
we may be thrown errors or we might get
some problems in our program so the
first truth is that you cannot start
your variable name with a number so if i
were to give a variable name like for
num
is equal to something say
the same string hello this would be an
illegal variable name and i will get an
error when i try this so if i were to
choose a num for
is equal to hello this would be
perfectly fine i won't get an error the
second rule is we are not allowed to use
any
non-alphanumeric characters except the
underscore character while naming our
variable so for example if i were to
name my variable num underscore 4 and i
say i said random some random string
this is perfectly fine however if i
change num underscore 4 to num hyphen 4
this will throw me an error as you can
see over here next the third rule is
that variable names are case sensitive
so if i have a variable called num
or say num if this was one of my
variables and i stored say the value of
50 this is not the same as me writing
num all in capitals and say storing some
other value 60 these are two different
variables so it's very important that
when you name your variables you are
aware of what case you are writing them
in because python variables are case
sensitive now the final and probably one
of the most important rules in python is
that you are not allowed to use what we
call reserve words in python now python
has a bunch of reserved words these
words essentially are performed or they
are used to perform certain special
functions and are used as identifiers
for certain special functions in python
that we that have a special purpose like
that particular word has a special
purpose within the python programming
language and we cannot use them to name
our variables so a list of them either
you can see over here some of them are
like false def if
and there are like there are around 33
of them and
sometimes some of these words are taken
out sometimes there are more words added
as python gets updated now let's let's
move on to a concept
where we try to really understand
what do we mean by storing data inside a
variable now when i say that we are
storing something inside a variable you
get an image or you get an idea in your
head that this variable is like a
container where we store or we put a
particular object inside it so does this
mean that variables have a place in the
memory are they also an object that is
placed in the memory where we can put
other objects inside of well i'll show
you an example where this idea is kind
of disproven or where i'll show you that
the idea of variable is kind of
different than what we understand by
storing something inside a variable now
let's say i'm storing the same object i
will take this object as some random
number let's say 100 and i'm going to
store it into two different variables so
i take x is equal to 100 over here
and in the next line i will store 100 in
y as well now if objects were i mean if
variables were objects that we placed in
our system then x and y should have two
different ids but let's see what happens
when i check the id of x and the id of y
they should be different in case
variables were their own objects however
as you can see the id of x and the id of
y are exactly the same so well obviously
we know that two different objects in
python cannot have the same id
so
does this so what does this mean when it
comes to the nature of a variable well
the the fact is that variables are not
actually objects in python in fact
variables are more like pointers or
references to the actual object so when
i said x is equal to 100 and y is equal
to 100 what i'm actually telling the
system is that there is this variable
name called x that i want to refer or
point towards the actual object that is
in my memory called 100 and i do the
same thing with another variable y so i
am not exactly creating it a different
space in my system for these variables
these variables are more like
placeholders or references that point to
a particular place in the memory where
this object is located and that is what
happens when i do id of x and id of y
it's not giving me the idea of something
called x or the id of something called y
is giving me the id of 100 each time
because 100 is stored in x and y so as
you can see this is something like a
visual representation of what i'm trying
to say and similarly if if i were to so
in this example on the left as you can
see i've used the
value of 50 to explain my point so as
you can see initially x and y are
pointing towards this value 50 because i
have stored 50 and 50 in both x and y
now what if i changed the object that is
stored in x well that means x is now
pointing towards this new object and i
have stored this new object called hello
this string called hello as you can see
here so now x is pointing to a new
object in the system and it's called
hello
and
i haven't changed anything with respect
to y so y will point towards the same
thing and i can also make the pointer of
y different or what i'm trying to say is
i can store something else in y see i
stored this list in y 50 60 100. when i
do that now y is pointing towards a
different object in python and x is also
pointing towards something else so what
happens to this object 50 well now that
there's no variable referring to this
object 50 it becomes what we call an
orphaned object and we can actually see
that when we do the id of x now let's go
back to my example on the right where i
stored x is equal to 100 so as you can
see it gives me some id represented by
this number now let's say i stored x i
stored something different index say 200
now if i do the id of x it should give
me a different id because as you can see
the values are different and this is
because
this object 200 is what is stored in x
and when i do the id of x i'm actually
getting the id of this new object now
200. so as you can see point as you can
see variables are
they should be and they are treated more
like references or pointers
instead of containers for a particular
object in this video you will be
introduced to the concept of objects in
python now what are objects in python
well all the data that we manipulate or
use in our operations in our code are
represented as objects or relations
between objects so if you want an
example two numbers that you add in your
code well both of them are objects and
the usually numeric type objects
similarly if you want to store someone's
name or an address of your hometown in
your code you usually store it in a form
of text and that text is also an object
usually a string similarly you might
want to create a container of different
smaller objects inside them and that big
container is also a type of an object
and one of those containers are called
lists and similarly we have many
different types of objects which we will
be covering during the duration of this
course the following pictorial
representation gives us a broad
classification of different python data
types and objects as we can see there
are five broad classifications numeric
which contains integers complex numbers
and floats we have the dictionary data
type we have the boolean which
essentially consists of objects that
have only two valid values true or false
then we have sets and we have sequence
data types such as strings lists and
tuples every object in python has three
important properties that kind of define
that particular object they are its
identity its type and its value the
identity of an object is it can be
considered as a place in the memory or
its address in the memory where an
object is stored an object's identity
does not change once it has been created
so for example if i took an example of
say a string called hello i can use the
id function which is this is how you use
the id function to find out the id of
this object and it should be uh the
answer should be in the form of a
particular long integer so as you can
see the id of hello is this integer two
three two six four seven six six two
three zero two four similarly all
objects in python have an identity we
have another operation with uh regarding
the identity of an object is the is
operator and the is operator compares
the identity of two objects so if two
objects have the same identity it should
give the answer true otherwise false now
the next property of objects is the type
type of an object is essentially
what defines what kind of values and
operations
that that object can have so for example
a numeric dr type in python such as an
integer would allow us to do arithmetic
operations and similarly string object
type in python will allow us to do
concatenation operations much like its
identity the type of an object cannot be
changed as well now let's see what's the
type of that particular object that i
had shown you above as you can see it
should be string str stands for string
similarly if i did a type for a number
say 50 it should give me int as you can
see now the third property of an object
in python is its value now the value is
the actual data that is contained in the
object it's the thing that we use that
we display that we can manipulate and
that we can perform operations on so for
example if i were to talk about this
string the string is hello so the value
of the string is the word or the
sequence of letters that spell out hello
and similarly this particular object is
a numeric object with the value of 50.
let's see in this in this pictorial
representation i have shown you that you
can assume this dash blue area as the
memory of the system within this memory
we have objects created called 50 and
hello and this list containing smaller
objects called cat pen and 40. now what
i'm trying to show you here is each of
these objects have a type an id and a
value and let's see what they are if i
wanted to see as we had already seen the
type of 50 now let's find the id of 50.
as you can see we get this unique id for
the object 50 which is obviously not the
same as the id of the object hello above
and the value of this object is the
value of 50 itself so that was a brief
introduction into objects in python in
this video we will cover the topics of
numeric object types and type
conversions in python now let's get
started numeric object types in python
are a broad classification of objects
plenty of common real-life applications
that we associate with numerals such as
arithmetic operations and calculus are
done in python using numeric object data
types there are three main types of
numerals or numeric data types in python
they are integers float and complex
integers as the name suggests represent
all integer values in python these can
be such as 100 minus 3 to 305 and so on
floats are used to represent numerals
that contain decimal points such as
100.3 3.9 4.8 minus 6.8 and so on then
there is the complex object type which
is used to represent complex numbers in
python and this is an example of a
complex number three plus seven j
this is a complex number three plus
seven j where the real component is
three and the imaginary component is
seven all complex numbers have a real
and imaginary component and this is how
we denote them now it's important to
note that this j is a very common symbol
in maths and engineering used to denote
the
imaginary portion of a complex number
and it's the same in python as well so
moving on let's talk about type
conversion in python type conversion
refers to the conversion of an object
from one data type to another for
example from string to an integer and
there are different types of conversions
and let's go through some of them first
of all let's consider the conversion of
something to an integer and more
specifically let's consider the example
where we convert a string to an integer
so let's consider
my example string to be some something
called one four five and i'm sewing this
within a string for a reason because i
want to convert a string to an integer
so as you can see i have stored this one
four five within my within a variable x
and if i were to confirm that is
actually an integer i can use the type
function and see that it is actually an
integer str now let's convert this into
an integer using the int function so how
would we use it is
simply passing the end uh sim by passing
the variable that we want to convert
into the in function and as you can see
this is what i've done over here but
before this i will also store it into
another variable all right now let's see
what's in y well y gives us 145 but are
we sure that it's an int we can just
check it by using the type function and
as you can see the type gives us
the answer int that means that we've
converted the string to an end
interestingly we can convert something
and
also specify what base we have to treat
the number as
by default when we pass something in the
in function the program or python will
treat whatever we have passed uh within
the string as something in base of
decimal but what if we were to pass
something that is well not in a decimal
well we could do it like this now let's
store y
and ny let's store
let's do this and i will show you what
this means x
and i will give a comma and 8. what this
does python is well i want to convert
the string in x into an integer but i
want to treat whatever is an x as a
number of base eight so 145 is actually
145 in the base 8. now when we
see what's in y we get 101 which is
different to 145 because well 1 0 1 is
actually the decimal equivalent of 145
in the base 8. similarly if we were to
give it in the base 2 we would just
replace eight with two over here now
next let's talk about converting
something to a float now as we know
float is just simply something that has
a decimal point so let's convert an
integer into a float how would we do
that simply by using the float function
so if i give 120 and i pass this integer
through the float function i should get
120.0
these two are not the same though they
may mean the same things to us but in
for python 120 is an integer and 120.0
is a different object which is a float
and this is how we convert something to
a float now what if we wanted to convert
an integer to a string well we can use
the str function we can also use the hex
and the oc function if we want to
convert a particular number to a
hexadecimal or an octal string
respectively let's look at all three
examples say i have a number 688 and i
want to convert this into a string i
just use the str function around this so
as we know just to confirm let's see
what the type of 688 is this is
this should be an end as we can see but
when we pass when we let's say
we convert it into a string 688 and
let's store it into some variable let's
call it a all right now let's see what's
in a it gives us 688 in the form of a
string but we can confirm
by checking the type of a it is an str
so it is a string similarly we can use
hex
if we wanted to convert an integer into
its hexadecimal equivalent in the in in
in as an output of a string as you can
see this comp this sort of this sort of
complicated thing is actually telling us
that we have converted 688 in terms of
hexadecimals now how do we read this
output this zero
should not be treated as anything it's
more like a an identifier which says
that
the letter after this first zero is the
base of this whole number so it's saying
that x x stands for hexadecimal so it's
saying that 2 b 0 is to be treated as a
hexadecimal number and if you did basic
maths
you would find that the decimal
equivalent of 2b0 is 688. similarly if i
did oct if i use the oct function for
688 it will give me the result something
like this so again how to read this the
first zero is to be treated as an
identifier and not part of the number
what it's saying is the letter after the
first or after this zero is the base of
the number following these two following
these two characters so as you can see
as you can see what's this saying is
that this whole number is an oct
represented by this letter o
and the number itself that we are
dealing with is one two six zero and one
two six zero in octal system is the
equivalent of 688 in the decimal system
so this is how we've converted a an
integer in
an integer into a hexadecimal or a an
octal string now what if we wanted to
convert two
numeric objects into a complex data
object well for that we can use the
complex function as you can see here
if i passed complex 5 and say
say something like 3.1
let's see what this gives us as you can
see it gives us an
a complex object where
our real part is 5 and our imaginary
part is 3.1 so what this does is
essentially
you pass two numbers the first one is
the real component and the second is the
imaginary component it combines to give
you a complex number as you can see here
now let's look at some other type
conversions the next type we will be
talking about is converting something to
a tuple or a set or a list so what if i
wanted to convert a string into a tuple
i will use the tuple function and as you
can see over here so let's say i have a
string called
random let's call it random all right
now if i want to convert this to a tuple
i will use the tuple function as you can
see over here
the output will give me tuples where
each individual component of this tuple
are the individual components or the
individual characters of my string
random
similarly if i wanted to convert the
string to a list i would use the
list function
this will give me a list of the
individual characters
of the word or the the string random and
i could do the same thing with the set
function to create
a set of
individual characters of uh the string
random as you can see here
so yeah these were some of the basic
python
type conversions that i have shown you
as we learn about more complex data
types and different object types in
python we will learn different
type conversions and functions
associated with them in this video you
will be introduced to the concept of
strings strings are an object type in
python used to store textual data this
textual data could be something like for
example someone's name it could be an
address of a place or it could be
something like a word or a sentence now
strings in python are an object type
that is actually a subtype of a broader
classification of objects called
sequences sequences are objects in
python which contain components placed
one after the other where each component
is given what we call an index a numeric
index this numeric index identifies the
component in the sequence and is
positioned within the sequence
now since python is a zero index based
language the first object of any
sequence is always index zero the second
is index one the third is index two and
so on now let's move on to defining
strings how do we define them well
strings are defined using what we call
delimiters and delimiters occur in pairs
an opening and a closing delimiter in
python these zero emitters are pairs of
single or double quotes so for example
if i were to use single quotes to define
a string i could i would do it like this
this is a string
as you can see this is a string is
printed over here this is delimited
using single quotes similarly if i were
to define a string using double quotes
it's as simple as doing this this is
also a
as you can see
now a valid question arises what if i
wanted to include a single quote within
my string well
if i try to let's see what happens if i
try to print a statement with a single
quote naturally inside it so say i'm
saying it's my
birthday
all right let's see what happens if i
try to print this statement it says
invalid syntax and this is because as i
had mentioned in python single quotes
and double quotes are delimiters so they
have a special function in python and we
cannot simply just use them within a
string because python will treat them
specially for a special purpose so what
python will do is it will pair this and
this delimiter so single quotes and say
okay this looks like a string to me and
it's not going to understand the rest of
this and then it'll find a random single
quote and it won't find its pair and it
will basically throw us an error because
of this so one way or one workaround to
introduce single quotes into a string is
simply to delimit our string itself
using the other type of delimiter or
double quotes so if i want to include a
single quote i will close my string
using double quotes so if i did this
instead of what i had done earlier
this is a perfectly valid and legal way
of defining my string and i could i
would do the opposite if i had to
introduce a double quotes within my
string i would use single quotes to
close it so
if i were to write a speech statement
she said
i am
hungry all right i have i want these two
double quotes to essentially show that
this is a speech and i'm going to close
the string using single quotes and this
is a valid way of doing it as you can
see my string has these two double
quotes now i had mentioned that strings
are sequences well let's describe how
are they sequences so first of all all
sequences in python are a um it's a
essentially a sequence of smaller
objects that form the sequence right so
let's try to understand like how do how
are strings to be treated as sequences
some sequences that we will learn later
are like lists or tuples and in all
sequences
we can retrieve any particular object or
component in that sequence using its
index and how do we use indexes in
python well we enclose a numeric index
within square brackets now let's see
what i'm trying to talk about by this
example now say i'm storing a particular
string called say random within now my
variable name here is test and i'm
storing the string random within it all
right and this is a way of retrieving a
particular uh index from test i write
the variable name and then next to it i
put the square brackets now i'm supposed
to put um a numeral within these square
brackets to
tell python like what a particular index
i'm looking for so let's try zero now as
i said python is zero index based
language so
the zero index essentially means the
first part of for the first component of
a sequence so let's see what happens
when i ask python to retrieve the first
part of
what is stored in test it gives me the
string r in fact it's just one character
r and it's a string so as you can see it
has given me the first character of the
string random which is r so what this
shows is that this string random is
essentially a collection or a sequence
of one character strings so this is so
random is essentially a collection of
the string r the string a the string n
and so on together combined to form the
whole string that we call random
similarly if i wanted the character at
the third position of this thing i would
use well since the third position and
since we're working in python i would
use the index 2 and it should give me
the letter n as you can see it's given
me the letter n so this is how we can
show that strings are also sequences in
python well now let's move on to
certain string operations and functions
that we can perform well as you have
seen already that we can retrieve any
particular character within a
within a string using numeric indexes
well what if we want to know what index
is a particular character at and we can
do it like this we use the index
function so let's say my test and i want
to know where or what position the
character d is in my string random so
this is how i would use the index
function index and within the index say
i'm looking for the character d and now
i it should give me the answer 0 1 2. it
should give me the answer 3. so if i
execute this it gives me the index 3. so
this is
the index function that we can use for
our strings now what if we want to
say slice a string into a into its uh
into a smaller part we want to slice it
and we want to retrieve only that
particular size well here is an example
say i'm gonna i'm gonna use the same
string called random and stored in tests
right so let's
so one way of so the way of doing this
is like this
now let's see what this let's just see
what this does first as you can see it's
given me a and d and if i went to my
string random a and d is this particular
slice now let's try to understand what i
have done by entering one colon for well
what this has done is it's retrieved a
slice
from the first position uh the first
index which is the character a
up until the fourth position which is
the character o but it has not included
o so it's very important when i index
like this every every time i put
something to the right of this colon i
am not including this itself all right
so it's essentially one when i say one
colon four what i'm telling python is
give me the first the second and the
third character but not the fourth one
so it's given me a n and d and it's
that's this is how we do a slicing
operation in python similarly if i were
to say slice
from the first if i wanted only the
first and the second character i would
do this is what i would do
if i wanted the first and the second
character i would do one two three so
this way it says python that i want the
first i want the second but not the
third
off so as you can see i get a and n now
so this is a basic slicing what if i
wanted the portion of a string from a
particular point all the way to the
right or all the way to the left well
let's consider the example of where i
want the portion of the string random
from the say fourth character until the
left well the way i would do this is
test now since i want it all the way to
the left i don't enter any index to the
left of my colon sign and since i want
everything to the left of the fourth
character i enter 4 here so as you can
see it gives me a r a and d which is
everything from the fourth character of
my string random to the left similarly
if i wanted something to the right of it
i would just do it like this i would
enter some index here and i would leave
the portion to the right of the colon
blank so this will give me everything
including the third character since this
is how we treat the uh indexing in
python everything including the third
character all the way to the right so
this is dom as you can see now another
perfectly valid um
slicing is say i want to slice
or take out
different characters from the string but
i want to skip certain characters like i
want this one then i want to skip one
and i want to take the next one and then
i want to skip one well in that case we
have to introduce a step so one way of
doing this is now how do we read this so
as you can see i have written 0 colon 6
colon 2. so what this is telling python
is i want every character from my string
test
starting from the zeroth character up
until the sixth but not including the
sixth after skipping or taking two at a
time taken to a time can also be assumed
as
skipping one at each step or skipping
one character at each step so what this
will do is it will go to random it will
take the zeroth one it will take r and
then it will skip the next one so it
will not consider a and then it will
pick n and then it will not consider d
and then it will consider o up until the
sixth character whichever that may
whichever that may be and if you see the
output it gives us rno which is exactly
what we wanted we wanted r we wanted n
we wanted o where we skipped uh a and d
or we skipped the every second character
essentially so this is the way of um
slicing strings while also skipping
certain characters or skipping
characters and steps now python is also
an uh there's another interesting
technique that we can use in python to
where we can start retrieving characters
from the rightmost side of a sequence or
a string we can use negative indexes so
if i were to for example show you let's
see what this what this gives me test
what what is a minus one index it gives
me the character m now remember our
string is random so minus one gave us
the last character of the string random
which was m so this is a way of using
negative indexes and similarly if i used
test minus 2 it would give me the second
last character which should be the
character o as you can see here now
there are some other important functions
that you may use in python so for that
let's create another let's get another
string let's call it upper
lower all right i'm sorrying it again in
the same variable test let's see what
happens when i use the upper function
and what happens when i use the lower
function
now i'm going to use the lower function
for this
these two functions will respectively
give out or give us the result or give
us our string in uppercase and lowercase
respectively so as you can see the upper
function created the first string in
full upper case and the second one
created this string in full lowercase
now another important and probably one
of the most important methods that we
use for strings especially when it comes
to data science is the split function so
let's see what i mean by split function
let me create another string let's call
it hello world
all right and i'm going to use a split
function and i'm going to see what
happens when i
use this function essentially so what
i'm doing in these in this these three
lines is i'm creating the string hello
world i am storing it in test and then i
am using the split function on the test
and whatever result i get i'm storing
another variable called sliced and then
i'm just going to show you what is in
sliced as you can see what's happened to
the string hello world is that i have
broken it into its components or its
component words if that makes any sense
into hello and world and i've stored
both of these into what we call a list
now you might ask well how does python
know that it has to separate at a blank
space well the split function by default
will
break up a string at its blank spaces
but if we wanted we could break it up
using or add every comma so for example
if i wrote hello world using comma and
if i put a comma inside over here and
now if i try to execute this
like for example i am going to find i'm
going to look for commas in the string
and i'm going to try to split it as you
can see there's no splitting happening i
have one list with my original string
itself because it's not found a comma
what if i introduced a comma over here
now let's see what happens as you can
see the splitting has happened it's
found this comma and it's caused a split
between hello and world similarly if i
in my string if i put this comma again
and i put something else it should give
me the split over there again so we can
define our split using some whatever we
put in between these circle brackets
after the split function it's just
important to note that by default if in
case we do not enter anything over here
it will use blank spaces to do the
splitting
another very important operation and
very common operation in strings is what
we call concatenation so if i have two
strings first and say another string
second
and i want to join these together well
the operator i would use to do this is
called the plus symbol this is the
concatenating operator when it comes to
strings so what is the result of this
let's see let's print this out let's
print this whole thing let's see what is
the result as you can see what this has
done is it has combined the first string
first and the string second into one
string called first second so this is
the concatenated concatenation operator
now finally uh the last topic in this
lesson is the topic of escape sequences
now escape sequences are special
commands that tell python to either
suppress special meaning of some
character or symbol in a string or give
or give the special or give some special
meaning to an otherwise ordinary
character
in a string so let's look at the first
example now remember my in my for
earlier in this video where i was i was
telling you like
what what is the way of writing or how
do we introduce single quotes or double
quotes into a string and i told you the
trick if i want to use a single quote in
my string
i just close it using double quotes or
if i want to use a double quote i close
it using single
well another way of doing this is using
what we call an escape sequence and an
escape sequence in python is the
backslash character all right so let's
see what happens when i use the
backslash character where i want to
introduce my single quote so if i use my
previous example where i wanted to
introduce a single quote and say
i'm going to close it using single
quotes
as well so i'm going to go back to my
error example so as to speak now this
would throw me an error right as you can
see it has thrown me an error so what if
i used the escape sequence that i
mentioned the escape sequence is just
backslash character now this is the
point of the string where i want my my
single quote so i introduce the
backslash now i have my single quote and
i continue writing the rest of my
statement let's close the string now
will this work as you can see this has
worked so what this has done is this
backslash character has told python
to not read this
special character or the single quote do
not treat it specially and let it be as
a part of the string so as you can see
that's what's happened here now the next
case or the other uh use case of escape
sequences is when we want to
give a particular character that is
otherwise just ordinary some special
meaning so
let's take the example of the character
t and the character n we use the
character t to introduce tab space
and we use a character n to introduce
what we call line brick well let's see
by an example so
normally the character t has no special
function
so the character t within a string will
just
be outputted as the characterity itself
however as you can see here i'm going to
introduce a backslash before this
character t
let's see what it does it introduces
this thing that we call a tab space
which is a larger than normal space
similarly if i were to use the
backslash n combination this would
introduce what we call
a line break
and if you were to see the output of
this you can see at the point of the
string where i have this combination of
backslash n a line break has occurred so
uh there are plenty of other escape
sequences that you may choose to learn
and
these are just two of the probably the
most common ones that are used so yeah
this was an introduction into strings in
python in this video i will give you an
introduction into lists and tuples
starting off with lists lists are a
collection of ordered orbit arbitrary
objects that are similar to what we call
an array in other programming languages
but lists are way more flexible when it
comes to python python lists are a type
of sequence and we might have you might
have seen what a sequence is when we
were learning about strings and much
like in sequences or any other sequence
list objects are assigned a numerical
index and whenever you want to uh
manipulate an object in a list we use
its respective index how do we define
lists the lists are defined using square
brackets so this is a simple way
or a simple list that i have just
created and assigned to a variable a
which contains three objects one two and
three let's talk about some of the
features of python lists python lists
are ordered and what this means is that
even if two lists contain the exact same
elements if they if the elements are
placed in a different order the two
lists are actually unique and different
and i can check that over here i have
created a list one two and three and see
if i create another list two
and one and three the same elements were
in different order i will use the is
function to check whether these two
lists are the same and if they are the
same when i use is function it should
give me the value or the answer true and
if they're not the same it should give
me the value false and as you can see i
get the value false because even though
i have two lists with the same elements
they are in different orders and so they
are different and that's what we mean by
lists are ordered the next property for
lists are that they can be manipulated
using their indexes or the elements and
the objects inside a list can be
manipulated using the indexes and we
will see that in the section where i
show you list operations the next
property is lists are mutable what this
means is that once we create a list
object we can actually make changes and
modify them without having to create a
new list object the next property is
that lists are dynamic and what this
means is that as we are making or as we
are programming we can actually make
changes to an already created list as we
are
programming without having to go through
a compilation stage so if we had to say
increase the or we had to add certain
elements to an already created list that
original list grows in size to
accommodate for these new elements the
next property is that lists can
contain any arbitrary objects so if i
created a list right now where
say if i want to store some numbers
say some floating point numbers now and
i can put strings
as well into my list all of these are
valid
when it comes to objects that can be put
inside a list we have no such
restrictions so we can put any arbitrary
objects inside our list the final
property that i want to talk about is
that lists are
they can be nested to any arbitrary
depth what this means is that i can put
a list within a list and i can keep
nesting it essentially by putting as
many lists i want within my list and i'm
only essentially restricted by my
systems memory so if i created a list
like this and within this say i put any
other list and within this list i put
another list i can keep going on to by
keep going on doing this and i'm only
restricted by the memory of my system
that i'm using so moving on let's move
on and talk about some important list
operations that we will be doing when it
comes to lists so let's create a basic
list called a where i'm storing six
numbers so now say if i wanted to
retrieve a particular element say if i
wanted to find out what's on the index
three this is how i would do it if i
wanted a slice of my original list and
much like strings i do it the same way
so what this does is it tells python
that i want all the elements of list a
from index one to index four but not
including index four so it will give me
one two and three index uh objects so it
should give me two three and four in
this case as you can see here two three
and four i can do the same thing by
considering elements say two at a time
if i wanted to consider elements or
consider every second element what i
would do is this syntax i would use this
syntax and when i give this command to
python what it tells what it understands
is i want every element from a
from index 1 to index 4 but not
including index 4 but i am going to
consider 2
every second
element essentially so what it will do
is it will go here
and then it will skip one and then go
here and then skip one and that's
essentially what we uh what it's
essentially what we call start
slicing by using strides so i'm taking
strides i'm not considering elements
consecutively but i'm skipping certain
elements in between if i wanted to
consider every third element i would
change this to three fourth element i
would change this to four alright so
let's see what happens when i take every
second element it should it should give
me uh it will consider say from one to
index three right so it should consider
essentially
this section but since it's going to
skip one it's going to consider this
skip this and then consider this it
should give me two and four as you can
see it has given me two and four and
like in other
sequences we can use negative indexes as
well negative indexing essentially
starts
looking from the right hand side of the
list so when i say a minus one it's
essentially looking at the last element
of the list so it gives me the sixth or
the last element which is the which is
object six if i did a minus two it gives
me the second last element similarly
another neat trick that we can use for
sequences is the following syntax double
colon and we give a minus 1. what this
tells the
what this tells the system is i want the
list a but with all the elements
reversed so as you can see i get my
element
my list a but the elements have been
reversed right now let's move on to
uh concatenation and replication well
concatenation much like in strings is
done by using the plus sign so as we
know on either side of the plus sign
should be two similar objects so if i'm
doing a plus something a being a list on
the other side it should be a list as
well so let's add a list like this
now let's see what's in a
as you can see my original list has
7 8 9 added to it and i can also add
things to the beginning of a list
similarly so if i wanted to add say
zero
you know at the beginning of a list i
just do it like this
and i get the element zero added to it
it's very important to note that i
i i actually added 0 within a list
because if i did 0 like this
it would throw me an error because like
this 0 is just an int object and it's
not a list but when i put the square
brackets i make it a list and then this
concatenation becomes valid because a is
also a list similarly if i did a star 2
this is essentially replication or a
replication function where i'm repeating
the values in a twice if i did a star 3
it's the same function
but now i'll have the elements repeated
thrice as you can see here let's move on
to modifying list values
this also shows the mutable property of
lists that i had mentioned earlier so
let's consider this example so i created
a list with elements where there's three
strings eggs apples and carrots and i
have
five int objects one two three four and
five
now if i wanted to change say the first
element all i have to do is take the
zero width index
and say if i want to replace eggs with
say mango this is how i would do it
now i will replace eggs with mango if i
check what's in b
you can see the eggs have been replaced
with the element mango similarly i can
use the slice syntax to replace
a particular slice from my list with a
slice essentially so let's look at this
um i'm replacing i want to replace the
first three elements i want to replace
mango i want to replace apple and carrot
so what i will do is i will consider
this since this carrot is the
second index so i will consider 0 to 3
because the third is not counted now i'm
going to replace this with three
different um
let's see tv
and say sponge now let's check what's in
b you can see my three elements have
been replaced in fact i don't have to
replace like for like if i want to
replace say three elements with only one
or two elements that is also possible so
now if i want to replace the first three
elements kv orange and sponge
with
just one element this is how i'll do it
let's say
wine
now let's check what's here as you can
see three elements have been replaced
with one mine i can do it vice versa as
well i can replace smaller number of
elements with a larger number of
elements but here there is a slight
caveat that i want to show you so an
obvious way of doing this would be say
if i wanted to replace the first element
wind with three different elements an
obvious way would be just consider that
elements index
and then put whatever objects you want
say i want to add instead of wine i want
to add beer i want to add
ball
and
say
club yeah well let's see what happens
now if i say b
check what's inside my now you can see
my elements have been added but they
seem to have been added as is you know
i had entered a list over here and that
whole list has been replaced
or this vine has been replaced by this
whole list in the first position but
that's not exactly what i wanted i
wanted the elements within this list to
be individually placed into my list and
the way to do that is not this syntax
but actually what i'm going to show you
now if i want to replace one if i want
to replace the index or the object at
index 0 i would give this statement a
slice statement where i will give 0
colon 1 so when i do this and if i
so let's create my old scenario again
where i had 1
and i had 1 2 3 4 and 5. now if i do
this b
zero but i give a slice then this slice
is essentially a single object slice
it's essentially the zeroth index again
but because of this uh formatting or
this this type of syntax that i'm using
what python will do is now when i say
beer
and
ball
and club now what python will do is it
will not consider this whole list and
add it to in place of
wine or whatever i want to replace it
will actually consider the elements
inside of this individually and then
replace so if you see here
now if you see my list i actually have
the
i've removed wine and in place of it
i've put beer ball in club but these
three are actually individual objects
within my list and not objects within a
list that is then placed within my
original list so this is an important
caveat that you should take note of so
moving on let's talk about certain
methods associated to lists let's take a
simple list now one two and three the
first
operation that i want to show you or the
first method is the append method so
when i do a append and say if i want to
append the list by one object called 4
i just do it like this now let's see
what's in a i put so as you can see the
append has put the object 4 into my
original list now say if i wanted to
append
three different objects i want to append
five six and seven now let's see what
append function does
oh no as you can see it's done a similar
operation to what we have seen earlier
when we gave a single index or the
single element replacement
that we saw earlier it essentially put
this whole list into this particular
spot into the list and this is not what
i wanted i wanted 5 6 and 7 to be
individually placed and we do have a way
of doing that and the way to do that is
the extend function that is what i'll
show you next now if i want to extend
say the original list by three different
elements 8 9 10 when i use the extend
function
it will not put this whole thing it will
consider each object inside this thing
individually and then add it to a so if
you see my result this is exactly what i
wanted now the next method that i want
to discuss is the remove method
so the remove method is
what you how you use it is within the
parenthesis you put the
object that is present in the list that
you want to removed so you don't give an
index over here you give the object
itself so if i want the object 8 all
right this number if i want 8 itself
removed what i will do is put the value
8 here and it will remove it from my
list so if i check my list a as you can
see the value 8 has
it's gone a next another similar
function to remove is the pop function
now the pop function by default will
remove the right most value from the
list but unlike remove the pop function
actually outputs a value
and that value is what we have popped
out of the list so by default it will
pop out the right route right most value
of a list or rightmost element of a list
and in this case that element is 10 so
it should give me 10. but of course if
we want to pop out any particular object
in this case we do not give that
particular object we give its index so
now say if i want to remove this
this list object from my bigger list
as i can see it's in index 0 1 2 3 4
it's the fourth index so if i want to
remove the list which is at the fourth
index i give the index value inside the
parenthesis and it pops that out for me
as you can see over here so this was it
for lists let's move on to tuples next
so tuples are another ordered collection
of objects much like lists but they
differ from lists in two key properties
first of all the tuples are defined
using parenthesis instead of square
brackets so this is how i would define a
tuple with elements one two and three
and the next very important property
that is different or that differentiates
tuples from lists is that tuples are
immutable and what this means is that
once we create an object of type tuple
we cannot make any modifications to it
we would have to only create a new
object if we wanted something different
and this is obviously a key difference
between a tuple and a list but apart
from this
every operation that we have done on
lists are actually
possible to do in the case of tuples as
well so any operation that we did to
lists that did not modify the list or
that does not do any modification we can
actually apply to tuples as well so if i
wanted the first element of this dupl
all i have to do is call it by the index
0 it should give me the value 1 as you
can see if i wanted a slice
i can do that as well it should give me
2 and 3. and if i wanted to reverse my
tuple well i can use my same neat
technique that i've used for lists and
that i can use for the sequence i mean
strings as well so it gives me my old
tuple but with the elements reversed so
now the natural question is why do we
use tuples over list well one important
difference is that when we con when we
make a program execution where or where
we are manipulating a tuple if we did
the same thing for the exact same
objects in uh that if it were present in
a list
it would be much faster in a tuple
essentially program execution is just
faster on tuples when compared to an
identical list so we use tuples over
lists when we want to be efficient while
we're creating an ordered list of
objects so whenever we create an ordered
list of objects that we don't need to or
we don't want to make any further
modifications to we don't need to create
a list we can create a tuple and another
very important area where we use tuples
over list or why we need a tuple instead
of a list is when we are using
dictionaries dictionaries as we will see
later is a data type in python that
needs an immutable component
while we are creating the dictionary so
if we
want to use uh something that is like a
list but since lists are mutable we can
use a tuple instead and use that when we
are creating our dictionary and we will
see like what uh what i mean by uh the
immutable component for a dictionary
when we actually
learn about dictionaries but yeah these
are some of the places where we would
use a tuple over a list a brief section
on tuple unpacking and packing is what i
would be doing right now and what that
means is that when i create when i give
this sort of a statement
you can assume this to be
me packing this tuple into a object or a
variable t now what's very interesting
is and this is something that's very key
to tuples is that i can unpack a tuple
onto another tuple so let me show you
what i mean by that so now that i have
packed one two three and four tuple into
t let's unpack it into another tuple
let's call this let's
put these elements into this tuple and i
put this into t alright now let's see
what i mean by unpacking something onto
something let's see what's uh what what
what happens when i put a if i just want
to see what's in a it actually gives me
the value 1 if i see what's in b it
gives me the value 2. if i see what's in
3 giving value 3 and d gives me value 4.
so essentially if you think of it what i
have done is i have matched this tuple
then put it into t and then put that
tuple t into this tuple a b and c d so
what it's what what has happened
essentially is the element a has been um
or a better way to say this would be the
element 1 has been packed onto or
unpacked onto a 2 has been unpacked onto
b 3 has been unpacked onto c 4 has been
unpacked onto d to show you what i've
done in a single line is essentially
this
this is essentially what i've done
i have assigned 1 to a 2 to b 3 to c 4
to d i have matched these two tuples
together like this and this is a very
neat feature of tuples the only only
important thing that you have to keep in
mind is the elements of this tuple and
the elements on this tuple
should be equal so if there are four
elements here there should be four
elements here all right i in fact
another very important thing about or a
neat feature is that we don't really
need to mention the parenthesis when
we're doing this uh unpacking or packing
so if i did x comma y comma z if i did
it like this if i put say five and six
and seven this is also a valid way of
packing and unpacking so now if i see
what's the value in x it is actually
five if i see what's the value in y it
is 6. if i see what is the value of x
and
z it should give me a tuple containing 5
and 7 as you can see over here so this
is a neat feature of tuples called
packing and unpacking so yeah in this
video we will cover concepts surrounding
dictionaries dictionaries are another
type of composite data type in python
that are also a collection of objects
much like tuples and lists and like
lists they are also mutable dynamic and
can be nested however a key difference
and property of dictionaries is that
they are unordered items in dictionaries
are paired using keys unlike in lists
and tuples where the objects are
assigned numerical indexes to define a
dictionary we use curly braces each key
value pair in this dictionary in a
dictionary is separated using commas and
the key and values themselves in a pair
are separated using a colon let's look
at an example this is a dictionary where
i have three key value pairs as you can
see they have been separated by colons
and each of the pair themselves are
separated by commas and these are
enclosed in curly braces to define the
whole dictionary in this
example
these are the keys banana apple and
grape and their respective values are
yellow red and green so this is very
important that in this particular
data type we have what we call a key and
that key is assigned a value and we can
have multiple such pairings and we have
three such pairs in this particular
example another example or the or
another type of way to define a
dictionary is using the dict function
this is how we use it as you can see i
have
inputted two value or two object tuples
this is a tuple this is a tuple and this
is a tuple and when i use it in a dict
function
when i place it within a list what
python will do is it will consider the
first element of each tuple as a key
and
the second element of each tuple as its
respective value
now if i check what's in d as you can
see the key banana has a value yellow
the key apple has a value red the key
grape has a value green this is another
way of defining dictionaries
an important
note over here is that
the
the objects that we use for keys have to
be of an immutable data type so we
cannot use for example lists
as an example of keys but we can use say
integers or strings for our dictionary
keys also keys have to be unique when it
comes to a dictionary you cannot have
two different keys with
or should i say the same key having two
different values you can have only one
key and that one key will have a unique
value assigned to it duplicate keys are
not allowed however when we speak about
values we have no such restrictions you
can have a mutable or an immutable data
type as a value in a dictionary and you
can have duplicates as well so if i
created a dictionary with a key say
banana
and if i gave if i associated with it
a value green i cannot create
another key banana and associate
a value yellow let's see what happens
when i actually do this if you actually
see
what has happened here is python has
considered the second case so it's it
first looks at the first pair it goes
okay so my dictionary has a key banana
with a value green but right after it
sees another key banana with the value
yellow so it overwrites my first key
banana with the second key and it
overrides the first value green with the
second value and we essentially get one
key banana with the second value yellow
so obviously this is a python does this
to avoid duplicacies however if i
created a dictionary with a key banana
again
if i created i gave it a value yellow or
say green
if i created another
key and if i gave this also a value
green this is perfectly fine and this
will not
nothing special will happen in this case
because values do not have to follow
such rules let's speak or let's see
certain dictionary operation operations
and functions now so let's
bring back our original dictionary which
we had created earlier with the three
pairs all right so what if i wanted to
we can use keys to
essentially do these operations and
functions let's see what happens when we
so much like how we use sequence how we
use indexes in example of sequences we
use keys when it comes to dictionary so
let's see what happens when we use a key
over here
so we actually know banana is a key in
this dictionary let's see what happens
when we do where we give this command it
actually gives the value associated with
that key which is yellow what if we
wanted to change a particular value
associated to a particular key i would
give i would do this i would give the
key and assign it
the value that i want to change it with
all right now if i check my dictionary
you can see the key banana no more has
yellow value but the value gold what if
i wanted to add a new pair you know a
new key with a new value completely i
would do it pretty much the same same
way as i did in the previous step i
would
essentially write my new key whatever i
wanted say if i wanted a new key called
watermelon i would assign it a value
red
and now if i check my dictionary at the
end of the dictionary you will see that
my
new key pair key value pair has been
added watermelon red as you can see over
here now what if i wanted to remove if i
wanted to remove a key value pair from
my dictionary i can use the delete
function which is
called by using this the del function
now how do i do it say if i want to
remove the key value apple in red so all
i have to do is do l
d and within square brackets i have to
only mention the key i don't even need
to mention the value just the key so
you can probably draw parallels in how
we use indexes when it comes to lists
and tuples and even strings and how we
use keys when it comes to dictionaries
they are quite similar so if i did this
and if i um oops i think red is actually
not a key as you can see red is a value
my
key is apple actually it's not red it's
apple as you can see now if i see my
dictionary the key apple and its value
red has been removed so these are some
of the operations that we can do
for dictionaries using keys what if we
wanted to use certain inbuilt functions
that are associated with dictionaries
well some of the examples are as follows
there is a get function when we use the
get function all we have to do is
enter a key inside the parent thesis and
it will get the value associated with
that key so if i gave the key great
let's see what value is associated with
it as you can see it's green
there is also a function called items
that returns the key and value pairs in
our dictionary as a list of two object
tuples where the first object is
the
key and the second object is a tuple so
let's see what it does as you can see it
gave me a
list and in this list the
objects inside the list are two object
tuples where the first object is always
the key and the second is the value and
it's the same for each of the tuples so
this is what items function does let's
see what
the next so the next function is keys
let's see what the keys function does as
you can see it returns a list of all the
unique keys within our list i mean
within our dictionary similarly we can
there is a function for values as well
and as you can see it returns all of the
different values that are present in our
dictionary in the form of a list also
it's important to note that if we have a
particular value that has occurred
multiple times in a dictionary it will
appear as many times it has occurred in
the dictionary or appeared in the
dictionary in our list over here when we
use the value function so if say
a particular value say i had another key
where its value was green again so i
would have the value green appear in
this list once more essentially our next
function is pop item what this does is
much like the
pop function in list
it gives us the last entered
key value pair that is present in our
dictionary so the last centered pair was
watermelon
key watermelon with the value red and
that's what has popped out when we give
this function another important function
associated with dictionaries is the
update function and the update function
is a very neat function that is used to
merge two dictionaries together so say
if i had a dictionary let's say i'm
creating a dictionary
using the dict function where
i have say
some key called key v so as i had
mentioned i will use two object tuples
in this case and
let's say i give this also a value green
all right and another
pair would be
say mango and
let's give it a value yellow
all right so this is another dictionary
that we have created as you can see over
here we have created a dictionary with
the key called kiwi with value green and
another key mango with the value yellow
and i already have a dictionary d with
uh these values all right now if i want
to merge these two dictionaries i can
use the update function what i do is say
if i want to merge d with x or x with d
only the ordering will change and that
doesn't really matter when it comes to
dictionaries so if i want to merge d
with x i use d update and then inside it
i put my target dictionary now when i
check what's in d i have
the
the the dictionary x and its key value
pairs
merged inside my original dictionary d
as you can see i have my original ones
here and i have the merged ones over
here so this was the update function in
this brief video i will explain what we
call the
type hierarchy or the standard type
hierarchy and python it's also known as
the data model in python and it probably
has other names so essentially in the
what we do or what we speak about in
this is
how the different types that we use in
python
are categorized and classified and what
are their subtypes so it's important to
note before we continue further that
they're in future versions of python
there might be new types that are
introduced or the existing ones may be
modified but it's safe to say that
what i will speak about in this video
will still form the core of what we call
python standard type hierarchy so let's
begin so the first type is the nun type
it's accessed through the built-in name
none its truth value is false it's
essentially used to denote
functions or it's you it's returned as
the value for functions that don't
really return anything so if you have an
expression or a function that returns no
particular value you actually get a data
type called none that is how python
interprets it
then there is the ellipses ellipsis is
something that you might encounter later
it is accessed through the built-in name
ellipsis
it is used to indicate the presence of
this particular
syntax this particular symbol or
expression
or syntax in a slice its truth value is
true again don't worry too much about
ellipses right now next is numbers and
numbers is something that we are very
familiar with we have seen we work with
numbers a lot they are an immutable type
they are created through numeric
literals and they are the outputs of
arithmetic expressions and built-in
arithmetic functions its subtypes are
integers floating point numbers and
complex numbers
within integers you have plane integers
that represent numbers in the range
this number and this number so this this
number is basically the largest positive
value that you can represent using 32
bit notation in two's complement and
this is the equivalent
for the the negative the negative side
long integers on the other hand are used
to represent numbers in an unlimited
range that is only subject to the
available memory of your system so these
are two types of integers and as we know
floating point numbers represent machine
level double precision floating point
numbers or numbers with a decimal point
and a component after that complex
numbers are numbers that contain a
floating point number that represents a
real part and a floating point number
that represents a an imaginary part so
these are the types of numbers then we
have sequences sequences are finite
ordered sets indexed
by natural numbers so each element in a
sequence has an index and that index is
a natural number the different types of
sequences are based on the mutability
whether the objects can be changed or
not is essentially what we mean by
mutability right once we create an
object whether we can modify it or not
and that is how we differentiate
different types of sequences so there
are
mutable and there are immutable types
now the different types of immutable
ones are strings we know what strings
are they are sequences that contain
characters unicode is the other
immutable sequence and then there are
tuples tuples are a collection of
arbitrary python objects and unicodes
are
sequences that contain unicode
characters then we have mutable
sequences and
there is only one currently there is
only one built-in
mutable sequence in python and that is
lists
lists are also again collection of
arbitrary python objects
finally we have well not finally but
next we have mappings and mappings are
again
sets of
objects but these objects are now
indexed using arbitrary
index sets you know the difference
between a mapping and a sequence you
could consider
sequences are ordered but mappings are
not ordered and
the indexes given to the objects and
sequences are always numbers they're
natural numbers whereas in mappings they
are not natural numbers but they are
certain arbitrary objects that we can
set for ourselves again in python there
is only one built in standard
mapping type of objects indexed by
nearly arbitrary values the only
condition is uh so what i have mentioned
until now are probably the most common
data types that available types such as
user-defined functions user-defined
methods built-in functions built-in
methods classes and class instances so
again callable types as a whole are
referenced using the call function and
this is something that we will learn
when we start learning about functions
when we learn about object oriented
programming
and methods and functions and such the
other type are modules so modules are
module objects or modules essentially
are referenced or called using the
import function again modules can be
considered as these large
libraries or larger pieces of code or
applications that we
that contain various different methods
and functions and objects and classes
within them
again modules are something that we will
think about a little later files are
data types that are called using the
open function so anytime we and as we
will during the course of this uh
tutorial we
or during the course of this uh
this course essentially we will be
working with a lot of files these some
of these files are text files some of
them are comma separated files so all of
these files that we open using uh the
function open or some other certain
specific functions where we create file
objects out of these files these are
what we call file data types
finally there are internal types that
are used by python interpreter again
this is something that
does not concern us right now but just
know that
the interpreter for python uses these
data types for its functioning so into
python
type hierarchy in this video i will show
you some of the categories of operations
that are possible in python so let's
start off so the first category of
operations are arithmetic operations and
as you can see in this table there are
different types such as addition
subtraction multiplication so let's go
over them one by one so a simple
addition operation would be like 5 plus
6 giving me the value 11. i can do 5
minus 3 that's subtraction similarly i
can do a multiplication using five say
five into two there's division where i
use the backslash so say i did division
of eight divided by two now you might
encounter another type of division which
is called the floor division where we
use a double backslash and what this
does is it returns us the largest whole
number that is lesser than the result of
our division uh so the division
difference between the float division
and and the normal floored and
the floor division or the single and the
double backslash is this say i did 9
divided by 2 using a single backslash it
should give me as you can see 4.5 right
so this is the actual value now let's
see what happens when i do 9 double
backslash 2. it will give me 4 which is
the largest number lesser than or equal
to 4.5 that is also a whole number so
this is what we call flow division
essentially finally we also have
if we want to raise something to the
power of something so if i want to do 5
i'll say 6 raised to the power 3 so i
would use double asterisks and this is
how i would do it it give me 216 as you
can see if i wanted remainder between
the division between two different
numbers i will use the percentage sign
so if i wanted the remainder of the
division between seven and three this is
how i would do it i get the answer one
as you can see the next category of
operations are logical operations the
first one is the logical and operation
where we use the operator end all right
so let's see
what we mean by this i am creating so as
we know the and operation returns the
value true if both the operands are true
so
that's actually let's actually do this
for an example let's give this variable
the value true and this the value of
false actually should be done like this
false so now uh think of it like 1 and
0. so one and zero is obviously zero
right so if i did a
and
b i should get the answer false or zero
because i'm doing true and false so it's
like doing one and zero so if you see
this i should get the answer false if i
change this to true as well now if i do
this i will get the answer true as you
can see
the next logical operation is the or
operation where
well
logical or is if either of the operands
are true then we should get the
answer to our order operation as true as
well so in this case obviously if i did
or over here it will naturally give us
true if i change this to false
it should again give us true and it will
only give us false if both are false as
you can see here now it's false the next
operation is the logical not uh it's
done by using the not operator so in
this case the
value that we get
is true if the operand is false so let's
take a as we know a is false over here
so if i did not a i should get the
answer true but if i change this to true
now if i do not a i should get false as
you can see so this was the
logical operations let's move on to the
next set of operations that is
comparison operations so there are a
bunch of them let's go over them one by
one if i want to check if two operands
are equal so if i did x is say equal to
two and now y is equal to three if i
want to check if they are equal i will
use the double equals to sign and if um
they are equal i will get the value true
if they aren't it'll get value false as
you can see since x is 2 and y is 3 as
you can see x and y are not the same so
there's false they are not equal if i
change this also to 2 now i will get the
answer to another the next comparison is
the
not equal to or where we use the
exclamation sign so over here this is
this
the result of this is true if x and y
are not actually it's the same so i
should get false over here as you can
see but if i change this to say 5 now i
will get true because x is not equal to
y in this case the next one is greater
than so if i did x greater than y as we
can see 2 is not greater than 5 i will
get false over here similarly there is a
lesser than if i did x lesser than y i
should get true over here as you can see
well there's also a
greater than or equal to and lesser than
or equal to we simply add the equal to
sign here so let's see now if i say x is
less than or equal to 3 i should get
true because x is 2.
and if i put 2 here i should also get 2
but what if i put 1 here since x is
equal to 2 and 2 is not less than equal
to 1 this is a false statement and i can
do the same thing with like this using
the greater than equal to now it's true
because 2 is actually greater than equal
to 1. and so this was comparison
operations the next set of operations
that we can do in python are assignment
operations we've already seen a whole
bunch we've already been assigning
values to variables we've been doing
assignments throughout already but let's
go over them and see some of the
assignment operations so as we already
know the equal to operation is assigning
everything that is on the or the value
on the right hand side of the equal to
sign to what is on the left so if i did
a is equal to 5 plus 6 it will assign
the value 5 plus 6 or 11 to a let's
check what's in a as you can see it is
11. there is a plus equal to sign and
what this does is so for example if i
did
say a now since a is 11 let's create
another variable called b and call this
5 all right so now if i did a plus equal
to b what this will do is it will add b
to a and then store it in a so let's see
what this does once i do this now let's
check what's in a it should be 5 plus 11
as you can see 16. so this a plus this
is this plus equal to sign is
essentially the same as doing a is equal
to a plus b it's essentially the same
thing they're both the same uh there's a
similar thing for this the negative sim
or subtraction as well minus equal to so
now that a is 16 and b is still 5 of
course if i did minus equal to b now i'm
subtracting the value 5 from 16. so i
should get a is equal to 11 again as you
can see here and this is the equivalent
of doing a minus b a is equal to a minus
b i mean as you can see so
uh the next similar like assignment
operation let's create a is equal to say
6 in this case and say b is equal to
i will say 2 all right now if i do a
star
star equal to b what this does is it
multiplies b to a and then assigns it
back to a so if i see what's in a now it
should be 12 as you can see here
similarly there is similar thing for
subtraction as well so if i did a is
equal to 6 and b is equal to 2 and if i
did a sorry for division so if i did a
division symbol and equal to sign and
then if i give b what it will do is it
will divide a by b or 6 by 2 and it will
assign that back to a so my value on a
should be 3 as you can see here 3.0
obviously this is a single
uh single backslash so this is a float
division the resultant of a single
backslash is always a float i can do the
same thing with a double backslash so
let's see if i did a is equal to seven
now and then b is equal to three now
if i did a double backslash equal to b
now it will do the same division
but uh it will do a floor function so it
should give me two in this case if i did
the same thing
with a single backslash just to show you
the difference between single backslash
and double backslash division in this
case it will give me um
the value around 2.3 or something a
float basically 2.33 as you can see here
then there is the
modulus you can use the modulus sign as
well with this assignment um say a is
equal to say 5 now b is equal to 2 now
if i do a percentage symbol equal to 2 i
mean the it should give me it will
assign the uh it will take the modulus
in both sides and then assign it to the
left hand operand now let's see what's
in a as you can see it it did uh a
divided by two the modulus symbol is
basically the remainder of the division
between two objects so in this case it
will divide a by b and then give me the
remainder and then put that remainder
back in a and as you can see the
remainder of 5 divided by 2 is 1 and we
get that over here similarly we can also
do exponential so if i have a is equal
to say
5 b is equal to 2 and i want to raise a
by if i wanted to raise the value of a
by the value of b and then store that
back in a this is how i would do it
so it should be 5 to the power 2 which
is 25 as you can see here so this is
assignment operations so finally we move
on to
uh two special sets of operators one is
the identity set identity operators and
the other is the membership operators
let's look at the identity operators so
when we talk about identity operators
what we when what we mean is the is and
the is not operator so what the is
operator does is it checks whether two
operands
have the same location in the memory
essentially this does not mean that it
does not check for whether two objects
have the same value and this is very
important so let's look at this if a is
equal to 1001
and b is equal to 1000 plus 1 all right
if i did a is equal to this is an
equality check are they the same values
true now if i say a is b let's see what
happens as you can see it's false this
is because this object and this object
are not the same and this is what the is
operation does
we can confirm this by checking the id
of a the id of a gives us some value
like this and the id of b gives us as
you can see a different value so the two
objects are not located in the same
place in the memory as we have seen
using the id function and that is what
we check uh through the is operator and
the is not is essentially just the
opposite of that so so that is the
identity operator now the membership
operator is used for checking whether
something is present in a sequence or
not so let's create a sequence i will
create a list to
show in this example my list is one two
and three basically simple list with
three integer objects one two and three
i will check whether now say two in a so
is two in a if it is it will give me
true as you can see is 5 in a it should
give me false because 5 is not in a and
the a not in operator is just the
opposite of that it checks the other
condition essentially so this is the
membership operators in python in this
video i will be speaking about what
precedence or what importance each
operator has when you use multiple of
them in a particular statement or a
command this is what we call operator
precedence so of course there is
confusion when we don't know which
operator has precedence over the other
and in python there is a strict
precedence that is followed in such
scenarios so this table gives us the
precedence so as we can see the
the operators at the top are at the
lowest precedence and as we go down we
get operators with higher precedence
over the ones above them so the low of
the operators that we have seen the all
operator the and and the not have the
lowest precedence so
or and not and then we have comparisons
and identity operators such as the equal
to equal to sign the the exclamation
equal to sign so these operators come at
the next level then you have addition
and subtraction followed by
multiplication division modulus and flow
division and finally the highest
precedence of all the operators that we
have seen till now is the exponentiation
or the double asterisks so let's see a
couple of examples that explain this
point a little more so as we can see in
this line we have 20 plus then there's a
5 an asterisk 3 minus 25 and we want to
know like okay what is the precedence in
this case so as we know we have the plus
sign we have a minus sign and we have
the asterisk sign so we have addition
subtraction and multiplication so which
one will take precedence over the other
well let's refer to this table as you
can see the addition and subtraction
have lesser precedence over
multiplication so this multiplication
will happen first so we actually do 5
into 3 first we get 15 after that we do
plus and minus so we get 5 into 3 15
then we add it or we can subtract it
over 25 that does not matter so we do 5
into 3 15 and then we do 20 plus 15
which is 35 minus 25 so
we should get an answer 10 as you can
see we do get the answer uncertain
another
example would be
where we have this plus symbol we have a
double asterisk talking which shows
exponentiation and a subtraction and a
division so again as we know
exponentiation has the highest
precedence so in this whole operation or
this whole expression we first
do uh the operation associated with the
exponential so we do 5 to the power 2 or
5 exponential exponentiated by the power
2. so we have 5 to the power 2 which is
25 now we look at okay once we have that
we still have a addition and we still
have a subtraction and we still have a
division symbol and as we know division
takes precedence over addition and
subtraction over here so once we do this
we finally move on to this step where we
do the division of 6 divided by 2 where
we get 3 so we have 25 from this 5 to
the power 2 which is 25 and we have 3
over here so now we do 20 plus 25 which
is 45 minus 3 which is 42 and then as
you can see that is the answer over here
let's look at um the precedences when it
comes to certain of the certain um
comparisons or
the logical operations or the comparison
operations so as to speak so i've
created a variable called season with
the string summer i have created the
variable age with the value
with the string 10 so you don't need to
put it in a string so i have the into
object 10 and i have the color uh a
variable called color with the string
pink now i'm going to see in this line
i'm going to do an if and else statement
so if you don't know what an fns
statement is just follow along with me
so what this does is if this condition
is met i will print this statement
otherwise else i will print this
statement now what is this first
condition it is saying season equal to
equal to summer whether this variable is
equal to the string value or as we know
about the or operation age is equal to
this and color is equal to equal to pink
so as we can see in our
comparisons
and our logical operations the
precedence for or and and not is or is
the lowest precedence uh and is above
that and then not is above that in this
we have the or and we have the and so of
course the first check is the and
function so it's going to check whether
this whole condition and this condition
are
it's going to it's going to do that
operation so it's going to do this and
this so is color pink color is indeed
pink okay so this this part is true now
let's see if this part is true as well
now once we're going to check whether
this is true or not what we need to see
is this condition itself has an oil
statement so the first part of it is
saying is season summer season is indeed
somewhere as you can see here next part
is saying is age greater than zero but
this does not matter since the or
function just needs one of the operands
to be true and in this case this is true
in this case it is also true so this is
this whole statement is true as well so
once we have this statement as true and
then this statement is true
we can we finally move on to we come
back to this and statement and we say
since both the operations or both the
operands i mean are true the resultant
of this and should also be true and
since this is true this whole condition
we actually move into this section of
our ins if else condition where we say
okay we can
do this statement this print statement
and we do not have to print this
particular thing so
our answer should be our result should
be the uh printing of this string this
string okay and as you can see the ok
string is actually what is printed over
here so this is
an example on operator precedence of
course it's it always helps to
you know try to fiddle around on your
own uh
create random expressions out of like
out of the top of your head and see how
exactly python is evaluating that and
try to understand break it break it down
on your own and this is probably the
best practice you can do to understand
operator precedence in this video we
will be looking at the math module in
python and we will look at some of the
math functions that are associated with
this module in python so starting off
what is this math module well the python
map module is an important library or a
feature that is uh designed to deal with
mathematical operations this math module
is part of the
basic python installation so you don't
have to install this separately
to use this math module all you have to
do is import this module and this is how
you would do it you just do import
math and this will import your math
module for you to use in your
programming and in this in the course of
this video i will be showing you certain
um concepts surrounding the math module
such as what are the constants that come
with the mass module some of the
arithmetic functions the logarithmic
functions
power functions and even trigonometric
function that we can do using this math
model and the function inside the math
module so starting off let's look at
some of the constants that are part of
this so as you can see
the standard constants are available uh
in this module are pi there is tau there
is euler's number nan which is a special
it's a it's a programming specific
concept and infinity uh so let's look at
this one by one so starting off our
first constant is pi um
pi is as you know in maths it's the
ratio of the of a circle's circumference
to its diameter and
pi is an irrational number you know the
value of pi is 3.14 something since it's
an irrational number it does not we
cannot define it in terms of a specific
fraction but it can be approximated to
the fraction 22 by 7. so how do we
access this
pi constant is as simple as this once
you have imported maths uh the maths
module all you have to do is do match.pi
and it will give you the value as you
can see so as you can see the value
returned to us is a float this is
important to note and the number of
number of decimal digits uh the number
of digits after the decimal point that
we can see here are 15 and this is like
a by default uh thing for python that if
you call the pi constant it will give
you the value of pi correct up to 15
decimal points so an example of where we
can use this thing is say we have the
radius of a circle three it can be in n
units three meters or whatever you want
and you want to find out its
say circumference so as we know the
circumference of a circle is 2 pi r so
if i had to find the
circumference of a circle in my say my
code for some application with the
radius 3 or all i would have to do is
use the formula 2 pi r and to call the
value 2 pi r instead of specifically
writing 3.14 or something i can just use
this function math
dot pi over here and then i can enter
the r as you can see it will return me
the radius as you can see so moving on
uh the next constant that we will talk
about is tau tau is similar to pi
in fact tau is the ratio of a
circle circumference to its radius pi is
the ratio of a circle's circumference to
its diameter and tau is the ratio of a
circle's circumference to its radius so
important to note this difference so
because of this definition tau is always
two times the value of pi this is by
definition and
much like pi if you call the tau
constant in
you from the math module it will also
return you a float number and
to find that this is the function that
we use or this is the syntax so as you
can see this is this is actually 2 times
the value of pi 6.283 and even this is
returned correct up to 15
places to the right of the decimal point
and this is by default uh next constant
is the euler's number
the uls number is a it's one of the most
widespread constants used in the world
of sci uh in the scientific community in
mathematical community um you will be
using the uh euler's number probably a
lot as uh if if you move into data
science or ai or something like that so
what is the euler's number it is uh it
is the
base of the natural logarithm if you
know what the natural algorithm is it is
used to calculate rates of growth or
rates of decay and as with numbers or
constants like pi and tau even the
euler's number is an irrational number
with infinite decimal places uh the
value of
the euler's number in short it's denoted
by the small letter e so this value of e
is
usually approximated to around 2.718 so
how do we call this
constant is simply as math dot e
this is how we do it so you get this
value again this is also a float and
it's correct up to 15 decimal places so
the next concept that we will be talking
about is infinity now infinity is a it's
more of a mathematical concept and this
is very important to note because
infinity doesn't is not really a number
there is no number called infinity it is
it is used to define something that is
infinitely large or infinitely small so
positive infinity something that
is higher than any known number to us
and a negative infinity is lower than
any known number to us
so this is the concept of infinity and
how do we call this uh function well so
let's see what happens when we call the
math function math constant infinity so
this is how we do it and as you can see
it will return us this uh it might look
like a string to you but this is
actually a special type in python um
which is not a string this is also a
float it's a type of a float in fact
this uh infinity value it's it's a it's
like a special data type it's a special
data type that you can
you can consider as an equivalent to a
float but um it's not it's not a typical
float that we know like you know 3.14 or
2.71 the value of
will give us um inf and this is this inf
is actually not a
string so we can we can confirm that
over here as you can see when i do a
type when i check the type you see it's
actually a float in fact this was
recently added in python 3.5
a special type known as math dot inf um
it returns this inf data type
which is the equivalent wave float
so this is this is how we use infinity
if you wanted to get the value of say
minus infinity all you would have to do
is math dot inf with a minus sign
preceding this constant and you will get
minus inf now let's check if
the concepts or the properties of
infinity are maintained you know like
every a positive infinity is greater
than any number that we know and
negative infinity is greater than any
number that we know so let's just
confirm this um so i'll take math throat
in and i will do a check
is this greater than
say some really large number something
that comes off the top of my head
immediately okay so let's see if it's if
this is true then
this is conceptually correct and as you
can see it is true in fact i can change
this number to anything as large as i
want this will be true because infinity
is true is larger than any number that
we know uh and similarly if i did minus
math dot in
inf uh and i checked some very small
number you know a very very small
negative number so just consider some
minus uh 10 to the power something right
this should also be true uh sorry it
should be a smaller sign symbol this
should also be true because i'm checking
minus infinity smaller than any node
number to us and it is true as you can
see so
uh it's very uh also if you did uh if
you did something like so let's say if
we do
let's add something to this you know
it's a number so we should be able to do
arithmetic on this let's actually see
what happens when i add say 10 to
positive infinity it actually gives us
the same value back infinity because uh
intuitively we know that infinity plus
anything is still going to be infinity
right and this is exactly what python
does for us even if we add a number to
this the math dot inf or the infinity
constant in python it will still give us
uh the same value the same data type of
inf or infinity similarly if we
subtracted something from the negative
of math.inf you know um say minus say
again let's say minus 100 so if you
subtract something from minus infinity
we're technically still minus infinity
itself so this will again give us my s
and then my minus inf as you can see and
this is absolutely what we need and this
is a very very interesting feature in
python finally the last
constant that we will discuss is the nan
or the not a number constant so this is
not really a mathematical constant
there is no constant in maths called not
a number this is a computer science
related concept that
it's used to
is used to
denote invalid inputs or in it's used to
indicate
a certain places where say a variable
that should have a
number
it's been corrupted for whatever reason
and it it now has a text or a symbol and
our code throws an error then in these
in these cases where
python expects a number from us or from
your code and it does not get it it will
throw you a nan
value and this is usually used in cases
where you have errors in your code so
again just to check like what this this
constant like how to call it this is how
you actually do it math.nan and it will
give you a data type called nan also
much like the infinity constant let's
see what's the type of this um this
constant again might look like a string
to you but of course this is not a
string this is a
numerical concept and as you can see
it's still a float so this is like um
it's another special uh data type that
was created for specifically this case
where it's some it's the equivalent of a
float but um it's not really the typical
float that we are that we associate with
so this is a constants in the math
module so our next topic will be
arithmetic functions that we can do in
the
using the math modules so some of the
common arithmetic functions that are
available to us are factorials the
ceiling operation floor operation
there's permutations as combinations you
can find the greatest common divisor or
the gcd and the lcm or the least common
multiple and you can truncate numbers so
let's look at them one by one so
starting off with the factorial
operation the factorial operation is
done using the factorial function as you
can see here actually defined like this
math dot factorial all right so now what
we pass in between the parenthesis will
be uh what we calculate the factorial
for
as you know factorial is so factorial is
always for a positive integer and the
factorial for say a number 10 would mean
10 times 9 times 8 times 7 so on until
the number 1. obviously factors are only
defined for positive integers it is not
defined for negative values or it's uh
and it's also not defined for decimal
values so let's see let's look at an
example so as we know um so let's say we
pass
math dot factorial for six and let's see
what's the value so
this is exactly what we expect so we
expect the value of 6 times 5 times 4
times 3 times 2
that is actually 720. let's see what
happens when we pass 0
this should give us 1 since we know 0
factorial is 1. now let's see an error
case where we pass say minus five as you
can see this will throw us an error
because factorials are not defined for
negative numbers now moving on let's uh
so the next function that we'll talk
about is the ceiling function so the
ceiling function is defined using math
dot see
seal as you see here so again we pass
the number that we want the ceiling for
in between the parenthesis so what is
the sealing function it gives you the
largest uh sorry excuse me it gives you
the smallest number
that is uh greater than or equal to what
we pass over here so
for an example if i gave you 6.6 and i
asked you okay what is the ceiling
function for 6.6 it should give you 7
because 7 is the largest integer in
integral value that is greater than 6.6
or equal to it obviously if you give the
ceiling function for an integer it will
give you the integer itself so let's
look at an example 7.8 so this should
give me the value 8 as you can see here
let's look at another negative number so
minus 12.3 uh an integer that is greater
than minus 12.3 uh is minus 12. the
smallest integer that is greater than
minus 12.3 and this should give you 12
as you can minus 12 as you can see here
a similar function is the floor function
which is defined like this
again the floor function what it does it
gives you the greatest number that is
smaller than
whatever value we pass between the
parenthesis so if i gave it 2.3 it
should give me the value 2. um again if
we pass integers it will uh just give us
the integer itself again it is to
reiterate this ceiling and floor
functions uh they give you int in
integer values so the floor function
will give you the largest integer that
is smaller than what we pass over here
so let's look at 6.7 so the largest
integer that is smaller than 6.7 is 6
and as you can see this is our answer
over here
the next function that we will look at
is the truncate function
the truncated function is defined using
this truncate is very similar to what we
have seen this is how we define the
truncate function uh it is very similar
to the ceiling and floor uh in the
truncate function what we do is um we
pass a decimal value a float number to
the between between the parenthesis and
what we get back is the number without
the decimal component so only the
integral component so if i give it 7.8
for example it will give me only the
seventh part it will return me only the
seventh part and it will chop away the
point eight part um if i give it minus
twelve point three uh it will chop away
the 0.3 part and give me only minus 12
back so let's look at an example 8.9 it
should give me only 8 as you can see
here see i did minus 8
or minus 6.9
this will give me minus 6. so you can
think of truncate function as
it does the floor function for positive
values and it does the ceiling function
for negative values because it rounds
down and rounds up respectively for
positive and negative values so now
let's look at the next set of arithmetic
functions um let's move on to
permutations permutations are defined
using this as you know so in between the
parentheses i have to pass two values n
and k so i have to pass n n and a k
the k has to be less than or equal to n
because the permutation as you know is
uh the number of ways in which we can
permute
from n objects k tie uh k different
objects so what this mathematically what
this is is um permutation of n and k is
n factorial divided by n minus k
factorial so if i pass say 10 and 6 it
will give me the permutation of 10 and
6. so let's look at what's the value as
you can see it's a very large value
15 150 1200
similarly there is a combination
function and this is a combination of
permutations are used a lot in
probability so if you're going to move
into that sphere which you will
encounter a lot in
machine learning ai you will be using
these functions quite a bit um so the
combination function again you pass an n
and a k again the n should be greater
than or equal to this k what this
evaluates is n factorial divided by n
minus k factorial times k factorial so
again this is a mathematical concept so
let's look at the permutation sorry the
combination of 10 and six so as you can
see it gives me 210 which is the
combination of 10 seconds in the
arithmetic function section
are gcd and lcm as we know gcd is the
greatest common divisor lcm is least
common multiple so as of the newest
version of python in three point python
3.9 the math module gets these two new
functions that were very lately added
actually
since i i cannot show you that because i
don't have the absolute latest version
of python on my system but using the
math dot gcd function this is a function
and in between this we would what we
would do if we had the latest version is
we would pass two numbers or as many
numbers in fact and what this function
would do is find the common divisor
amongst them so if i gave these say for
example if i gave these numbers it would
give me the value 10. similarly the lcm
function again added in the python 3.9
finds the common multiple amongst
whatever we pass over here so if i
passed say 20 and 30 this will give me
uh the value of 60 which is the sim of
20 and 30. so again these are it's
something neat that if you say you have
python 3.9 or
if you have python 3.9 or after that
you will have access to these functions
as well if you when you import the math
module so that was for the arithmetic uh
functions let's move on to the next
section which are power and logarithmic
logarithmic functions so let's start off
with the power function
there are two there are uh multiple ways
you know you can actually do a power
function in math in python so you can do
something like this which is the
equivalent of 2 to the power 3 or you
can use the inbuilt uh module math and
you can use the
pow or the power function which is this
is how you do it and if i had to do same
2 to the power 3 i would just pass 2 and
3 as arguments like this and it should
give me the value as you can see 8 over
here what if
so there's actually one more function
which is simply the pow function and
this is uh not part of the math module
it's a function not part of the math
module but it's still part of the
base python you use this as well and you
can do the same thing vow 2 and 3 it
should give you the value 8 again the
now you might ask what's the difference
between these two functions well it's
not much for at least in a beginner's
standpoint it's not that much just note
that the math dot
power function is slightly
computationally faster than the simple
power function so yeah moving on their
next topic would be the next function
that we'll discuss is the exponential
function which is defined like this
again exponential function is again e to
the power something so if i did
exponential of 3 uh this would give me e
to the power 3. as you can see oh of
course i did not define the module
beforehand so math.exp now when i do
this it should it'll give me some value
which is basically euler's number or e
to the power 3. so this was the
exponential function and let's look at
an example so we will look at the
example of rate of decay and we will use
the uh this function in that example so
the exponential rate of decay um
for uh is used to calculate the amount
of radioactive elements that is present
in a substance after a certain amount of
time so the the
the the the expression is uh something
like the initial amount of radioactive
elements that were present
right at the beginning times the
exponent of minus 693 times t
t for time divided by the time period
the half lifetime uh so let's just write
it down to make it simple so again as
you can see the uh so this will give me
the remaining amount of radioactive
elements right so let's uh let's write
down the remaining let's assign this to
a variable remaining so the initial
again
um initial is the initial amount of
radioactive elements so let's give it
some value say 100 um
the time let's assume it's 10 years
and let's say the half-life
half-life
is
around i don't know let's give some
value say 3 or something again this is
the details are not important so this
will i'm using the math.exponential
function over here as you can see and
for these values uh now when i check
what's the value of remaining after i
calculated it it's something so this is
it's basically what this tells me is
that i started off with 100 units of
some radioactive element
and in 10 years this is what is left so
yeah so this is how we would use say the
exponential functions in a particular
example of ours so next
next type of again
functions are logarithmic functions so
let's look at some of the logarithmic
functions that are part of the math
module so basic log function would be
written like this math.log in between
this i would pass the number that i want
the log for by default if i just pass
one number it will it will calculate the
log of 8 to the base of e as we know e
is the euler's number so let's see what
it does in this case it gives me some
value what if i wanted to specify a
particular base well i would pass a
second argument in this case i want to
find the log of 8 to the base 2 this
should be the value 3 as you can see
over here
there are two specific functions that
are also provided in this math module
that is log 2.
what this will do is again it will again
i have to just pass one argument and
this will automatically find the value
of the log of 8 to the base 2 as you can
see here
similarly there is a math dot log 10
function if i give if i did this i will
find the value of uh something here to
the base 10 as you can see so this was a
logarithmic functions then you have the
finally you have the square root
function so how would we use the math uh
the square root function is math.sqrr
again we pass the what we want over here
if you want the square root of say
49 this should give me the value 7 as
you can see finally maybe move on to the
final set of functions that we can do
using this math module they are
trigonometric functions and they are
hyperbolic functions so
let's start off with some of the
trigonometric functions as we know
we can do sine we can do cosine and tan
some of the basic functions
the way we would do it is math dot sign
in between this what we this is to
calculate the sign of a particular
angle and this angle must be passed in
radians this is very important to note
we do not pass it in degrees but in
radians so if i say past
sine of
3.14 as we know 3.14 is an approximation
of the value pi
my sine pi is
supposed to be
in fact it's supposed to be zero so
let's see we get something close to zero
again since this is an approximation it
won't give us the exact value
similarly we can use math dot cos to
find the value of a particular angle
if you want to find uh if you want to
find the value of the sorry the cost of
a particular angle we can use the tan
function in case
we wanted to find the tan similarly uh
we have the next set for arc sine and
the arc cosines of
certain of angles so to use to find the
arc sine for example we would use a dot
sine i mean sorry a sine
for our cosine we would use this and for
r10 we would use this the next set would
be hyperbolic functions again hyperbolic
functions are
basically the sine and the cosine and
the tine calculated not circles but on
hyperbolas
again the details don't have to be you
don't have to know the details you just
should you should know that if we wanted
to say for example find out the uh
hyperbolic sign of an a of an angle we
would use math dot
sign h
and we would pass what we wanted between
this similarly if you wanted to find the
cosine it would be cos such uh tan it
would be tan h and if we wanted to find
the inverse of uh the hyperbolic inverse
what we would do is what we would do is
use a so we would use a tan h if you
wanted to find the hyperbolic inverse
of sine we would use a sine h and
similarly for cos it would be cos
a cos h so this concludes our video on
the math module in python and some of
the math functions surrounding this in
this video we will learn about
conditional statements
and we will learn about how do we create
these control structures
where we have these conditional
statements uh we will learn about the
keywords that we use in python to create
a conditional statement block the if
keyword the lf keyword and the else
keyword we will also learn about
indentation and its importance in python
so let's get started so the basic uh
syntax if you will for a if statement in
python consists of the keyword if
followed by an expression as you can see
from this pictorial if there's an if
statement there is a expression
there is this block of code which if you
can actually see is slightly indented to
the rest of the code
and then we have the rest of the rest of
our code after that so what we're
looking at is this so this is our if
statement block um now let's let's break
this down so what is this expression
that we are speaking of uh an expression
in this context is a boolean expression
which evaluates to a true or false
statement so when we are speaking about
the if statement we have an expression
and if this expression evaluates to true
then we execute everything below the if
statement otherwise we skip that portion
as you can see if the statement is true
we execute this statement or these
statement blocks
otherwise if it's false we move on to
the next the next statement block or the
beginning of a new statement so let's
look at an example to further understand
this let's take this if statement over
here as you can see in this if statement
i have this expression 50 greater than
30 so what python is going to do now is
it's going to check whether 50 is
greater than 30 and it's going to check
in a boolean context if this is true
then we can move on to the next portion
which is this but if it is false then we
will skip this so let's see what this
what happens over here so since we know
that 50 is indeed greater than 30 this
is a true expression we move on to this
block of code which is saying that print
50 is indeed a larger number than 30. so
let's see if this actually gets printed
so as you can see we get this the result
which is this is a true statement and we
get our print statement getting executed
what if we give a false expression over
here so let's look at uh what happens if
i give a false expression now i'm
checking if 50 is lesser than 30 which
is a false statement so if it's a false
statement we do not move on to this
portion of our if statement block and we
we directly in fact we directly skip so
if i have to execute this you will see
nothing gets executed in fact my print
statement is just not executed because
we never entered this because our
expression over here was indeed false so
yeah this is how a basic if statement
block looks like in python and this is
how the uh how we move on to how we
check for the true the truth
truthfulness or the falseness of a
particular expression in the if
statement so moving on um let's move on
to the topic of indentation in um in
python so as you can see
this uh this if statement is an example
of a control structure so without moving
without defining what a construct
control structure is
in detail control structures consist of
these conditionals or loops or
iterations if you will
so all of these control structures
involve heavy indentation so what does
an indentation mean well what if i gave
you an example say i gave you some
variable called h and i wrote 20 over
here now if i give you an if statement
saying if age is greater than 10. now uh
it's very important to note that when
i'm defining an if statement i need this
colon otherwise this if statement is not
defined so this colon is important uh
anyways so now i'm checking this
expression if age is greater than 10.
now what is this
what happens if h is greater than 10 now
what if i want python to do something
only if age is greater than 10 well how
do i tell python that there is a piece
of code
or a section of code that i want
executed only if this condition is met
well this is where indentation comes
into play so if i want say if i want
this line
this person is an adult again this is
some random line where i'm assuming ages
pertaining to this adult all right or
this person so
if i have uh this variable age where i
write this number 20 which denotes the
age of some person and i'm doing a check
if age is greater than 10. actually
let's be specific here well the adult
age for most people is 18 in most
countries so let's see if age is greater
than 18. now if i'm doing this check uh
i want to print this statement only if
this person is a person's age is above
20 above 18. so how do i tell python
that i only want this statement to be
executed only during this if this
condition is met well this is where
indentation comes into play as you can
see exactly as you can see uh this part
this portion of the code is slightly
indented compared to the if statement so
when this condition is met then only do
we move on to this if this condition is
not met we move on to whatever the next
section of code will be like whatever
whatever
code that we have after this if
statement so let's see so this since
this condition is actually met as you
can see this print statement is actually
executed so this is the importance of
indentation now we will see uh in as we
move as we learn more about if
statements and else statements and lf
statements how indentation plays a key
role in defining what we want as an
output when a certain condition is met
all right so for now it's very important
to understand that this is how
indentation is used in python in other
languages we might use uh we probably
don't use indentation in fact popular
language the c language uh does not use
indentation at all but some languages
and python and probably the trademark
language for indentation and programming
so you might say that yeah so different
people have different opinions on an
indentation the general consensus is
that indentation helps make the code
look very presentable and very readable
and this actually is one of the facets
of python programming is the indentation
and the easy readability of it anyways
moving on so what if we have um multiple
conditions in our code or if in our if
statement block that we want to see so
let's create this
list or let's actually just copy this
example that i have written over here as
you can see what i'm doing in this piece
of code is i have a list x where i have
this integer 50 i have two strings cat
and apple now i want to check a bunch of
things so i want to check if 60 is an x
and i also want to check if the string
cat is an x
and i
want a final sort of like if none of
these conditions are met i want
something to happen so how do we do that
well we start off our state our if
statement block with the standard if
keyword all right now if we have uh one
more condition that we want met then we
can use the l if which
is kind of a short form for else if uh
so we use the l if keyword so it so what
this python
what python reads is it checks this
condition then it will check this
condition and then finally we have this
else keyword and else is the keyword
used in our block to tell python that if
none of our earlier expressions have
been true then do uh what is in the uh
that is within the else keyword that is
indented within the s keyword so
again we don't pass an expression for
else because else is uh only we only
reach this l as statement in case all of
the other earlier conditions have not
been met or have uh come to be false and
not true so let's look at uh this
particular example so we have a list of
50 cat and apple and i'm my first
expression that i'm checking is
is 60 in x so this is how we check
actually so if 60 and x should be read
as is 60 in the list x so is this 16
elix list x well actually no we don't
have the object 60 so this part is not
executed we move on to the next
condition is the string cat in x well
actually it is
the string cat is indeed in x so we move
on to this statement block which is
within the condition that is met which
is print cat is in list x and you will
see that none of the other statement
blocks will be executed because we have
met our condition over here so if i
execute this as you can see that the
print statement cat is in list x is what
is actually executed and we do not uh
execute this obviously because it is
false and we do not even check or we do
not even move on to the statement
because well we have a condition met
over here so it's a one thing that is
important to note is that we can use as
many elif statements to check for as
many conditions that we we want to check
for
but it's very important that we only use
and if we are using that we only use one
else statement and only at the end of
our block okay so moving on now i'm
going to show you a very neat example
about how python actually does its uh
these these condition checkings so it's
very important to note that once a
condition is met none of the other
conditions are even checked for so
we do not even consider the next
statements and we directly leave this if
statement block so let's look at this
example over here now in this example
that i have over here is where i've
stored the string cat in x now i have
three um i have three conditions that
i'm checking i'm checking is 50 greater
than 60 i am checking if the value of x
is indeed cat and i'm checking i'm some
random expression 1 divided by 0. this
is not even a check this is literally
just checking if 1 divided by 0 is true
or false and as we know we cannot divide
anything by 0. so let's see what happens
when i execute this statement now
typically if i wrote 1 divided by 0
python will throw me an error because 1
cannot be divided by 0 that is an error
error in a statement so let's see what
happens when i do this actually as you
can see i have a statement being printed
but i have no error even though i gave a
wrong i gave an errand statement in 1
divided by 0. well now you might ask why
is that so well it's simply because i
have actually never reached this
condition i have not even
python has not bothered looking at this
because if you actually see there is a
condition previous to this uh over here
which is met and which is true so we
move on to this block we execute this
block and we forget about the rest of
the code so we don't actually get to uh
this erroneous statement which is an
interesting thing and which is an
example that i have shown uh to show you
that once a condition is met in an if
statement block we do not look at any of
the further conditions that are being
checked okay so finally um i have one uh
one small topic that i would like to
share with you is the conditional
expressions or the pythons ternary
operator now this is slightly different
to the if statement that we have talked
about up until now
in the sense that it is not a control
structure so what this actually is is
more of an operator that defines some
expression so let's see what i'm trying
to say over here so as you can see over
here highlighted is the
syntax for what i'm trying to talk about
this ternary operator so let's look at
this example and let's see what i'm
trying to do over here so i have this
variable age all right and this age is
26. now x now just just read this
statement x is equal to adult if age is
greater than 18 else child now i could
have done an elaborate control structure
with an if statement and an indentation
within that if statement and then
i could have written else and then
another indentation and i would have
written another statement over there but
instead of that i have used this
operator to assign a particular value to
the variable x and this
what value i'm assigning to x depends on
if this condition is true or false so
as you can see the condition says is age
greater than 18. so if this is true then
i assign this particular string if it is
false then i go to the else statement
and i assign this so since age 26 is
greater than 18 i should assign the
string adult to x and as you can see if
i execute this and check what is in x
you can see adult is indeed an x so this
is a very neat a very needable readable
and a very um
it's a it's probably a more it's a
better looking way
to perform simple else uh some simple if
and else statements where you don't want
to create a whole
if stay if else statement control
structure block so yeah this was the
ternary operator finally we let's uh we
make a short note on the path statement
uh in python so the path statement or
the past keyword is a
a place where it is a placeholder of
sorts so what if i had an if statement
and i'm writing a piece of code but i
don't know what to do with this if
statement so if if a statement is
correct if a statement is true um but i
don't know what to do if this statement
was true
how do i tell python well let's just
keep it a hold for now and i might
put something into this block later in
the future well i would use the pass
statement so if i had this uh say the
sum condition again so i'm checking age
is greater than 18 but i don't know what
to do with this i would just simply use
this pass statement and uh this
basically does nothing uh it it's a way
to it's like a way to create a
placeholder where maybe in the future i
might have i might write some sort of a
say a print statement or some sort of a
different function or something else
within this indentation so but in the
meantime like currently i don't have
anything to place over here so i just
leave it with a pass statement so this
is a way where you can use a pass
statement in um if and as statement or
infinite control structures so yeah this
was a uh basic or the an introduction
into conditional statements and uh the
control structure uh of if and l
statements in python in this video we
will be doing a small exercise on if
statements just to drive home the point
or the purpose of an if statement we
will be doing a small exercise so let's
first revise some of the concepts of an
if statement so basic if statement can
be something like this we have a small
condition where we're checking if a
variable x is greater than 5 or not and
if it is greater than x we print a
statement over here so if this condition
is met we print this statement else we
move to this statement block now our
variable x has the value 5. now since x
is not greater than 5 what this will do
is it will check the statement and since
this will be false we skip the statement
block and move on to this multiple
statements we use the l if statement in
such a case so
x is equal to 5 or if x is greater than
5 and then finally if both of these
conditions are not met we say else and
we print whatever or we do whatever is
in this particular statement block which
is a simple print statement so as you
can see x is indeed good is equal to 5
so this is the block that will get
executed as you can see here now another
example are nested if statements so
nested if else statements are if
statements within if else statements so
let's look at an exalty and the string
is fresh now we have an integer or a
float in this case 4.0 stored in orange
price now our first statement is
checking whether orange quality the
variable orange quality is it equal to
the string fresh now within that if the
statement or if this condition is met we
do another check where we're checking
what is the price is it lesser than 5 if
it is we do this block else we execute
this block finally if our initial
statement our initial condition is not
met we move on to this else block now
when i execute this what should happen
is i will enter this block because this
is true and finally i will enter this
block because this condition is also
true so i should have this printed i
will buy five dozens as you can see here
now let's move on to our main exercise
for this video so this was all just a
revision now we're going to use some or
all of these concepts in a sample
project or a sample exercise
to for your further practice
so in this exercise what we're going to
do is we're going to request the user to
enter a number between 1 and 20 and our
our code is going to check whether this
number entered is an even number of code
the first check is going to be whether
the number that is entered is between 1
1 and 20 we have to move on to the
further checks which is whether it is an
even or an odd number so let's see how
we do that so in this piece of code what
we start with is a print statement
saying please enter a number between 1
and 20 and then we add an input command
this input command will open a box where
we can enter whatever number that we
want to enter
now we use this in keyword to make sure
that whatever we have entered into the
input box is stored as a int data type
in the enter num variable
once we do that our first if statement
is going to check whether the entered
number is greater than or equal to 1 or
less than equal to 20. sorry and less
than equal to 20. so both of these
conditions have to be met if this
condition is true then we have a valid
input and this statement is printed that
we have entered a valid number and then
we move on to the rest of the statement
block within this if statement which is
another set of if and else if statements
if our number is not between 120 we move
to this block and this block prints that
we have entered an invalid number now
once we have say entered a valid number
we move on to this block this is in
if else
if elif statement block now what this
block is checking is whether by two one
leaves the remainder zero when divided
by two so this is what this check is
doing if this check is true that means
our number is even and we get printed
that our number is even the other other
check or the other
if statement is checking whether it's
here and we get printed your number is
odd so let's execute this and see what
happens when we enter a number
now it's asking me to enter a number
let's say i enter 17.
now that i have entered 17 as you can
see it's a valid number that i have
entered and the code is telling me that
my number is indeed odd let's look at
some other what if i entered something
else here let's say if i enter 16 now
since it's an even number as you can see
16 is also a valid number as it's
between 1 and 20 and my number is even
and the code checks for that let's see
if i what happens when i enter an
invalid number let's say 25 now i enter
25 as you can see it has not met and i
have moved on to the statement block so
to give you a breakdown as to when i
enter 9 the first check that happens of
course is this check and in this block
is checking whether our number is
divisible by 2 or not recap into the if
statement and if else statements
necessary file statements the other
video we will be i will introduce you to
the concept of iterations in python and
we will so let's look at what an
iteration means an iteration is uh
executing the same block of code over
and over potentially many times a
programming structure that implements an
iteration is called a loop now in
programming we have two types of
iterations definite and indefinite
iterations and in this example we will
be speaking about indefinite iterations
indefinite iterations in python is the
while loop where we use the while
keyword to define an indefinite
iteration so let's look at the basic
syntax as you can see this is the basic
syntax where we have the while keyword
followed by an expression and again the
colon and below that is something
indented again we encounter indentations
just like in fl statements a set of
statements where
what happens here is following the while
keyword we have this expression where
this expression is evaluated in and if
it is true we
execute all the statements or the
statement block that is indented below
this file statement now this is another
example of control structure much like
if any statement blocks where we use a
lot of indentation so let's look at a
basic example now of while loop so let's
copy this example and let's see what
this does so i have a variable n where i
am assigning it a value 0. this is
called an initializing process and it's
very important to note that most while
loops consist of an expression which
contains a variable a control variable
uh which
is usually initialized prior to starting
the loop and then this control variable
is typically very modified somewhere
within the
main loop body so in this case my
control variable is n and i am
initializing it by assigning it the
value 0 so let's uh move into the loop
now so the loop has this while keyword
as you can see followed by a uh an
expression n lesser than or equal to
five now what this is is an expression
which is going to check if it's true or
false is n lesser than or equal to five
and as long as this expression is true
we will continue doing whatever is
indented below this while statement and
what is below this while statement is a
print statement first of all which says
value of n is and it basically prints
the value of n in that particular
iteration and as you can see this uh
compound assignment where we add the
value of n
by 1 and we assign it back to n so what
this is let's see what this does
actually let's execute this and see what
this does uh important to note the value
of n again is initialized at zero so
this while low five so as you can see i
have the execution of this
particular block of code or this while
loop where i get the
multiple different iterations of this
print statement that you can see here
the first iteration it says value of n
is 0 then it's the value of n is one
what i'm doing is i am writing i am
assign i'm writing uh the value of n
multiple times uh and each time the
value of n is written over here based on
what iteration it is so what is
happening actually is that initially
value of n is 0 and i print the
statement value of n is 0. now i add
the value of what is in n by 1. so now
what is the value of n so again we do
this check so after this first iteration
we
come back like once this whole
block of code is executed we again come
back to this expression and we again
check if this statement is true so now
that the value of n is actually one
this statement is still true so again we
execute this and that you can see over
here value of n is one now again we add
the value of n by one and again we go
back here once this uh this block is
executed and we check if the statement
is true again and as you can see the
value of n when it's 2 is still
making sure that this expression is true
and this keeps happening until the value
of n is greater than 5 so we do not
execute the statement because this
expression evaluates to false and we do
not do this anymore and we finally leave
our while loop so let's check what the
value of n is just to confirm this as
you can see the value of n is indeed 6
and that is why we have left this while
loop over here so this is an example of
a basic while loop where we check for
this
an expression if it evaluates to true we
evaluate everything within it once this
is done we go back and we evaluate this
expression again if it is again true we
again go back into whatever is indented
within it and we keep doing this until
the expression gives us false and
interestingly we don't we don't
necessarily have to define these control
variables always we can actually use uh
iterables and we will learn about
iterables actually in a future video but
we can use iterables and an example of
an iterable is uh the list so let's look
at this list and let's look at this
whole block all right so i created this
list a which contains five objects one
two three four and five all integer
objects and i have another variable x
where i store the integer one now i'm
this while statement now it might look
confusing now it's it says it says while
a now what is a well a is not uh your
typical expression where you're making
sure if some condition is being met or
not but this the way you read this is
while a exists so in the context of a
list as long as a which is a list
contains objects within it a is true if
it does not have any objects within it a
is false so while a basically what it
means is while a has objects within it
and if it does have objects within it or
as long as it does we continue executing
whatever is indented within this while
statement and this y statement is a
print statement again we uh do like we
we have this value x where we um we're
doing this this we're printing this is
iteration number and
we pass x so the first iteration
obviously pass x is equal to one and
then we add x by one and then the second
iteration should pass this iteration
number two and then so on and finally we
have another statement within this block
called the a called the pop statement
where we're popping the elements of a
now as if you would have seen the list
the video and list the pop statement
removes the right most value
from a list so if i do a dot pop
initially it will remove 5 from this
list and i will have the rest of them
again if i do pop it will remove four
from this list and then you will have
the rest of these so let's actually see
we'll actually check what's left in this
list each time we do this pop statement
so that i'll also print the list
a each uh during each iteration and
let's see what happens over here as you
can see what is happening out here is
while a or while a has elements we are
going to continue doing this y statement
whatever is within it so in the first
iteration obviously we have all of it uh
and it is iteration number one and as
you can see the list contains everything
then i pop it then iteration number two
it again has elements but it has lost
its most rightmost element and this
keeps on happening until the list
finally has no elements left and once
element or events the list has no
elements left we this expression while a
evaluates to false and we do not execute
this anymore and we leave the while loop
and again let's check what is in a a
should have no elements as you can see
it's an empty list when i check what's
in a it's an empty list and that is why
while a returned near false and we did
not print any further so this is an
example of using a while statement using
lists
and of course the next topic would be
discussing nested while loops and um
this is a broad topic what i mean by
this is that when when i'm saying nested
while loops i'm actually talking about
nested control structures so we can have
while loops within while loops not only
that we can have if anders statements
within while loops we can have while
loops within if and else statements and
we can have if and l statements within
if and l statements so if you think of
all of these loops
and we will even speak about for loops
in the in the in in in another video for
loops again are a type of control
structure so all of these are control
structures while loops are control
structures for loops or control
structures if and l statements or
control structures all of these are
control structures and nesting can
happen within them and it does not
matter
which is the like the parent of the nest
and then the child or the nest we can
have a while loop within an if and a
statement you can have for loops within
a while loop all of this is valid in
python and uh it's one of the one of the
great features of python that is very
flexible in this way so let's look at an
example where i have a while loop within
another while loop so i'm copying this
piece of code where i have this list one
two three four five and another list
first and second now my first while loop
i print i print what is popped from a so
i take a then i pop the zeroth index so
basically from the left hand side and i
print what is that all right and then i
have another while loop where i have
this list b and i'm doing the same thing
but this while loop is within the first
while loop and let's see what happens
out here so as you can see my first uh
my first iteration of this parent while
loop causes me to pop what is the first
element which is one then i do these
while loops and this is completely
executed and only then do i go back to
this first one and then i come back and
do all of this again then i go back to
this one and then i come back and do all
of this again and that's why you can see
this repetition so i have this first
iteration and then i do uh the second
while loop then i have the second
iteration and then i do the second while
loop and i keep doing this and this is
an example of a nested while loop okay
so our next topic in this section this
video would be break and continue
statements now break in continue
statements are ways to abruptly end
iterations uh in in a particular loop
you can use break in continue statements
not only in while loop but you can use
it and also in for loops so let's look
at how we use it in while loops and
let's look at what we mean by breaking
continuous statements first of all well
the break statement terminates the loop
entirely so once the break statement is
found the the complete while loop that
we are using is completely terminated
and the continuous statement on the
other hand terminates only the current
loop iteration and it goes back to the
beginning or the expression and it
checks whether uh the expression or the
uh the controlling expression is again
reevaluated and it is checked whether uh
the loop will execute again or terminate
this pictorial that you can see here
actually emphasizes or it shows the
difference between break and continue so
i have this while loop and i have an
expression all right i have a bunch of
statements and i have a break command
over here and have a continue command
over here so if i encounter the break
command it will not execute any of this
in fact it will not execute this while
statement at all and it will move on to
the next piece of code that we have but
a continuous statement if a continuous
statement is encountered in while loop
will not completely break away but it
will not uh it will not execute the the
rest of the statements in that iteration
only these two but it will go back here
it will check this expression again and
again we will do this all over again so
this is this small uh difference between
the break and continue statements but
both are used to abruptly end an
iteration in a loop so let's look at an
example of how we use the break
statement so i will use this example
where i have again i have initialized
some controlling variable n to zero uh
my first loop will check whether n is
less than equal to five if this is true
then i will now in my previous my
earlier example using a similar uh using
the similar example uh i had no like
this this part was not there so what you
got was i was printing the value of n so
it was printing as like value of n is
one i mean zero and then one and then
two and then three four and five but
over here i've included a small i've
nested an if statement and within that i
put a break statement and this if
statement is checking if if n is equal
to let's see what happens now as you can
see once
so when i have executed this i don't get
the whole value of n is 0 and then 1 and
then 2 3 4
i i stop at one and that is because once
n is equal to two i actually do not
execute this while loop again i do not
go back and execute print value of n is
two now in fact i break from this whole
while loop and my while loop terminates
right then and there and that's why you
only get these two iterations value of n
is zero and then value of n is one okay
so now i'm going to show you a neat
example of what happens or what is the
difference between a break and a
continuous statement okay so let's uh go
back to our initial example where we're
printing this value of n is 0 1 2 3 4
and so on but i've added one more
statement where i print hello at each
iteration so let's see what happens when
i do this as you can see it will print
hello after each of whatever i was doing
already now let's introduce our break
statement first of all so when i do
break well let's
go back to this if statement if
if we check this condition then we break
let's see what happens now as you can
see something interesting has happened
where we have this first iteration
completely being executed but the second
iteration kind of stops where there's no
hello and that is because we have broken
from this while loop before the second
iterations hello was printed let's see
the difference between a break and
continue now so now i have this
continuous statement instead of a break
let's see what happens here as you can
see it seems familiar to our first
example where we did not have any break
or continue but there is a small
difference that i want you to catch and
that is very important about this
continue statement so as you can see the
first iteration has value of n is 0 and
then hello the value of n is 1 but there
is no hello and this is because and this
is because once this condition is
actually met we do not move on to this
statement but we go back to this
expression and we will evaluate this
expression and then once we evaluate
this expression again and it's found to
be correct we do everything the same
again where we print hello but except
for that one step where this if
statement was met and we did continue
and this following statement was not
executed and that happens only for one
iteration and that is when n is equal to
equal to two and as you can see that is
what happens over here in one of the
iterations we may say hello and that is
the difference of the continue statement
between uh there is a difference of the
continued statement with the break
statement so this concludes it for our
video on indefinite iterations this
video we will be looking at three
examples where we are using while loops
along with other stuff like say if and
if statements so our first example will
be where we calculate the factorial of a
number in this example as you can see
here we are first going to ask the user
to enter a particular number for us now
this number is supposed to be an integer
once we have this integer we store it to
a variable called number now we have
this you can say this
variable called fac which does one and
you we will see how we are using it
later now we know that the factorial of
zero is one that's how it's just defined
so we have an if statement checking
whether our entered number is 0 and if
it is 0 we say that the result is 1 or
the factorial is 1. however if we enter
a number that is greater than 0 we must
calculate the factorial for this number
and that is what we are going to do in
this else statement block over here now
in this else statement block we have a
while loop in this while loop the
condition is checking
while number is greater than or equal to
1 so as long as this condition is true
everything within that while loop will
be executed so as long as number is
greater than equal to 1 we are going to
execute these two lines now what do
these two lines do let us see so the
first line takes the variable fac where
we had the number one stored and we're
going to store fac times number into it
number being the number that we have
inputted so in case for example we
we entered 8 then what this will do this
line will do is 1 into eight and it will
store that back into fac now once that
is done we move on to the next line
where we are decrementing the number
variable by one so if we have stored
eight or we have entered eight into our
input it will become seven now as we
know 7 is still greater than equal to 1
so this condition is still being met and
then we do this process again where we
are going to multiply fac this time fac
stores the value 8 and we multiply times
the new number which is seven now so we
do eight into seven and then again we
decrement this uh also once we do eight
into seven we store it back into fac and
we keep doing this where we keep
multiplying eight times seven and then
we decrement the number variable by 1
and then we check this condition again
so what ends up happening is we are
going to keep doing 8 into 7 into 6 into
5 into 4 into 3 into 2 into 1 and once
we are at 1 again when we do this
decrement operation the number variable
will store the value 0 and then this
condition will no longer be met so
number will be 0 and this condition will
be false and we can move out of this
while loop then finally we store the
result into a variable called result
which stores the result of 8 into 7 into
6 into 5 into 4 into 3 into 2 into 1.
this is of course if we did enter 8 when
we were asked to give an input so let's
see this um in real time once we execute
this so i'm executing this the first
thing it asks me is to enter a number so
let's say i enter my number eight as i
was speaking about eight all right now
that i've entered eight as you can see
the result that it gives me is factorial
of eight is four zero three two zero
which is correct and you can check this
for yourself where it will show you um
eight times seven or eight factorial is
basically this this number okay so now
in our next example we will be looking
at how we can generate fibonacci numbers
for this example we will be using bunch
of if and else if statements along with
a while loop so let's look at this piece
of code where we are actually doing this
so as you can see the first part of the
code is basically an input statement
asking us how many fibonacci numbers we
would like to generate and then the user
would be asked to give an input which is
stored as an int into a variable count
now in this uh if statement the first
if statement checks whether what we have
entered is 0 in which case we just store
an empty array in the variable called
fib next if our
entered integer is 1 we just store the
value 1 in this array called fib
if our entered number is 2 we store 1
and 1 in the array fib all of these are
different sets of fibonacci sequences
this obviously an empty an empty array
shows that well there is no numbers to
be generated in this sequence if we have
one we just print the first number of
the fibonacci sequence which is one
itself if it is two we print the first
two numbers which is 1 and 1. now
the actual calculations happen when we
say we want a fibonacci sequence for
more than two numbers now in that case
we move on to this block in this
statement block we initialize the fib
variable with the first two fibonacci
numbers one and one and we store in this
very in this array now we are going to
do a while loop within this and in this
while loop we we're going to keep
executing this statement block as long
as this condition is met or this
condition is true and what this
condition is is it's checking this
variable i which we have initialized as
1 over here and we're going to check
whether that is lesser than count minus
1 count being the number that we have
been asked to input if the statement is
true and as long as the statement is
true we will be executing the statement
block which is basically us appending
this expression into the array fib now
what this expression is is basically
it's going to keep adding uh each
subsequent numbers and we're going to
store each subsequent numbers back into
the
array fib so in this case if you see the
what the first step will do is it will
take the value at the first position of
the array film and it will add it to the
value at the zeroth position of the
array fib and both of these values since
they are one and one when we add them we
get two and we append that to fib so now
our fib will look like one comma one
comma two then we increment this by one
and what we do is we
do the same process again so in the next
step what would be what we would do is
we would do two plus one so we would get
three now this would keep going on until
this condition is met or basically until
uh the numbers that we actually want to
generate in our sequence so let's like
let's let's uh execute this and let's
see an example of what happens so it
asks me how many fibonacci numbers i
would like to generate and i will say i
want the first let's say six fibonacci
numbers so i execute this as you can see
this gives me the first six numbers in
the sequence which is one and one and
then two which is basically one plus one
and then three which is one plus two and
then five which is two plus three eight
which is 3 plus 5. so if we wanted more
numbers we would just enter over here
like say if we wanted the first 10
numbers it would give us
the first 10 numbers in the sequence as
you can see here now in our next example
what we are going to do is we are going
to write a program which takes two
digits that represent the dimensions of
an array for example if we want a three
by three array we will enter three comma
three and we are going to generate a two
dimensional array in which each of the
elements of the array are basically the
row times the column position of that
particular element and what i mean by
this is say we have a position i comma j
on the array the value of the
element at that position would be i
times j so for example if i'm looking at
something at the third row and the fifth
column or say the third row and the
third column for example the value of
the element would be three times three
and if i'm looking at something at the
second row and the fourth column i am
going to do two times four so let's uh
let's see how we can do this using code
so if you look to the right over here i
have a piece of code where i'm going to
in where it asks me to input two numbers
two integers to represent the dimensions
of my
example my sample array now once we have
done this we are going to store these uh
these uh
dimensions in the
inputs
in a variable called input string so
obviously when we enter say five comma
five that will be stored as an in in
this particular string or this variable
what we want is we want
5 say we enter 5 comma 5 we want 5 as a
separate integer and the other 5 as
another separate integer and that is
what we do in this particular statement
where we're going to split up our input
string
based on the comma separator and we're
going to store the first part of that
string into the zeroth position of
dimensions which is an array and the
next dimension in the first position in
this particular array now
we are going to store the number of rows
as row number and that is the zeroth
position of this array and we are going
to store the number of columns as the
first position of dimensions or whatever
we've mentioned in the input so now we
we have this um our results array called
multi-list which is basically
what what our final array is going to
look like and we're going to store into
multi-list and
in this example we will be using for
loops to
do this or to create this particular
array so as you can see here our first
we have initialized our multi-list
saying that um we're going to have only
zeros in our sample array so initially
once we have initialized this array all
multi-list will contain is a say for
example we have inputted a 5x5 array it
will have basically a 5x5 array with all
elements as 0 and that's what this line
does once we have done this we are going
to move on to the for loop portion where
we are actually going to create our
array that we want so as you can see we
are our first for loop is going to say
for row in range row number so obviously
uh range will generate a
an iterator which can be iterated over
um and since it says range row number
and say our the number of rows that we
entered were five what it's going to do
is it's going to create an iterator
containing the value 0 1 2 3 and 4. so
for row and range it will basically
basically row will take the value 0 1 2
3 and 4. and a similar thing is going to
happen in this nested for loop which is
within this where we're going to again
uh create a an iterator using this range
function and for the column number once
we have this we're going to do the
simple process of
multiplying the uh the value of the
element based on its position so if it's
at the position 3 comma 4 we're going to
store the value 3 times 4 into that
particular position of the array and
we're going to do this for every
position which is what happens in these
two for loops we're going to first go by
each row and then within that we're
going to check each column and we're
going to perform these calculations and
finally we print our result so let's
look at an example now i'm going to say
i want a 3 by let's say a two by four
matrix so let's see what the results
will be when i give this as uh so what
i'm saying is i want two rows and four
columns now as you can see here it might
not be very clear to you right now but
what you can see here is this is the
first row and this is the second row and
each row contains four columns so these
are the this is the my final array that
i get so what you can see here is this
is the zeroth position and the uh or you
can say this is the first row first
column first row second column and uh
since python is zero based so this is
actually the zeroth row and this is the
first row so as you can see uh this this
value basically is zero times one this
value is zero times two zero times three
zero times four and over here it is one
times zero one times one one times two
one times three so similarly if i did
for example a five by five matrix what
you will get is five rows now five rows
and five columns and for example like
this particular value is uh
one two three or zero one two three so
zero one two three and the first column
so this is three times one um if i took
this value this is like the fourth row
for example fourth row times the
zero one two three third column so this
would be four times three which is
twelve so and uh each value of this has
been generated in the similar process so
this is an example of how we can use for
loops um for a particular exercise that
i have shown you right now so this was
it for these particular examples into
violent for loops i hope you found the
two examples on while loops in this one
example on for loops helpful to you and
i hope it gave you further insight into
how we can use these types of loops in
different projects in this video we will
be covering the topic of definite
iterations uh using for loops in python
so starting off we know that there are
two types of iterations in programming
uh definitely an indefinite we have
already covered indefinite iterations in
the form of while loops definite
iterations on the other hand are done
using the keyword for
and the basic syntax or the standard
syntax for a basic for loop in python is
as you can see over here we have this
four keyword we have some variable we
have the in keyword and we have this
iterable and
we of course define this control
structure with the colon and then
indented we have this statement block so
once this for loop has started we
execute all of these statements within
the statement block as part of the for
loop iteration so yeah let's uh now
let's to understand like how for loops
work
exactly let's
look at the concept or meaning behind
what we call iterables and iterators so
so think of it in a stepwise manner all
right so we in python we have different
objects that can be used as iterables
and an iterable is basically some object
that uh it's a collection of other
objects so you know think of your lists
uh think of dictionaries and sets so all
of these are essentially collections of
objects so once we have these collection
of objects
we can create an iterator out of it
how do we do that is we use the iter
function so for example if i passed this
list a if i pass this list a through the
iter function and i store it in some
variable iter underscore a
and i see what is iter underscore a it
is actually a list iterator at some
random memory location which we don't
really care about similarly if i gave a
tuple and i did the same thing i will
create a tuple iterator and in the left
if you can see over here i've done the
exact same
functions with sets and dictionaries as
well so i'm creating iterators out of
these
iterables so as to speak
now what is an iterator well an iterator
is
an object that
yields
values successively so
if my list contained five values or five
objects an iterator of this list will
yield these values uh one after the
other and that is kind of how or that is
the basis for which we do
we create loops let's see what we
exactly mean using this uh
using another function that we call the
next function so the next function keeps
moving from object to object within an
iterator so since i've created this list
iterator let's just do it once again so
as you can see i've created this listed
iterator item underscore a now with this
item underscore a what i'm going to do
is i'm going to use this next function
what next function does is starting from
the leftmost object within this iterator
i will keep yielding or keep producing
the values so let's let's just see what
happens when i do next iter when i do
next for this particular variable it
gives me this object first now let's see
what happens when i do it again
now it gives me the object second what
if i did it again it gives me third now
if i kept doing this it will keep giving
me the different objects that were
initially stored in a that is first and
then second third fourth and fifth one
after the other so let's actually
perform that now i get fourth now i get
fifth now a natural question is now that
i've exhausted all of these values what
will happen if i perform the next
function again well let's see what
happens i get a uh an error or and this
error is the stop iteration function
error which basically is telling me uh
look you have uh exhausted all of the
objects that were initially present in
this list a and you cannot you cannot
keep doing the next in the next function
anymore you cannot go you keep going
further so yeah so this is uh what the
next function does when it comes to the
concept of iterators all right so now
we've learned two things what is an
iterator and what is the how do we
create an iterator out of different
collections of objects like a list or a
tuple and we've also learned how to use
the next function now let's move or
let's come back to our for loop that we
started off this video with so our for
loop again let's consider our for loop
over here
as you can see some for loop with
objects second one two three four and
five all right this is a list now i'm
going to do for x in a print x and let's
try to see
what happens when we do this okay as you
can see when i have executed this it
gives me one two three four and five so
i have first of all let's look at this
for loop i in this for loop i define a
new variable x and then i say for x in a
print x and what's happening well in
each iteration i am printing whatever
the value of x is
at present so in the first iteration it
is the first object one in the second
iteration it is the second object two
then three four five and then finally uh
on its own like uh this for loop knows
that okay now once i have exhausted all
of the objects within my iterator i can
stop doing this for loop and i can move
on with the rest of the code all right
so think of it like a three-step process
uh a for loop in python the first step
is it calls an iter function to obtain
an iterator for whatever we pass over
here this iterable second step it calls
the next function repeatedly in each
iteration all right to keep getting the
next item from the iterator so it gets
one and then it calls next then it gets
two then it calls next and it gets three
and then four and then five and so on
and then finally the third step is the
termination step is when after we do the
final next where we get this error as
you can see the stock iteration error or
exception finally this tells the for
loop function or the for loop that um
okay we have reached the end of our
definite iteration or the end of our
definite for loop and this is where we
must terminate our loop and then
continue with the rest of the code all
right so this is how a for loop works in
python now it's very important to note
that whatever we have discussed when it
came to while loops such as nesting of
while loops and nesting of other control
structures is also applicable in the
case of for loops so if i had a for loop
within another for loop that is
perfectly fine if i had a vial within a
for loop that is perfectly fine so all
of these are valid statement blocks that
we can do
and again for loop is another control
structure and so we must follow the
concept of
indentation when it comes to writing our
statement blocks within a for loop okay
so now i'm going to speak about in
specific i'm going to speak about the
this uh something called the range
function that is uh quite
you could say it's used definitely it's
used in other areas of programming but
it's widely used in python
i mean
i mean the for loop in python now
what i mean by this is that
range this range function is very
important for the for loop and we will
see why okay so let's look at um one of
the examples of using the range function
so what does the range function do is if
i give range 5 let's see what it does it
gives me range 0 to 5. what this
basically tells me is that this will
create an iterator that contains uh
integers from zero to five so it will
contain the object zero one two three
four and five and we can use this as an
iterator so let's let's look at this uh
i have range five uh let's store this in
x okay now let's do a type just to see
what happens when we do type x it should
give me the type of range as you can see
and this is a type of an iterator in
python now let's see what happens when i
do for i in x
print i okay let's see what happens as
you can see it prints the number 0 1 2 3
4. an important caveat when it comes to
the range function is when we say range
5 it creates an iterator from 0 to 5 but
it contains the objects 0 1 2 3 and 4
only it does not contain the object five
itself okay this is something that is
very important too so uh once again i
created
i use this range function to create an
iterator from
iterator of five objects from zero to
four zero one two three and four uh i
use that in my for loop and uh that's
what that is what you are seeing here
now let's use this range function in the
context of something else for example
let's see so i had my earlier list a
right look at my list a here
so you can see list a contains these one
two three four five five objects okay
let's see what length of a is length of
a is five okay
let's use the range function on top of
the length of this list a and this is
like i can't show you an example right
now without any context but this uh this
form of using a for loop is used is
widely used in
python programming you will use it so
much in data science you will use so
much in machine learning and ai i cannot
tell you uh this is so this is a very
important like sort of uh for loop
expression so you have four
let's say i
in
range
len
a let's see what's going on here first i
create uh first i do length of a that
gives me five then i do range of five
that creates an iterator between zero
and four right when you do range five it
gives you an iterator of 0 1 2 3 and 4
as we saw earlier and this is what we're
doing over here we have created an
iterator out of the length of a list
now when i do print i it should give me
again 1 2 3 4 0 1 2 3 4 of course so as
you can see here it will give me 0 1 2 3
4. and this is a very neat way of using
the range function on top of the length
of a particular collection of objects in
this case we're using the list a this is
something that you will use a lot so i i
would recommend that you get used to
this form of creating a for loop as well
using the range function also of course
um there are uh the you can use break
and continue statements as you have in
the case of while loops uh exactly this
it works exactly the same in the case of
for loops wherein the break statement
will abruptly stop the for loop
completely and we will move on to the
next piece of code whereas the continue
statement will break that particular
iteration and then we will resume with
the next iteration so yeah that was
breaking continue statements and
follow-ups uh finally i would like to
show you something about uh how to use
dictionaries as an iterator or as an
iterable when it comes to for loops so
let's create our dictionary let's go we
have a dictionary already here in fact
create this dictionary again we'll store
it in a okay so i created this
dictionary a all right so i have
dictionary a uh what i'm going to do is
i'm going to pass it through the
iterator function as you can see and now
i'm going to just for the sake of
showing you it will show i'll show you
that it is actually an iterator of type
of a specific dict key iterator type all
right so
now let's uh let's do something on this
so as you can see in the dictionary i
have the key first that has the value
one i have the key second that has the
value two i have the key third that has
a value three and then fourth for four
fifth for five now
a good question would be when i do
iteration or when i do a for loop on top
of this a well what is it going to pick
up is it going to pick up first uh is it
going to pick up the keys like these or
is it going to pick up the values or is
it going to go one by one key and then
value and then key in the subsequent
value uh let's see what actually happens
let's do four i in
uh iter underscore a print hi let's see
what what is the iterations happening
upon using this so as you can see we're
using the keys so by default when we do
this when we perform when we create an
iterator out of a dictionary we use only
the keys as our
iterator elements or at iterator values
but of course like if you wanted to use
values all you would have to do is pass
a dot values over here and if you
remember from a dictionary video this uh
a dot values gives us a a list of or it
by it gives us the essentially a list of
the values in our dictionary so when we
pass this to the iterator uh iter
function and we create an iterator out
of it let's see what happens over here
now let's see what is it underscore a
you can actually see it's now the dict
value iterator at a particular memory
location so it's not the dict key as we
saw earlier it's a dict value iterator
so now that we have this dict by
dictionary value iterator now let's
print what are our iterator elements and
as you can see now we are printing
values and not um the keys so this is
how to these this is basically two
different ways of iterating through a
dictionary one through keys and one
through values so this concludes it for
our video on definite iterations in
python i hope in this video you
understood and you learned about the
concept of iterables and iterators and
the different functions associated with
it and how exactly the for loop function
works
in python in this video we're going to
learn about the topic called file
handling now file handling is basically
needed because so most of the times when
we're handling large and different types
of data in python or in general we
cannot store everything into a variable
and we will have to use files now there
are two types of files that we are going
to deal with they are binary and text
files so binary files are some of the
files that we most of the files that we
commonly encounter like document files
image files video files etc now all
binary files are encoded in a particular
format and they cannot be read by a
normal text editor and we would be
needing certain specific softwares for
specific files text files on the other
hand do not have any specific encoding
and they can be opened in the normal
text editor itself and they are like
xml css html files and so on now there
are four main operations that we can do
on
by in python on files they are open read
write and close um there are certain
other operations as well like rename
delete so some of the most basic
operation that we can do is obviously
creating and opening a file and the
syntax is as you can see here where we
store where we use the open command and
we give a file name and we give a mode
and we store that in a particular
variable now a mode is uh basically
telling python how to handle this
opening so we can have a read-only mode
which is done by this letter r a write
only mode which is done by letter w and
for there are a bunch of other modes
such as read or write mode which is done
by r plus and we're going to see them as
we encounter them now the it's important
to note that what i just mentioned is
for text files if we are going to do
for binary files we're going to do this
file handling then we would be using the
letter b in front of whatever we were
using in the case of text files so if we
were doing a read-only mode for opening
a binary file we would be using rb and
if we were doing read and write mode
read or write only mode for a binary
file we would be using rb plus
so basically just adding the b in the
case of binary files let's look at a
basic example when we want to open a
particular file we are going to like in
this example i'm going to open some file
called filehandling.txt in a read and
write mode read or write mode and i'm
going to store it in fo so this is as
simple as it gets similarly if i wanted
to do it for the binary file since i'm
using a binary file i will use the
letter b as well in the mode and uh
that's how you do it here now let's look
at different ways in which we can read
from a file and there are three commands
that we can use we can use the read
command followed by optional number of
characters we can use the read line
command followed by an option number of
characters and the read lines command so
this optional number of characters is
denoted by n over here
and basically is telling us how many
characters we want to print so let's
look at a simple example of
where i'm going to print something
called
so i'm going to take this and i'm going
to do a print on top of this so i have
done first i've opened it and i've
stored it in my file and then i'm going
to do a
a method or a function called read and
i'm going to say like in this example
just read the whole thing so as you can
see my file that i have opened has all
of these lines this is like the whole
file basically now what if i wanted to
open only the first five characters of
this file which is basically this well
in that case let's open this once again
now let's do the same read command
except we will give the character number
which is five as you can see it's only
printed five now let's do a print read
command and try to read the whole thing
again and you will notice something very
interesting now when i do the read
command you can see it's kind of picked
up from where we left off in our from
our previous command and that is the
nature of how
python handles files so if i wanted to
again take the cursor back in such an
example i will have to open this again
and then i use this read command once
again to get back to where i started
from as you can see here now another
command that we can use is the read line
command so let's uh once again open this
over here and now we're going to use the
read line command
over here so what redline command is
going to do is going to each time we use
this command it's going to go one by one
and read each particular line from this
file so in first case it will take
artificial intelligence then data
science big data and so on so as you can
see if i execute this it first takes
artificial intelligence now if i did
this command again it will say data
science next time if i do it it should
say big data as you can see here okay so
this is the read line command now within
the read line command also we can enter
characters and that will tell us
basically
that we want these number of characters
from the next line so if i want the
first six characters of the next line i
will say six i will enter six here and
it will give me the first six characters
of this particular line which is the
next line that is to come as you can see
here now another way in which we can
print whatever is there in our file line
by line is by using a for loop so again
i'm going to open this file i'm going to
store it here now i'm going to use a for
loop saying that well for line in my
file and what this does is basically at
each each iteration it's going to take
each line and store it in this variable
that we end over here which is called
line itself and we're going to print
that at the end of the loop what we'll
have is all of the lines have been
printed one by one and another thing
that we can do right now is um say we
want to read a particular line say i
wanted you to read the
fifth line of my file i can use this
technique where um i just say okay i'm
gonna store five in this variable called
line number and i have this um another
variable called current line which i'm
going to initialize with one and i'm
gonna any i'm gonna what i'm gonna do is
i'm going to
do the same loop where i'm gonna say
four line in my line but i'm going to
add a condition saying that only if
current line when it's equal to line
number am i going to print the line and
then i'm going to break out of this
whole thing
and at the end of each
loop i'm going to say current line is
going to be incremented by one until
basically these two variables are equal
so when i do this i get my result which
is uh machine learning which is the
fifth line of um
my which is the fifth line of or
whatever file i had now we're going to
move on to the topic of um image file
handling so we we saw how we handled and
we we saw certain operations around
text files um and text files obviously
something that we're going to use a lot
but we are also going to be using files
such as images a lot and let's uh look
at certain examples and certain
use cases around image file handling so
my first step is going to be importing a
bunch of modules and packages now the
details of these modules and these
packages are not important as of right
now because they will be covered in a
future video but just keep a note of
some of these packages such as
they say numpy and
image the image
package so once i've done this let's
move on to my example so what i'm going
to do is i'm going to store certain file
locations in two variables so it's
basically two strings
i've attached the of this prefix r to
say that this is a read-only uh sort of
a prefix so the next topic that we're
going to be handling is image file
handling now we have already seen many
examples pertaining to text files so
text files are obviously something that
we're going to be using a lot but image
file handling is something very
important as well and we're going to see
certain operations that we can do around
image file handling so starting off i'm
going to import a bunch of
packages and modules what these packages
exactly are and what these modules
exactly are are right now not of that
important i'm not not that important to
you right now but it's something that
will be covered in a future or in future
videos uh it's important to just keep
note of what these are such as numpy and
image so once i've done that what i'm
going to store is i'm going to store two
particular file locations into variables
location one and location two and i've
prefixed them with r just to say that
these are raw strings so once i've done
that i'm going to use the image
from the image package i'm going to say
open and i'm going to say open from this
particular location in this particular
location and i'm going to store these
image images in im1 and im2 over here
very similar to a normal text file
opening now once we have done this
we can access certain properties of this
image using say format which tells us
the format of the file
it attributes the it identifies the
source of an image and if the image is
not read from our file it is set to none
we can also see the size of the file
using the size attribute and we can see
the mode which basically defines the
number and names of the bands in the
image and also contains the pixel type
and depth certain common modes are like
l for luminescence rgb for true color
images and cmyk for pre-press images so
let's look at them so when i
access this you can see my first file is
of jpeg of this size and an rgb format
image and my second image is another
jpeg slightly bigger image and again rgb
now we
can also of course display these images
and to do that we can use the plt um
again plt is the is supposed to stand
for a matte plot lip dot pipe plot it's
a particular for a particular package um
that again you don't need to know the
details of right now but this is how we
would um do this so i'm going to use a
bunch of
commands and methods such as figure and
subplot and then i am sure so once i
have done this as you can see both of my
images with this being im1 this being
im2 have
been produced on the screen as you can
see i can also use display this display
function followed by the name of the
file and this will simply display my
image as you can see here now
i can obviously
save a particular
image using the save function which is
as simple as doing this so i'm going to
save the image as
i am underscore save dot jpg over here
now if i wanted to crop an image i can
do that as well so i initially i stored
the dimensions that i want cropped in
the form of a tuple as you can see here
and i'm going to pass that tuple to the
crop function and i'm going to apply
that on top of im1 and i'm going to
store that to region once i've done that
as you can see so basically what i've
done is i've cropped this image based on
whatever passed here and i've stored it
into region and now if i wanted to see
what was actually in that crop i can
just do the i am show function and i am
going to pass the particular cropped
image which is denoted by region as you
can see here and you can see my cropped
image is basically a certain a left
portion of this whole image has been
cropped out and i have produced it over
here now i can also use the copy
function using it's a simple basically
copy base you use the copy function and
it copies an image onto another variable
that you have assigned and when i use
the i am show function i am going to
show you the copied image which is
basically the same now we can do the
transpose operation as well so let's see
some of the let's see what we have done
here so in this transpose opposite
operation so in this uh basically i've
done a bunch of
operations such as rotating by 90
degrees rotating by 180 rotating by 7
270 and finally once i'm done with all
of these multiple operations i am going
to show you the final output which is
basically a certain transposed image
like this which is basically the result
of whatever i have done before this so
this is it for this video on file
handling i have shown you two slightly
more comprehensive examples on
text files and
even certain examples on image files
however we can use file handling and
different libraries pertaining to file
handling for
audio files and even for like stuff like
pdf files and
this is like this is just only the
beginning and i'm sure you will
encounter a lot of different use cases
different examples as you continue
learning
python programming this video is going
to be the first of a part of a series on
object oriented programming so to start
off with let's try to understand and get
an introduction into what is object
oriented programming well as the name
suggests object oriented programming is
all about creating objects an object is
a group of interrelated variables and
functions variables can be referred to
as the properties of the object whereas
the functions can be referred to as the
behavior of an object so if we were to
treat say for example a car as an object
its properties would be its color its
model its price and its brand whereas
its behavior or functions for that
matter would be like accelerating gear
change breaking similarly if i gave you
an example of a dog as an object we
could consider the properties of the dog
as its weight or its name its breed its
color whereas its functions could be say
barking playing eating walking etc
objects provide a better and a clear
structure for a program now let's move
on to what is a class and an instance
now a class is like a blueprint or a
template of certain functions and
entities whereas an instance is a
particular realization of a class
classes are used to create user-defined
data structures and define certain
functions called methods within the
class whereas instances are realizations
of these classes and when we are
speaking of classes and instances
classes don't contain any real data they
are just merely templates instances on
the other hand contain real data to
think of an example of the difference
between a class and an instance think of
a class like a empty form or a
questionnaire now an empty format
questionnaire does not have any
information but it does have a template
to it it tells you to fill in certain
information and based on who is filling
in the information that information or
the data on a particular form will be
different so an instance is like a
filled out form with its own
unique set of information that is one
way of
treating or understanding what is a
class and an instance now for our first
example on classes i will be taking you
through a class where i've defined based
on the circle object so this class is
going to define basically information
about your general circle such as its
radius and its area so let's go through
it now obviously to define a class we
need a keyword well in the case of
classes we use the class keyword
followed by a name for that class so in
this case my name is circle now after
the colon every every information that
is part of the class has to be obviously
indented as is typical for python now
you can see over here a bunch of def
keywords followed by so something that
you might not be familiar with and i
will try to get you through this so if
you see here you have a def keyword
followed by init and this init is
prefixed by a double underscore and it's
suffixed by a double underscore and you
can see the same thing for str and repr
well this double underscore is called a
dunder and any method these are of
course methods this is a method this is
a method this is a method this is a
method now any method that is prefixed
and suffixed by double underscores are
called dunder methods um these dunder
methods are or can be thought of like
predefined or built in methods for any
class that you define so these we have
like three dunder methods over here and
we have one user defined method that we
will get to so this first method that
you see here is the init method or the
initialization method and this is
invoked or called whenever we create an
instance of this class circle and what
we do here is basically we pass um when
we create this instant circle uh we are
what what happens is that we are we get
an option to pass and a value for
a
what is this
keyword or variable radius so if i pass
so you will see me later on creating an
instance where um i will be passing a
value and that value is basically stored
as the radius and by default the radius
that will be passed whenever we create
an instance for this uh class is one um
the str method is basically used to
return a descriptive string for the the
instance of
class
repr is not something that you have to
bother with right now and uh now get
area is something that you should follow
because if you see here i have not used
any double underscores so this is a user
user defined method um user defined
methods are it's a method that we define
and these are like tasks that we define
on our own so in my user defined method
called get area i will be returning the
area of the circle based on the radius
that i passed to it now if you notice
here the before every um in every method
i have the self keyword before any other
attribute so
like this herself this herself even the
get area herself now what this means
self is like an optional keyword that is
used to improve readability of a program
first of all and it's also the function
of the self keyword is basically um
telling python that well any of the
methods that we are invoking in this
class or the instance of this class has
to refer to attributes and variables
within that instance of that class so if
i'm going to use getarea function i am
going to
get values and attribute values and
variable values based on only the
current instance of
that particular class self is obviously
optional we don't really need it but
basically the first attribute of any
method is
is basically the is basically what the
mel is is the instance that
the method is invoked upon so if i say
self i'm telling
this particular function that okay all
the value that you're going to get for
performing whatever task you want is
going to be found in that particular
instance where you have been invoked
itself now don't worry if all this is
very confusing
this might be in the beginning but just
try to understand that this is something
that we do for good practice and you
will understand
when 20 yourself or when not to yourself
as you learn about object oriented
programming so if you see here my get
area function is supposed to return the
value
radius times radius f dot radius is
basically telling um whatever value i've
passed for radius for that particular
instance you can read this as radius
times radius times pi as well so
obviously this is pi r squared which is
the area of a particular circle now let
me show you an example where i am going
to perform some of these functions so if
you see this first line i have created
an instance of the class circle where i
have passed 2.1 for the radius of the
circle so now the value of the variable
radius in this particular instance is
going to be stored as 2.1 and this
particular instance is going to be
stored in the variable c1 now the print
c1 function invokes the str self-defined
or predefined function now if you
remember str was it's basically used to
return a particular string that
describes like what the class will do
and this is something that we define on
our own in our example str will return
the
string saying this is a circle with
radius off and then it will return the
radius that we passed so in this case it
should say this is the circle of radius
2.1 as you can see over here so if i
execute this you can notice this line
this is a circle with radius 2.1 and
this is invoked by the print function
the print basically invokes the dunder
str function which does all of this now
in the next line we say print c1 dot get
area so this is going to print the value
of the what what gets returned when we
invoke the method get area for this
particular instance c1 so obviously in
this particular instance our radius is
2.1 so the get area function should do
pi times 2.1 square and the value is as
you can see here is some 13.85 so that
is the area that we got now if we want
to print a particular radius um we just
say print c1 dot radius so this will
print the value of what is
what is stored in radius for the
particular instance c1 now you might
notice me using a dot whenever it comes
to defining a certain function or a
keyword well any time that we want to
invoke or use a method of a particular
class we have to use the dot keyword so
we use the instance name c1 dot followed
by whatever method that we want to use
so if we want to use the get area
function we say c1 dot get area if you
want to find out what is there in the
radius
key radius variable of a particular
instance we say c1 dot radius now before
we move on let's talk about some of the
naming conventions class names are
initial capitalized so if our class name
is
for example
like for example if it's camel case well
each word that is part of this class has
its first letter capitalized variables
and method names are in lower class so
if my class was called circle we say
class circle with c being in capital now
moving on let's talk about how we
initialize or define instance variables
now instance variables are declared
within the init method if you remember
from the earlier example of circle init
is a dunder method it's followed and
it's preceded by double underscore as
you can see here now if you see in this
particular
case i have again used the self keyword
and as i mentioned earlier the self
keyword is the first parameter of all
member methods
and it this basically binds that
particular method to the particular
instance itself during invocation so
every time a new circle object is
created the dot init function sets the
initial state of the object by assigning
the values of the object's properties so
the init function basically initializes
each and every new instance of
whatever of our class so we can give in
it any number of parameters but the
first parameter must always be a
variable called self now when a new
class instance is created the instance
is automatically passed to the self
parameter in init so that new attributes
can be defined on the object inside the
init method the self.radius basically
means that we want the value of radius
based on the current instance itself so
as you can see radius defines an
instance variable radius and we're going
to use the particular instance and its
value
of for radius in our variable radius now
instance uh the i mean the init function
is not a constructor but it is an
initializer to create instance variables
the init function also will never return
a value and it is optional and can be
omitted if there are no instance
variables now let's move on to um class
variables so now as we mentioned earlier
all the attributes that are created
inside the init function are instant
specific attributes and the instance
attributes are obviously specific to a
particular instance of the class for
example all dog objects now if we have a
class called dog then all dog objects
have a name and age but the values for
the name and age will vary depending on
which dog we are talking talking about
or basically which instance of the dog
are we talking about now class
attributes are attributes that have the
same value for all class instances and
we define a class attribute by assigning
a value value to a variable outside of
the init function so if you look at this
example over here we have created
another class called circle and we have
this initializer again where we have a
class specific variable called radius
which whose value will change depending
on whatever we pass for that particular
instance however if you look before the
initial the init
init function or the initializer
function if you see here we have another
variable called shape object which
stores the string circle and this
variable is going to be the same and
constant for every instance of
the class circle and unlike the
uh variable radius we will not have
different values depending on a
particular instance okay now let's talk
about instantiating an object and let's
see what happens when we create two
different instances of the same class so
as you can see here i've created an
instance c1 for class circle and i'm
going to check its id well if you see
the id is something like this now if i
created another instance over here
called c2 and if i check its id well
it's something different now so if you
see each instance basically has a
different memory location in our
memory
and each instance is this is how each
instance is different each time we
create it and they are created in
different memory locations finally
before we conclude this topic on
the introduction into oop let's talk
about class methods instance methods and
static methods now class methods are
usually declared are actually declared
with the at class method operator or
decorator as you can see here it accepts
the class as its first argument so in
this case i am going to say i'm going to
define a class called my class i'm going
to use this at class method decorator to
say that whatever follows here is going
to be a class method and i've defined a
class method called hello that takes in
a um that uses again self and a name
attribute so what this does is it prints
whatever i have passed to it in the form
of hello from
self.name now what this this is going to
do is basically it's going to give out a
string saying hello from
name of the whatever class we have and
whatever we pass in the attribute name
so oh in this my particular in this case
i'm going to invoke this method using
the class name itself i'm not going to
use an instance name because i have no
instance
in this particular example and since
this is a class method it can be invoked
using the class name itself so i'm going
to pass rakesh and let's see what
happens when we do this as you can see
the first print will basically
give us the information of the class
itself it's saying that the class is
called myclass and the second print
statement is basically a string saying
hello from the string name my class with
a
comma and then whatever we passed
initially which was rakesh next is then
instance methods and these are the most
common types of methods these are
invoked by an instance object so we have
to create an instance to actually use an
instance method and it takes the
instance or the keyword itself as its
first argument so if i say class.class
if i define a class myclass in this
example
and i'm going to define another function
called hello as you can see i have not
used any decorator like at
class method so this is going to be an
instance method and it's going to be
invoked by the particular instance so in
this case it's going to print hello from
and it's going to basically say the name
of the class again so i create my
instance called my instance1 and it's an
instance of this class and then i'm
going to invoke the instance method by
using this.operator and the instance
name and the result will be basically
this string over here as you can see now
finally we have another type of method
called the static method which is
declared using the add static method
decorator so a static method does not
know its class and is just attached to
the class for convenience it does not
depend on the state of the object and
could be from a separate function of a
module a static method can be invoked
via a class object or an instance object
so if you look at this example over here
i have defined a static method
i've defined hello and it basically says
print hello world so it's going to
basically just print this so if you can
see here i've created my instance and
i'm going to say dot hello it should
basically pre-print print hello world
that's all so um guys this was um this
was it for the introduction on oop in
this video we will continue our
discussion on object-oriented
programming in an earlier video you
might have gone through the introduction
into oop in this video we will continue
that discussion on oop with inheritance
inheritance is used to describe the
relationship between two classes wherein
one class takes the methods and
properties from another class in this
relationship we have something called
the base class or the parent class from
which we will derive all our sum of the
properties and methods and the class
which actually derives these properties
and methods is known as the derived
class so you can think of the derived
class as a specialized version of a base
class to explain what inheritance is in
a basic way i will show you an example
where i'm creating a cylinder class
which is going to be a subclass of the
circle class that you might have
encountered in the earlier video on op
so what we're going to do is create a
cylinder class that is a subclass of
circle where we're going to get the
attributes radius and get area from
circle class and we're going to add the
attributes height and get volume to the
cylinder so right off the start you can
see we have our class circle that you
might have seen in the earlier video so
this class circle has the familiar
initialization where we are supposed to
enter a value for a radius that gets
stored in self dot radius now we also
have a description string which
basically is a
dunder method that returns a string when
we invoke the print command on a
particular instance and we have the get
area method as well now if we move on to
the cylinder class you can see that i'm
defining this class with the class
keyword with the cylinder name but you
can see that i have added a parenthesis
and within it i have mentioned the name
of the superclass that i want the
cylinder class to be a subclass of so
this is how we actually define a
subclass in the most basic way you enter
the name that you want and you enter the
name of the superclass that you want the
subclass to be if a subclass of in
parenthesis right after the name now
next if you move on to the dunder
initialization um the initialization is
very familiar familiar except now we
have another attribute for height which
has a deeper default value of one just
like the radius so this basically means
that we have an option of entering two
different attributes for our cylinder
instances now if you see here there's a
line which says super dot init now this
is like um this is a command which we
use to invoke the super classes
initializer so anytime we create an
instance for cylinder we also want an
initialization for the circle method as
well as a part of our cylinder instance
next you can see that um much like how
we stored self uh i mean the radius
attribute in self.radius we're also
storing the height attribute in
self.height now even this uh cylinder
class has an str method to return a
particular string if we use this print
function and finally we get on to a more
a new method that we have defined only
for this render class called get volume
now
if you see the get volume it returns as
basically the volume of
the cylinder that is being described in
the particular instance for which we
enter the height and the radius so if
you can see here
what we basically added extra is an a
height attribute and another method
called get volume and the other parts of
the circle superclass such as radius and
get area are also going to be a part of
cylinder even though you do not
explicitly see them anywhere here and we
will see how in uh in the form of an
example that's coming up so let me just
execute these classes now that that's
done i'm going to create an instance for
cylinder i'm going to store it in cy1
and i'm going to pass 1.1 for the radius
and 2.2 for the height and once that is
done let's just print
to invoke the hdr method and as you can
see the sdi method basically tells us
the information that is a cylinder with
radius 1.1 and height 2.2 so now let's
print what is the value we get when we
use the get area method now it's
important to note get area was not
explicitly defined in the cylinder
subclass but it's a method that is a
part of the circle superclass and we can
see that we can actually access methods
that are part of the superclass simply
by accessing any other method so if you
use the dot get area you can see that we
get a value for the area of the cylinder
so this basically this area is basically
the area of the circle face of the
cylinder
the top or the bottom now let's use now
let's invoke uh the subclass specific
method which is the get volume method in
a similar manner as you can see just by
doing invoking this method we get the
volume as well now um if we want to see
what is the radius and the height we can
just do a simple print statement
followed by cy1 dot radius c1 dot height
and it gives us both of these values as
you can see here now over here what i'm
going to do is create another instance
of cylinder but i'm not going to pass
anything for radius or height so
basically it's going to take the default
values for radius and height which was
one and one respectively so once i print
um
this is this statement is basically
going to print the sdr method or
whatever we stored in the str which is
basically the description of the object
followed by what is its radius and
height this method will give us the area
and this method will give us the volume
so once i execute this as you can see
here this is what we get and this is
what we expect as well so
now in this example what i'm going to
show you is uh now i'm going to go back
and i am going to create another
instance for circle now this is the
superclass of course and i'm going to
give it and since the superclass has
only one option uh one attribute that we
can enter which is for the radius so i
pass three point three and i'm going to
print what what happens when i just
print uh this instance it's going to
basically give us whatever was uh a part
of the htr method after that i'm going
to print is instance this is basically a
check on whether c1 is an instance of
this class circle and x i'm going to
check if c1 is an instance of its
subclass cylinder now when i execute
this you can see that well this is what
we uh this is the str method that gets
printed but if you see here um you can
see that it says c1 is indeed a an
instance of circle when it says two over
here but when we look at the next line
is c1 in instance of cylinder it says
false and this is obviously because um a
super class object is never
an instance of a subclass object well as
whereas vice versa it would be true now
in the next part of this video what
we're going to do is look at the
different types of inheritances in
python so there are basically five types
of inheritance in python there is the
single inheritance there's multiple
inheritance multi-level inheritance
hierarchical hierarchical and hybrid
inheritance so we will go one by one and
see each of these examples starting off
we have the single inheritance this is
simply where we have one base class and
one derived class from that base class
so this is a simple
single inheritance and in this example
you can see i have a class called
country where i have a method that i've
defined called show country which is
basically going to say print this is
india it's basically going to print this
every time we invoke this show country
method then we have a class called state
which derives
from the
super class called country where we have
a method called show state which is
going to say print this state every time
so you can see i created an instance of
the class state and
through that instance i can access the
super class and the subclass methods
over here next we have the multi-level
sorry multiple inheritance and this is
when a derived class contains more than
one base class so let's look at an
example to understand this so if you can
see here i have a class called student
with the two methods defined called
method one and method two in method one
we can pass uh two attributes sn sno or
i think is this this is supposed to be
like uh an id i guess like sn number and
we have s name so this is basically two
attributes we can pass um that are
probably descriptors for a student and
in the next method you have basically uh
two print statements which says student
number and then they will print the
student number and uh it will also print
the student name next we have a class
called marks this is also um so these
these two classes are basically what our
super classes are going to be and we're
going to derive a third class from these
two so this second class is a class
called marks and we have two methods
again one method is called set marks
which has
the option of putting in two attributes
m1 and m2 both are representative of the
two marks and we store them in self dot
mark one self talk mark two the second
method is uh put marks which is going to
print the marks
namely mark one and then it's going to
tell us how much marks are there in the
first subject for example and another
print statement doing the same thing for
the second subject or mark two finally
we have a third class called a result
which derives from two classes marx and
student as you can see here in my
parenthesis i've passed in marks and
student both are super classes and our
class result is going to derive from
both of them this is an example of
multiple inheritance and within this
class result i have two methods specific
to this derived class called calc
wherein i'm going to basically calculate
the two the total marks of um
uh the the total marks which is
basically the addition of mark one plus
mark two and i'm then i'm going to have
another method called put total which is
going to print me what is the total so
if you can see here i have created an
instance of this derived class called a
result and i'm storing it in r then i'm
going to access method one which is
obviously a method from the first
superclass called student
and i'm going to store okay so that his
name is i guess lucky and he has 60
marks secondly then i'm going to do our
set marks which is the method from the
second superclass which is going to set
the marks uh respectively so you have
lucky student and his id is 60 and he
has got 50 and 60 marks respectively um
in say the first two subjects and
finally i'm going to access the derived
class method called calc so this is
going to do the sum uh finally i'm going
to also do our method 2 which is um
going to print our student number and
student name next we're going to have
put marks which is going to tell us the
um what are the individual marks for
mark 1 and mark 2 and then finally we're
going to print the total marks with the
put total so once i execute this you can
see here it says student number 60
student name lucky marks one is 50 as i
had written here marks 260 as i passed
here and then total is 110 which is
basically 50 plus 60. our next type of
inheritance is called multi-level
inheritance now multi-level inheritance
can be assumed as when you take a super
class let's call it a and you derive a
class b from that class a now what if we
derived a class c from b and we kept
doing this so until say a class e now
each of these steps is uh in its own an
inheritance but this whole relationship
can be described as a multi-level
inheritance so let's take an example
again so i've this this time i've
defined a class called student where i
have defined two methods called set stud
and put stud or you can call it set
student and put student in my first
method i have two options of adding two
attributes again this is the student
number this is the student name in my
second method i am going to print what
is the student number and what is the
student name finally uh so sorry next we
have another class called marks which
derives from the first class called
student this has two methods called set
marks where i'm going to again get the
option of adding two
integers for m1 and m2 which is going to
represent mark 1 and mark 2 and finally
i have put marks the method which is
going to print mark 1 and mark 2. um
finally i have another class called
result and this if you see
this derives from marks now if you see
this relationship you'll notice result
derives from marks whereas marks itself
derives from student and this is an
example of multi-level hierarchy and uh
even as a part of this third class we
have its own
methods called calc and put total
calc will calculate the total as we had
seen earlier and put total will
basically print that total and we're
going to do a very similar operation
we're going to create an instance of
this third class
result and store it in r
then we're going to do basically we're
going to set the student details uh his
student number and his name we're going
to give him his marks 50 and 60. we're
going to calculate what are the total
we're going to say okay now put the
details of what is the student's number
and name we're going to also store enter
i mean display his marks mark 1 and mark
2 and finally we're going to display the
total marks so let's execute this and if
you see
it's basically the similar operation
that we did earlier but the only
difference is in the earlier example our
our third class result was derived from
marx and student together so this was an
example of multiple inheritance whereas
in this example the result class derives
from marks and marks itself derives from
students so this is an example of
multi-level inheritance finally we have
um sorry not finally penultimately we
have
as our fourth example of uh inheritance
called a hierarchical inheritance apart
in my mispronounciation it's
hierarchical inheritance so in this case
a base class basically will contain more
than one derived class so let's see a
look at an example of what we mean here
so i have a class called one where i
have defined a method called display
where what i'm going to do is i'm going
to store self.x is equal to 1000 and
self.y is equal to 2 000 then what i'm
going to do is i'm going to print a
statement saying this is the method in
class 1 and i'm going to say
after that i'm going to print another
statement saying value of x is a self.x
which is going to be 1000. then i'm
going to have another print statement
saying value of y is self dot y which is
going to be 2 000. finally i mean next i
have another class called 2 this this is
going to derive from class 1 as you can
see here and in this class 2 i have
defined another method called add and in
this method add what i'm going to do is
i'm going to first print a statement
saying this is the method in class 2 and
then i'm going to actually print the
result of x plus y which is 1000 plus 2
000. finally i have another class called
3 and this is also deriving from one so
if you notice we have one parent class
called one and from this one uh parent
class we're going to derive two
different subclasses called two and
three so this is an example of
hierarchical inheritance now in this
class three what i've done is i've
defined a multiplication method what i'm
going to do is print first of all i'm
going to print this when i invoke this
method that this is the method in class
3 finally i'm going to say uh i'm going
to print the result of x times y which
is 1000 times two thousand so if you see
i am going to create an instance of two
and i'm going to create an instance of
three and i'm going to store them in t1
and t2 now since uh t2 i mean t1 is an
instance of two so i can access its
methods add and i can access this
methods display so i'm going to use
t1.display and even in 2
t2 i mean since it's a class
it's an instance of class 3 and this
also derives from class 1 i can also
access its method display but now i
cannot access add but i can access
multiply so if you see here i access add
through t1 instance since add is a part
of class 2 whereas multiply
is a method in class 3 so i access it in
its respective instance which is t2 so
if you see here now once i execute this
what you will get is basically
the results so first of all it will
basically display the method from
class 1 which is the display method it
will display the values of x and y and
since i've done this twice from two
different instances uh it will basically
show a repetition over here finally i've
done the addition and since this is a
method in class two it is going to say
as much that is a method in class two
and then it's going to say x plus five
is three thousand and now multiply is a
method in the third class so it's going
to say this is a method in class 3 and
it's going to tell me what is the
multiplication result finally we have
what is called hybrid inheritance and
this is a combination of multiple plus
multi-level inheritance that you saw
earlier so let's again understand this
through this example so we have a class
called student where we have a method
called set student um again two
attributes we can pass here for student
number and student name next we have a
another method part of the class student
called put student so this will print us
the student number and student name next
we have a class called marks and this
marks inherits from student so
we have a method in class marks called
cell set marks where we can pass two
attributes for mark 1 and mark 2
respectively and as we have seen earlier
we also have a put marks which will
display the marks for marks one and
marks two we have a class called
practical
the spectacle is basically a another
super class if you see here since this
does not derive from anything it is
super class on its own and what it does
is it uh it has two methods get
practical um and we can uh pass an
attribute for p1 here and we store that
in self.p1 and then we have an attribute
for uh put practical which will print us
the practical mark whatever we passed
for this attribute in p1 finally if you
see we have a class called result now in
this result we have we are going to
derive from marks and practical but if
you notice here marks itself is a
subclass of student so this is an
example of multi-level inheritance
whereas since result uh derived from
marx and practical both it is also an
example of multiple inheritance so if
you see a notice here this is an example
of multiple and multiple level
inheritance which is basically what we
call hybrid inheritance and as we had
seen earlier this result class will have
a calc method to
do a total of the marks um in this case
mach 1 plus mark 2 plus the practical
mark p1 and we have a put total method
which is basically going to print us the
total so now we are going to create an
instance of this result and through this
instance of result we're going to first
invoke the parent class method called
set student which is the the second
level parent basically the student
the student class
said student method so we're going to
set student here we're going to say 60
is a student id and name is ash then we
have set marks which is again the
the second level parent which is a
student class where we set the marks
finally we access this get practical now
if you notice get practical is part of
the practical uh super class so in this
we store the third subject or the the
practical marks hundred then we
calculate the total and we put uh first
the student details then we put the
individual marks then we put the
practical marks and finally we enter
what is the total so let's execute this
and if you notice you will see here
student number is 60 student name and
all the basically whatever details we
wanted um is shown over here so this was
it guys for
our video on inheritance in this video
we will continue our discussion on
object oriented programming with the
topic of polymorphism now the term
polymorphism in oop refers to the
ability of an object to adapt the code
to the type of data it is processing
polymorphism is one of the key concepts
of python and it is also a built-in
feature of python an example to get us
started on polymorphism would be how we
use the plus operator we use the plus
operator not only for arithmetic
additions but we also use the plus
operator
for stuff like string concatenations or
joining two lists together this example
where we are able to use the plus
operator for different different
operations is an example of polymorphism
to show you what i mean i have basically
done a simple addition operation here
where i'm adding two variables number
one and number two when i do it on
integers it basically adds one plus two
now when i use it on two strings str1
and str2 which contains python and
programming to separate uh strings and
when i use the plus operator on these
you can see what it does here it forms
um one string containing both of these
individual strings so this is basically
the plus operator showing polymorphism
and is one of the simplest occurrences
and yet most common occurrences of
polymorphism in python another example
of polymorphism would be through the
lens function the lens function in
python is something that we use a lot
and over multiple data types depending
on the data type that we use the length
function for we get a different value or
a different
sort of information from the length
function now if you see here from this
diagram when we use the length function
on a string it gives us the length of
the string when we use the length
function on a list it gives us the
number of items whereas if we use the
length function on a dictionary it gives
us the number of keys so this is well
another example of how we have
polymorphism in a function now what we
are going to do is look at the different
techniques through which we can enable
polymorphisms in our code our first
example that we are going to look at is
through method overloading now method
overloading in its traditional sense
where we can have a method with the same
name
more than one method with the same name
in the same class is
not exactly possible in python so if we
have multiple methods with the same name
in a class in python which may differ in
in types and number of arguments are not
allowed and not supported in python in
fact if we did something like this where
we created a method with
different
with different say types and number and
arguments but having the same name
in the same class then what python will
do is it will only recognize the the
last defined method and it will
not recognize any of the earlier methods
with the same name but we can simulate
polymorphism through method overloading
by using default arguments in a method
now for example what i'm going to show
you here is an example where i have a
method called sum now by default
it has three attributes that you can
pass through this method a does not have
a default value b does not have a
default value but if you notice c has a
default value 0. so this is a simple
example where i'm going to show you that
the sum method is
going to be used in two different cases
in one case we're going to simply add
two digits uh i mean two numbers and in
another case we're going to use the sum
method to add three different numbers so
we have this class overload demo within
it a method sum and i have three
attributes a and b are uh
have uh are supposed to be given by the
user since they don't have a since they
do not have any default values whereas c
has a default value zero so if you see
here in my first case i have uh i first
of all created an instance called over
an instance called od for the class
overload demo and uh i have uh what i'm
going to do is i'm going to store the
value of the sum of 7 and 8 in the
variable sum now if you see here i have
not passed a third argument so what this
method is going to do is is going to
take the value of c as 0 by default so
it's basically going to do
7 plus 8 and it's going to give us the
sum for 7 plus 8. and in the next
instance i'm going to give three
arguments 7 eight and nine so now c will
be replaced by nine instead of zero and
then i'm going to get the sum of seven
eight and nine so in this this is a not
a very use
not a very commonly used thing uh but
it's basically a method just to show you
that we can actually simulate
method overloading in python by using
default arguments so i've basically
shown you how the same how the same
method sum has been used to
do the addition of two digits and then
in another instance is doing the
addition of three digits it might look
very similar but
you'll basically notice that by having
this uh third attribute c i have a
default value of zero i have induced
some form of polymorphism through method
overloading now the next way that we can
induce polymorphism is through
inheritance which is called method
overriding as well now method overriding
gives us the ability to change the way
or the change the implementation of a
method in a child class which is defined
already
in one of its super classes now if there
is a method in a super class the method
having the same name and same number of
arguments in a child class
then the child class method is going to
override the method in the parent class
so what we do is when a method is called
with the parent class object the method
of the parent class will be executed
whereas if we call the method using the
child class object the method of the
chat class will be execute and executed
and it will override the method in the
parent class so the appropriate overhead
method is called
is called based on the object type which
is an example of polymorphism so let's
look at an example to understand this so
we have a class called person and we
have defined
what we're going to define the
initializer is two attributes which we
have to pass called name and age and
we're going to store them in self.name
and self.h now we have a user defined
method called displaydata where we are
going to print if this display data has
been called through the parent called
person um if it's going to be called
through the parent class object then
we're going to print in parent class
display method and then we're going to
print the name and age that we have
entered now we have another uh class
called employee which is going to be a
derived class one person so it's going
to um so it's also going to have an a an
initializer and this constructor will
basically um what what this initializer
will have is it'll have an uh
constructor for the class where we're
going to do this uh the same
initialization that we do in the super
class but we're also going to store
another attribute called id in self dot
employee id and if you see here we also
have another method called display data
which is the same named method from
person but now if you see in display
data i have every i have all the same
almost the same information i'm going to
print the name i'm going to print the
edge but if you see the first statement
i'm going to say if i'm going to call
this method from the employee object
then i'm going to say in child class
display data method instead of in parent
class display data method to say that
basically i'm invoking this method from
the child class object and i'm also
going to print on top of the whatever
i'm printing before i'm also going to
print the employee id so if you see here
i have created an object called person
which is
an object of the class person with the
information of name john and age 40 and
then i'm going to display this now next
i'm going to create an object called
which is the child class employee object
which is going to
now have the same information of john
for the name and age 40 but now is going
to have an employee id and then i'm
going to store this
in amp and i'm going to display the data
for this child class object and we will
see the difference in how the display
data is differing from the earlier
earlier case so when i execute this you
see the in the first case it says in
parent class display data method so this
uh display data has been called through
the parent class object and i'm only
going to show the information of name
and age whereas when i invoke this
method from the employee class object
it's going to say it's going to
specifically say that it's a in child
class display method and then i'm going
to say the name is and also the employee
id over here so this is the difference
between how display data has been used
in its parent and its child class and
this is basically the example of method
overriding now our next example of
polymorphism
is going to be through operator
overloading and operator overloading is
the ability to overload the operator to
provide extra functionality in
additional to its real or core operation
and operator overloading is also an
example of polymorphism as the same
operator can perform different actions
the earlier example of where we use the
plus operator for different operations
is an example of operator overloading
polymorphism now when
when when is operator overloading
required well um anytime you want an
operator to perform a different function
for you in your custom objects you would
basically do operator overloading now an
example of this would be what i'm going
to show you below so if you see this
class called point it has an initializer
where i'm going to store two attributes
x and y in sep dot x and y and septa uh
instep.x and self.y now i'm going to
create one object called p1 where i'm
going to create point one and two so you
can think of this object as basically
like a coordinate x coordinate one y
coordinate two this is one point and
another point called uh x coordinate
three x one four i'm gonna call that p
two now i want to print p one plus p two
all right now if i try to execute this
you will notice an error it says
unsupported operand types for plus point
and point this basically means that plus
does not know what to do when it's given
an object of this type it has no idea
what to do whereas what we wanted to do
is add the the the x coordinate from
this point and the x coordinate from
this point so we wanted to do one plus
three and we also wanted to do this y
coordinate plus this y coordinate or two
plus four and then we want to print
basically like something like four comma
six or the addition of the two points
or the the vector addition of these two
points so this is what we want this plus
operator to do but the python does not
have any inbuilt feature for the plus
operator and we are going to have to
basically do some operator overloading
to create a polymorphism on this so
let's see how we can do that so to do
that first of all we have to understand
that all operators in python have
internally defined methods to provide
functionality for these operators the
operator or the special method to
provide functionality for the plus
operator in python is the add method and
whenever the plus operator is used we
are basically internally internally
invoking the add method so
these these sort of internal methods
that provide functionality for the
operators are part of a bigger class of
methods known as magic methods and these
magic methods are automatically invoked
whenever its corresponding operators are
used so we want to change the or the
operation for um the plus operator in
this example we are going to have to use
the the add method in this case and
since it's a magic method uh magic
methods are also
are basically what we saw earlier in the
in the form of dunder methods so magic
methods are going to be invoked using a
double underscore uh a prefix and suffix
to it so similarly to how we defined an
init of an init method or an hdr method
we're going to also invoke the add
method using the same double underscore
before and after its name so now let's
see how we're going to do this so if you
see this class i have now my class point
and i have the same initializer when i'm
going to store x and y now i am going to
define on uh this this add magic method
i am going to override the the normal
functionality of plus and i am going to
give it a very specific function where i
am going to say um for two two different
objects you're going to add it's uh the
first part the first part or its so
called x coordinate with the other x
coordinate and it the y coordinate with
the other y coordinate and you need to
return return this to me in the form of
a similar object so now when i pass one
and two and three and four it should
return me four and six as you can see
here i have basically done what i wanted
to do by operator overloading i have
changed or i have overloaded this add
this plus operator using this add magic
method and i have created a new
functionality for this add function for
these two points one and two three and
four now i'm able to add one comma two
three comma four in the way i wanted to
so now that you saw how we did operator
overloading i'm just going to show you
um a list of similar magic methods for
different operators that we are familiar
with so the plus operator already we've
seen has the add method then we have the
minus operator with the sub method and
similarly we have for all of these
operations such as multiplication
division we have its respective magic
methods these magic methods are again
prefixed with two underscores and suffix
with two underscores and they are
basically they are also called uh
dunder's in python so this is how we
would do operator overloading in python
for whatever operator we want uh
similarly we can do this for like
comparison operators and for unary
operators as well so look at this
example now where i'm going to overload
the multiplication or the asterisk
operator so i've again defined a point i
mean a class called point i'm going to
define an initializer but i'm going to
store some attribute x and self.x now
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
overload the multiplication operator
where i'm going to basically
allow the uh this asterix operator to
multiply two objects uh from like for
example 12 and five usually i can just
do a normal 12 times five but in this
case my object is slightly different my
12 is being passed through an object of
a class called point and five as well in
another uh instance of the same class
now when i want to multiply these class
instances like the the multiplication
operator does not perceive these class
instances to be integer so by default it
would not be able to multiply what we
want to multiply but when we define
or we overload the multiplication
operator within our class it's now able
to understand what to do um using the
attributes of these classes in its
respective uh class instances so it's
able to say okay so i want this
attribute from this particular instance
p1 12 and i'm going to multiply it with
the attribute 5 from instance p2
whenever i say p1 times p2 or p1 astrix
p2 so when i execute it it will give me
12 times 5. similarly i can also do this
for the greater than operator over here
so i have a class called person where
i'm going to define an initializer where
i'm going to pass name and salary and
store them in sub.name server.salary the
gt method is basically the greater than
method uh magic method and it's going to
uh we're going to use this to overload
the greater than operator and now again
i'm using this greater than operator i'm
able to basically say object one greater
than object two and i'm basically able
to check through this and if object one
is greater than object two it will
basically tell us if it is true or false
or uh basically whatever like we want to
know so basically the print statement
will check for uh object one dot name
and it will say earns more than object
two dot name if in case object one is
indeed greater than object two so when i
execute this you can see here my first
information says john has is earning 4
500 some units natasha is earning 6 000
of some units so it will say uh john
earns more than natasha well it's false
because object one is not greater than
object 2. so
since 4 500 is not actually greater than
6000 and this is the check that i'm
doing by overloading the gt operator
over here where i'm so where i'm
returning the boolean value of uh what
is greater self.salary or other dot
salary self being the first
object in any comparison so in the if
i'm basically any comparison if i'm
doing say if i'm doing five greater than
five greater than six so what the gt
will do is this will be the self object
and this will be the other object so
this is what i'm doing over here i'm
checking self.salary with other dot
salary in in the form of these objects
and it's basically the same same way
that we we are able to do five plus five
through these class instance objects
that you saw earlier or 12 times five
that you saw earlier so this is all
examples of operator overloading in
python well this was it for polymorphism
in this video we will be learning about
exceptions exceptions uh errors that are
raised during the execution of a program
when an an error occurs python generates
this exception that can be handled uh
which avoids our program from crashing
python has many built-in exceptions uh
however we can create many uh
user-defined errors or exceptions as
well to catch whatever errors we're
looking for in our program so when an
error occurs python interpreter raises
an
exception and stops the current process
and it passes it to a calling process
until the exception is handled and if
this is not handled the program will
crash um some of the
built-in exceptions are like i o errors
in the case when a file cannot be opened
or import error python cannot find the
particular module being imported and
there are so many similar so many
exceptions that are built in python for
the appropriate cases now before we move
on and see how we raise these exceptions
um let's look at the difference between
an exception and a syntax error so for
that i will be using an example where i
will be dividing something by the number
zero of course this is not possible so
let's see how python handles this
particular problem well it traces
something that it raises what we call a
zero division error and this is an
exception that is built in in python
whenever we try to divide something by
zero now let's look at the difference
between this exception and a syntax
error so this is the same statement
except i'm going to add this extra
bracket which does not make sense
syntactically in this now if i try to
execute this as you can see we get a
different type of error known as the
syntax error and it says unmatched
closing bracket so this is what a syntax
error looks like like an extra bracket
or a comma
that basically makes the line unreadable
to the interpreter in the first place so
the the interpreter doesn't even get to
the point where it needs to figure out
uh that there's something being divided
by zero it doesn't even get to that
point because it finds this extra
bracket and it cannot execute this line
at all so that is like the difference
between an
exception and a syntax error all right
now for our first case of how we raise
or how we handle exceptions let's look
at
the keyword rays so for this example
what i will be doing is i'm going to
take this variable x all right and i'm
going to store a value 10 and what i'm
going to do is i'm going to check for a
condition if x is greater than 5 then
i'm going to raise this exception using
the raised keyword like this and in case
this condition is met if x is actually
greater than 5 i want this particular
message to play out in my
exception so let's see what happens when
i execute this as you can see the
exception is raised because x is indeed
greater than 5 its value is 10 and the
error message says so that x should not
exceed 5 the value of x was 10. so this
is an example of how we can raise an
exception and as you can see when a
condition was met the program comes to a
halt and an exception was raised now
let's look at another type of handling
exception where we use the assert
statement so when we use the raise
command we waited until an error
occurred and our program crashed midway
right what if we want to check if a
condition is met and if this condition
is met then then the program can
continue but if the condition turns out
to be false then we want a particular
error namely the assertion error
exception to be thrown to us so we can
use the assert command in such a case so
in our example we will be checking um
whether the system that we are working
on is actually linux or windows 32 so
let's see first of all let's import a
library called sys this is the it's a
library which where we can access system
information one of the modules and that
is one of the functions and that is the
platform it basically tells us what
system are we working on so we're
working on a win32 system okay so um
let's now let's use the assert keyword
all right now we're going to check if
linux is what we are working on and in
case it is not then we want an error
message and this will be the error the
error will obviously be an assertion uh
error because we are using the assert
keyword
so this is how we use the assert
statement and if we execute this as you
can see we get the assertion error
because systole platform contains win32
and not linux and so we got this
assertion error so if we change this to
check for windows system we won't have
any error when we execute this as you
can see so this is the example where we
use the assert statement
another way of handling exceptions is by
using the try and accept block so this
is probably one of the most common ways
of handling exceptions in python
where we
use a try keyword and an accept keyword
now within the try keyword as you can
see here we have a chunk of code which
we're going to check and if everything
is fine in the try keyword then this is
perfect so we don't need to move on to
what we call the accept part of the try
and accept block but if say there was an
error in the try block then we move on
to the accept block where we're going to
run the
part of the code in the case we find an
error in the try block so first we check
the
part of the code that is under the try
block and if if there is an error we
move on to the accept block and we run
that part of the code over there and
where we and in the except block where
we that is where we handle our whatever
error that might get thrown our way in
the try block okay let's look at an
example at how to use this technique so
i have a basic function out here all
right it's defining a function called
linux interaction what this is uh
basically doing is that when i call this
function i want to do an assert check
i'm going to check if linux is the
system i'm working on and if it is not
then i want this error to be thrown okay
and um so yeah let's see what happens in
the case and if if this search statement
is actually passed then we will move on
to this statement so you could look at
it like this if whenever i mean when i
call this function it will first check
for this search statement in case
something wrong happens and we get an
assert error then we do not move on to
this line so we only get this printed
but if this assert statement passes then
we move on to this line and we get print
doing something okay so let's see now
i'm going to call this function out here
let's see what happens here as you can
see i get an assertion error because
obviously this is a window system and
not a linux system and i get this
message okay now let's see what happens
when we use it in a try and accept block
all right so now i have a try block over
here in which i am going to try the same
this function linux underscore
interaction if in case i find an error i
immediately jump from the dry block into
the except block now you see the slight
difference in how we handle this like
what happens so as you can see when we
use the function explicitly we directly
went to what we call an assertion error
but when we use a try and accept block
we will not use the assertion error
because we are leaving the try block
immediately and we are going to go into
the accept block where the only thing we
are doing is printing the statement as
you can see we are not on linux found
some error okay now what if we wanted to
catch the error within uh this function
itself which was the assertion error and
we can do that explicit layer like this
so now what i'm doing is i'm going to
try all right and it's going to catch an
error in this slide so now in the accept
block i'm going to say the assertion
error that we found in this function in
the try block we're going to use that in
our accept block so as you can see we're
going to print that assertion error it
will basically print this statement
function can only run on linux systems
as you can see here function can only
run on linux systems function can only
run on linux systems and
the next part of the thing was the linux
interaction function was not executed
okay so this is a very this is like um
this is a key there's a key uh something
very important happening here when we
use this assert statement the whole
program is actually getting executed
right uh but when we're using the try
and accept block we are immediately
jumping on like the moment we catch an
error we are immediately jumping onto
the accept statement and uh however and
all the handling of the exception is
done in the accept block and not in the
try block anymore so we do uh think of
it like this that the try block is only
to check if a particular piece of code
is
like does it have any errors or not and
in case it does then every like all the
handling that we do is uh in the accept
block of this particular statement now
let's look at another example in this
example i'm going to try opening a
particular file now this file does not
exist so i will be i will get a file not
found error and this is a built-in
exception and i'm going to cache that
and i'm going to print that error over
here in the accept block all right so as
you can see file not found and whatever
like error i have i printed over here
all right so this is another like this
is a file not found error that we're
going to that we we caught in our try
block and we're handling it in the
except block now let's use let's combine
both of the examples where we use this
linux interaction and we also try to
open a particular file and we try to do
both things in the try block and since
both of these contain errors let's see
what happens when we try to what happens
when we have like multiple errors in a
try block so as you can see in my try
block i'm not only doing this linux
interaction i'm also trying to
open a particular file that does not
exist obviously so now you might think
will i get two exceptions well let's see
what happens when we try to uh execute
this so uh it's important to note that
in our accept we have an except for uh
catching a file not found error and we
also have an except for finding um
the assertion error that that is part of
this linux interaction function so so
since both of these uh are erroneous
statements or they will throw exceptions
so now the question is will we get both
of these except blocks or when we get
both of these exceptions well we get
only one of them that we get the first
one so let's see what happens so as you
can see my error statement is is very
much like the assertion error that i had
that we had done as part of this linux
underscore interaction function function
can only run on linux systems the linux
function was not executed as you can see
that that is the one that has been
caught and for some reason the file not
found error has not been caught and this
is because this is a very important
feature of the try block the moment we
find the first error in our try block we
immediately leave and we do not execute
any of the further statements and we
jump into the exceptions and we handle
it using the accept blocks so the moment
an error was found in this function we
did not execute this part of the
statement and we directly jumped into
the respective exception that was the
assertion error exception so this is a
key takeaway so some of the some of the
other key takeaways when it comes to
exceptions is a try clause is executed
up until the point where the first
exception is encountered and in the
accept clause or the exception handler
we determine how the program responds to
this exception we can have multiple
exceptions and we can differentiate how
the program uh responds to each of these
and it's also very important to not use
uh accept clause on its own it's very
important not to use a bear accept
clause now finally before we conclude
this topic of exceptions let's look at
the else and the finally clause so the
else clause is used when we want to
execute a particular piece of code in
the case where we have no exceptions or
no errors found so let's look at this
just like we had the linux interaction
function i am going to define a win
under underscore interaction and this is
going to check whether our system is
windows or not in case it is not then we
get this error message all right and in
case it is a windows of uh inter it is a
window system we print this in the case
of when we call this function so let's
again use our try and accept statement
only in this case we will be using an
extra else clause so we first try this
function in case there's an error we
catch it as an assertion error and we
print that error but if there is no
exception then we move on to the else
statement and we print this so as you
can see our
we have actually moved on to the else
statement and we print this line
executing the else clause and that is
because we have found no exceptions over
here so again it's key to remember that
the else clause is used whenever you
want to execute a particular statement
in the case where we do not find any
exceptions in the try block the finally
clause is used when we want to execute
something regardless of
whether we have an error or an exception
or not so no matter if an exception
happens i mean is raised or if it's not
raised we want this finally block to
always get executed and let's look at
how it's let's look at an example of it
being used so i have this block where
i'm doing a lot of things the first
thing that i'm doing is i'm going to
check for this linux interaction
function which is going to check of
course whether it's a linux system or
not this i'm doing the try block now if
i catch an error i want to be i want to
handle it by simply printing the error
over here and in the event that uh there
is no error then i will move on to the
else statement and i will try
this particular block of my statement
which is again that when i'm trying to
read a particular file that does not
exist and it's very uh it's very
important
that you note that within the else block
i have another try and accept block and
this is perfectly legal and perfectly
valid in our program we can do this so
think of it like this i'm first trying
this if i have an error then i do this
and i don't
execute this but if i don't have an
error then i execute this whole
statement which contains its own try and
accept block all right but regardless of
whether i get an error here or not um i
will always execute this portion of my
statement or under the finally clause
let's execute this as you can see of
course the error
is raised in this try
stride lock so we move on to the
exception and that is what is printed
over here and after the exception is
done we move on to the finally we of
course skip this else block because the
exception was actually raised so after
that is done we move on to the final
block where we print this
particular statement well that was it
for an introduction into exceptions in
python i hope you learned something from
this and
of course this is just the beginning
exceptions are something that you will
be uh that you would probably encounter
a lot especially when you're beginning
and it's something that you will learn
to extensively work with and that will
also help you improve in your
programming in this video we will be
taking a brief introduction into what is
a function so a function in python is a
group of related statements that
performs a specific task or tasks now
functions help break our program into
smaller and modular pieces of code and
it's very good and very
convenient to use functions to make
our code organized and manageable
especially as our overall program grows
larger it also helps us to avoid
repetition and makes the code reusable
so let's look at the basic way of
defining a function so this is a basic
function that i'm calling fun
underscored name all right
now the rest of the function or whatever
the task is going to be performed by
this function will be my written over
here within indent of course as a
standard when it comes to python so i'm
going to define this one
something in triple uh double quotes so
don't worry about what this is right now
this is a doc string don't worry about
what this means and i'll explain it to
you just in a short bit all right
now now the rest of the statement the
rest of it
will obviously be what this function
will do let's include a simple print
statement all right let's uh it's done
here let's call this
so of course now once you've defined the
statement function to call the function
you just have to use its name like this
this is how you call a function so as
you can see when i call this function it
should print the statement hello now
let's go let's uh look at some of the uh
like what happened over here so we've
used the keyword def to define a
function we give it a unique name which
makes it uh which with which we uniquely
identify this function
and also once we've done this we
we can give it we can give this function
a particular header uh it's called a
docstring so what this docstring is
basically something that we include in
triple quotes over here just after the
def keyword and um this is like a brief
we can use this to give a brief uh and
give brief information into whatever
function is doing so we can say this is
uh this function performs addition this
performs um
subtraction or whatever like some basic
information as to what our function does
so we can use a dog string for that um
of course this is an optional thing this
does not have to be we don't have to
include this as well all right but for
the sake of this let's just keep it here
after that of course rest of the
function uh will contain whatever tasks
we want to do with it and that will be
indented
finally we can also include a return
keyword and what the return keyword does
is um at any point you find the return
keyword in a function you immediately
leave the function you go back to where
this function was called okay so now
let's see um now there's also one more
important uh component of defining a
function and that's parameter now if you
noticed over here within these
parentheses i did not include anything
this is like an empty pattern this is
opening and closing what if i said a if
i included some a and b over here so
what this means is whenever i call this
function i need to pass two parameters a
and b these can be like strings or
numbers or whatever um but now it
becomes almost mandatory that i pass
these two things for my function to uh
to work so let's define a function where
i'm going to add a and b so instead of
this print statement let's do this i
create a variable c and in that i'm
storing a plus b all right and then i
return c so you can use a return and you
can you you can return certain like
variables along with the return
statement so i'm saying not only return
from this function but also given output
or return an output called c which is
the addition of a and b now how do we
use this well now instead of just
calling the function like this i'm going
to add better i'm going to include
parameters so i'm saying pass 2 and 3 to
function name where 2 will take the
place of a and 3 will take the place of
b all right what will happen now is
addition will take place and we will get
return the result so let's see what
happens now as you can see 2 plus 3 and
i got the written the addition of 2 plus
three and it returned me five so yeah
this was like a basic uh usage of a
function and parameters so
of course uh we can if you want to know
like what a what the
doc string of a particular function does
or or says
you can use this
particular you can use this like
statement so let's say
so uh it's very important to like just
keep a note in your uh
while you're going through this so while
you're learning that uh whenever we use
some sort of a function which has double
uh underscore right this is like a
built-in a built-in command provided by
python um within the python library
itself so these are like built-in
commands to check certain details so i
want to check what is the dog string and
this is how i do it so let's do print
let's print what is the dog string over
here this is a dock string so this is
basically what i wrote over here i can
change this to this
like this does
addition for example all right now this
will say this does addition when i
execute this line so this is the way to
check what is a dog string anyways so
now that you have seen a basic
basic function or two basic functions
that i defined for you and how we use
them what a parameter is let's look at
another concept that we call scope and
lifetime of variables so
scope of variable is the portion of the
program where the variable is recognized
all right now a parameter and a variable
that are
defined inside a function are not
visible from outside the function this
is a very key thing so if we define
something within the function we can
only use it within this function and we
cannot like we cannot use it once the
function has already been executed so as
to speak um
these variables and these parameters uh
have what we call as local scope since
they are only um recognized within a
particular function now the lifetime of
a variable is the period throughout
which the variable exists in the memory
itself and it's very important to note
that lifetime of variables that are
defined inside a function
are as long as the function executes um
once we return from a function uh
whatever we have defined within it are
destroyed so
when we use a function it will not
remember the values of a variable from a
previous iteration of a function call so
let's uh try to understand this example
or this concept using certain examples
so
out here i have defined a function where
i'm going to create a variable my
underscore var
my variable and i am going to store the
value 10 in this and then i'm going to
print so whenever i call this function i
will always create this variable i will
store 10 and i will print the value of
this all right now
what i'm going to do is i'm not only
going to create this myvar inside this
function i'm also going to create a
variable outside so you see there now
you might be confused as to okay how is
the behavior going to be because outside
the function i have created my var with
a value 20 but inside the function i
will always define my virus 10 okay now
i'm going to print so my first what i'm
going to first do is i'm going to
execute this function that i created
initially where i store the value of 10
in my bar and then i'm going to pray and
print the value of my wire that was
present outside the function let's see
what happens you can see two different
things happening so when i execute this
function it prints the value inside the
function as 10 but when i print the next
line which says
okay now get the value of my var um it
actually prints a value of 20. and this
is a very key concept because what's
happening here is when i initially call
my function within this function it
creates a variable called myvar and it
prints the value as 10 and the moment my
function has been executed it destroys
this variable and
the variable which contain the value 10
is of course now destroyed and all we
have is the my wire that contains 20
from the outside and when we print that
we get its respective value as 20. so
you can also think of it like this the
my wire that is present inside this
function is different to the mywire that
we create outside so the scope of the
mywire within this function is local
only to this function and once the
function is executed that variable is
destroyed alright now let's look at a
another case or the other side of this
case where
say we're dealing with variables that
have a global scope how do we deal with
them so let's create a variable called
mywear all right and i say i store 100
in this all right now if i define a
function i've stored my let's say i
define a function define underscore say
again
same name where what i'm going to do in
this is i am going to print the value of
whatever is there in my where okay so
let's do print um
value of variable is value stored in
variable
is
okay that's uh
my where so let's see what happens when
we do this let's call this function
underscore name see what happens here so
as you can see the value i stored a
value of 100 in y where and i've called
it inside the function and this is
because since i've defined it outside i
can use it inside as well now what if i
try to change the value of
this variable inside the function though
so let's see
if i did this and now if i try to print
let's see do is this allowed no it's not
allowed in fact i get an error it says
local variable myvar reference
before assignment
and without going too much into detail
what it's saying is that the variable
inside over here is still local to this
function and i have not defined this
myware as a global variable so i cannot
make changes to it within this function
right now and uh to change that i can
use the global keyword what if i did
global over here so if i did global and
now if i said okay global mywear and i
declare this variable as a global
variable
now if i do this now if i do the same
incrementation now let's see what
happens when i'm trying to do this you
see i get the value of 101. it's exactly
what i wanted and that is because i've
defined my variable to be a global
variable within this function so i can
in fact make changes to it within this
function so this is how we use the
global keyword and global variable
also just to make a quick note um there
are three types of functions uh the
three types of categories in which we
can divide functions first one being
built-in functions these are the ones
that are built into the standard library
of python the other is user-defined
functions that is the ones which we
define ourselves and the third type is
called anonymous functions they're also
known as lambda functions and this is
something that we're going to cover in a
separate video now let's talk about the
arguments that we pass in python so
there are four types of arguments that
python user defined functions can take
first one being default other one is
required then there is keyword and then
there is variable number of arguments so
the default argument is when say um if i
define the function where underscore
sorry fun underscore name and i'm saying
a comma b right but what if um the user
has not um like say i i want a default
value of a and b each time when i uh use
this function so in the case where if
say i don't pass a value for a and b
like this will always be used so i can
just say a is equal to 2 by default and
b is equal to 3 by default and then
within this function i will say c is
equal to a plus b and then return c
so
i do this and if i say fun underscore
name and in case i don't pass any
arguments here let's see what happens by
default i get the answer 5 because by
default a is 2 and b is 3 but this is
not fixed and i can always change this
by passing my own values here 5 and 6
and in this case i should get 11 as you
can see here now the next type is the
required arguments and when we are
defining a required argument we just
simply do not use the equal to sign for
the parameters over here and this
basically um it makes it so that now
anytime we call this function we have to
pass something over here now if i try to
pass like this i won't get a oops yeah i
won't get a default value then that's
because um
that's because well there's no default
value and it needs an a and b so i have
to capacity three and say four now it
should give me seven as you can see the
next type of argument that we'll be
talking about are the variable number of
arguments so let's look at an example
here so what i'm doing in this
particular example is i'm defining a
function called my sum where i'm passing
some parameter called my integers and
i'm doing something out here and what
this does is um it will take the values
of a particular like collection of
objects and that's called my integers
and each value i'm going to keep adding
it to each other and i'm going to result
a particular sum i'm just going to
resolve the sum of whatever is there so
in this case what happens is i'm
creating a list
one two and three which contains one two
and three and then i'm going to print
the summation of whatever is there so it
should give me six now the problem in
this case is that each time when i'm
going to perform this uh function i have
to create a separate list where i'm
going to store these objects but what if
i did i do not know like what exactly
i'm going to pass here what if i don't
know if it's going to be a list of
objects or like what is it going to be
exactly well in that case i can use a
variable uh variable uh key variable
number of arguments so it's like a
variable keyword argument so what we use
here is um
a specific way of passing um keywords
and we do it like this so i say define
my under underscore name and i use an
asterisk now i give it any name this can
be args this can be integers it doesn't
really matter what this is but it's just
this is the key the asterisks here and
this tells us that whatever we pass here
is now if we're supposed to create an
iterable out of this and then we can
perform whatever task we want so let's
just uh since i've already created one
here let's see how i'm going to use it
in this case so as you can see i'm doing
i'm creating a particular variable
argument function over here and i'm
doing the same task i'm just going to
keep performing edit uh i'm going to add
whatever i pass over here but now when
i'm calling this function i don't need
to create a separate list as i did over
here i'm just passing all the numbers
that i want to in the form of like it's
pretty much like a tuple so i'm just
passing these numbers here and what this
function is going to do is it's going to
create an iterable out of this and then
we're going to iterate over it as you
can see that's happening over here and i
can keep uh i don't need i i can just
keep like
so since i've done it for one two three
and seven the summation should be 13 in
this case i can add another number here
just explicitly just like this and you
can see the value will change and that's
because this is a variable uh this is a
variable argument
method of
perform creating a function now the
fourth type of function arguments is the
variable keyword uh
argument so let's look at what is the
keyword argument now so i have defined a
function here called the concatenate
function and let's see what i'm going to
do with this so in this i have passed a
keyword argument i've said that okay
this is going to be a keyword argument
function and what i'm going to do in
this is i'm going to create a blank
string and what i'm going to do is i'm
going to add
or i'm going to concatenate certain
strings that i'm going to pass to this
function so i
in this example i have passed python and
is and cool and an exclamation mark all
separate strings and what i'm going to
do in this function is i'm going to join
them together um and i'm going to create
one whole string out of it let's see
what's the result python is cool so this
is so of course like uh if i had to add
some something else like python is say
cool and say i just wanted to say hello
and say one more string i can add i can
add it just like this i don't have to
like define a fixed number of arguments
i can pass any number of arguments i
want and this works exactly the same as
variable and
only differences instead of positional
uh arguments we're using keyword
arguments over here hello bye like this
doesn't really make sense but just to
show you as you can see so this is how
we use keyword arguments well this is it
for um this introductory video into
functions in python i hope you uh
learned a bit about defining functions
and so the keywords and the components
that
are part of function definitions such as
keywords and
i mean arguments and um
dog string for example uh you also saw
the different types of arguments that we
can pass
welcome to this video on python projects
by simply loan today we will learn three
hands-on projects that will help you
improve your python coding skills
we have with us anish karan who will
take us through these projects
so the first project we are going to see
is given a block of text you will count
the frequency of each word occurring in
the text or paragraph
in the second project you will trace the
movement of a robot the robot can move
up
down left or right
you will write a program to find the
distance between the starting point
after a sequence of movements
in the final project we will write a
program to check the validity of
passwords given by the user
often by logging into a website or an
application you are asked to input the
username and password to register
our project will check the criterias for
setting a password and approve it only
when the criterias are met so a password
should have at least one letter between
a to z
at least one number between zero to nine
one uppercase letter one special
character and so on
so let's get started with our first
project
hello everyone and welcome to another
video on python programming in this
video we will be covering a sort of a
project type type of scenario which is
basically going to be a problem case for
you and
it's going to be slightly slightly
difficult slightly tricky um
but what we're going to do is we're
going to tackle a particular problem and
we're going to what i'm going to do is
also
show you a solution to that problem
so let's start with this so this
question that we have is
we have this program
that we have to write where we compute
the frequency of words that
exist in some input okay
the program should output after sorting
the key alpha numerically
now
this input can be any it's basically a
block of text right so in our example we
have for example if this was our input
right uh what we want to see is
um
an output which is basically saying that
the word python has appeared say well in
this example it's appear times and then
the word read has appeared one time and
so on and so forth like for each of
these words we want to see
how many times have they appeared in
this particular block of text so
let's look at
a particular example now
where we have done this so let's um
let's see here
so first of all i'm going to create a
dictionary so why am i creating a
dictionary is because i'm going to use
each unique word as a key and the number
of times they have appeared in
a block of text as the value to that key
so
i'm going to use a sample
string which is basically this long
string that you can see here which is
stored in line so this large chunk of
text is what we're going to be analyzing
um
so how are we going to do this it's
pretty simple so
we have this now what we want to do is
um when we find what we one way of
tackling this problem that we're going
to do here
is
we want to
um check word by word um first of all we
want to see if it's a unique word and if
this word is
um before i encountered it for the first
time then we need to store a new key in
our dictionary called frequent table or
frequency table
um and if it has already if there is a
key already with that
particular name then we just want to
increment the count or the value by one
so let's see how we do this over here
so if you can see in my this the
solution is as simple as this but if you
see what's happening it's basically what
uh what it's doing is we're splitting up
this string uh using the split function
what this will do is it will split up
the string at every white space so it
will take this as one part and take this
part as another part it will create an
iterable
with each word as the um each iterable
object in that
container so
it's going to be a list of words like
python is one so on and so forth and
we're going to go one by one so we're
going to say forward in line dot split
now if this word is if it exists in
frequency table as a key then
what we're going to do is we're just
going to increase the count of
the value of that key by one but if it
does not exist then we're going to
actually create
a key
with the word as that unique word and
we're going to create its value um
initialize its value to one
so when we execute this
now
if we
want to once you've done this we can
sort it by the count of the words so
what we're going to do is we're going to
create a another tuple called sorted
tuples where we're going to use the
lambda function out here
to
sort the
um
the dictionary
in terms of its values so what we're
going to do is we're going to take the
key
uh the key being the lambda item item uh
with index one index one is basically
the value um so a a particular uh key
has a value so the word python appears
so many times the per the word
say scientist appears so many times so
we're going to check which words have
the highest number of uh occurrences and
we're going to sort it in a descending
order so that that is basically what the
reverse is equal to true does so when
we're going to sort this when we're
going to use the sorted function when we
say reverse true
it tells the sorting function to sort
this dictionary um this dictionary
frequency table
in terms of value
by the the descending order so whichever
um
word appears highest that would be the
first word in our uh sorted tuple so
that's what we do in this line and once
we execute this we're also going to
print so if you see the result
of this
activity that we've done you can see
that the word machine
um
appears six times learning appears six
times then python appears five times and
so on and so forth so we've created a
sorted tuple where the first object of
the tuple uh
we've created a list of sorted tuples
where the first object of the tube each
tuple is the unique word and then the
second one is the number of times it has
appeared in this um particular example
or this particular string
so yeah this was
the first basic project that we have
tackled if getting your learning started
is half the battle what if you could do
that for free visit scale up by simply
learn click on the link in the
description to know more
hello everyone and welcome to another
video on python programming in this
video we will continue with what we
started in terms of our project number
one what we're going to do is um we're
going to tackle another slightly
complicated a question or a situation
we're going to try to arrive at a
solution so in this what we have is some
sort of a robot a moving robot which
moves on a cartesian plane a two
coordinate plane um is going to move uh
in terms of up down left and right okay
and each each time it moves up or down
or left or right it takes a certain
number of steps in that direction
integral steps of course so what we need
to do is from a starting position
whatever its starting position is which
we are going to take as 0 comma 0 in
this example
we are going to make it move to a
particular location with the commands up
down left and right followed by certain
steps
um and we're going to
ask what we're going to do is we're
going to calculate the distance between
these two points
and we're going to calculate different
types of distances so you might be
introduced to new concepts um your
distance concepts in this video as well
so
what we're going to be using for
distance calculation is the minkowski
distance and that is um we're going to
take
so the minkowski distance between two
variables is basically the absolute
difference between these two uh
variables so these two points um
and
we take it to the power of something so
if we want to say uh calculate the
minkowski distance with
um
in terms of the quadratic main cause
distance with basically p2 so we are
going to do x i minus y i absolute
difference to the power 2 and then we're
going to take the second root of it
after summing each and every point um
so when we take p is equal to two we we
say the minkowski distance behaves like
the euclidean distance and this is
probably one of the most common
distances uh in case you've done um
basic
cartesian geometry when you are asked to
find the distance between two points on
a plane um we can also take the absolute
distance where we take p is equal to one
so in this case we're just basically
summing the
absolute distances between each point um
no roots no powers nothing basically p
is equal to one and we call that the
manhattan distance so we're going to
take p is equal to one two and three in
each case and we're going to find the
distance between two points uh based on
these
measures
so
this is just a visual representation
this is basically the euclidean the
distance basically the
estimate of the value between these two
points if um
since this is a two coordinate system
whereas the manhattan distance would be
the absolute distance in terms of
if we go up and then we go right between
these two like say this was and this was
another point
um so yeah
let's
move on to the problem
so what in this in this particular
example we're going to start from the
starting position 0 and 0 on a on a
graph and we are going to give the
commands of up 5 down 3 left 3 and right
2. so first of all what we want to do is
um we initialize the starting position
as 0 and 0
and we also just for the sake of this
example we
initialize the end position as 0 and 0.
so what we're going to do first of all
is
let's execute this much now we have this
list list of tuples um it's we're going
to call this actions and this is the
actions that we're performing so the the
each tuple contains an action and the
number of steps in that direction so it
contains four actions up by five steps
down by three steps left by three steps
right by two steps so now we're going to
iterate over this each tuple and we're
going to get the direction first of all
in this line
um for each step uh and we're going to
calculate the number of steps it takes
so for each action it's going to first
tell um it's going to check what is the
direction which is done by this line and
we're going to find out the number of
steps in that direction which is
stored in this line so
once you've gotten this for each action
we have to uh update the end position
right
so what happens is if you go up
by a particular direction so you are
basically changing the y y axis right
the uh the y-axis so we're going to
change end position and the first index
which is basically this part of the
end position
coordinate point so we're going to say
if it's moving by up then we're going to
uh
update by adding uh
the y-axis by the number of steps so
um and and if the direction was down
we're going to do the same thing for the
y-axis but we're going to decrement it
similarly if we move left or right we're
moving the x axis right so we take n
position in the first index so we take
the x axis and if you're moving left
it's a negative uh it's a decrement and
if you're moving right it's an increment
so
if there's any other like action like
any other action for example that was
given here we say pass so basically the
only valid
actions that we can pass is
up down left and right otherwise we we
just skip that particular action so this
is what the this particular loop will do
it will update our final position
so once we've done this
um
if we if i execute this
what will get stored in the end position
is basically my end position so
now that i have my starting position and
my end position um just to show you what
the end position will look like right
now
let's
just do this so if you see here after i
have moved up by five steps down by
three steps left by three steps and then
right by two steps my final end position
is minus one and two
my start position on the other hand
was
as you remember it should be zero and
zero
it is zero and zero so now we're going
to find the distance between zero and
zero and minus one and two so we're
going to first of all create a function
called minkowski distance which which
does the basic function of just
calculate the uh
the difference between the
what do you say
the end position x coordinate and the
end position y coordinate times uh or to
the power of a root and we're basically
going to do this operation that
you saw here we're going to do this
and um
we're going to uh
we're going to
use this root variable to
specify to like p is equal to 1 2 or 3
like what p value we want to take for
this minkowski distance so once we've
done this what this function will do is
basically store uh this much and it will
wait for us to uh it will basically wait
for us to give us a route so when we
give root one it will create these it
will check the distance between the end
and the starting points um with the p
value of one if we give it two it will
calculate euclidean distance with p
value two similarly for three and we can
calculate for any roots so we're going
to calculate for one two and three roots
um and we're going to see what values we
get in each case
so when root is equal to 1 i print a
statement saying minkowski distance with
root 1 is something and then root 2 is
something root 3 something let's see
what results we get
so if you see here the minkowski
distance with root 1 is actually 1.0 but
the euclidean distance between these two
points is 2.23 whereas the um
the cubic minkowski distance with
basically the with root 3 is 1.91 so you
see these three different uh distance
measures for the same distance between
two points so in this video you
basically so in this basically by doing
this activity you might must have you
will learn how to um
basically how to iterate through loops
um and perform these uh distance
calculations which you'll find pretty
handy in
many activities related to data science
and machine learning
so yeah this was on the project too
hello everyone and welcome to another
video on python programming in this
video we will be continuing tackling
different uh problems and
problem cases in terms of a project
called project three where we're going
to be using regular expressions to
validate whether
certain passwords that have been entered
or do they match certain criterias or
not
so let's look into
our particular question
we have a website that requires users to
input username and password to register
now we have to write a program to check
the validity of passwords input by the
users now the criterias that the
passwords have to follow are that
there's at least one number between a
and z um and this is at least one number
between is at least one letter between a
and z and one number between zero and
nine uh the third criteria is that uh
there's at least one letter between
capital a and capital z so this first
and third point basically is saying that
there should be one lowercase letter and
there should be one uppercase letter um
now there should be at least one
character from dollar sign hash or the
at simple um it should have a minimum
length of 6 and the maximum length of
12.
so when we whatever passwords that we
enter into our
example they must be commas separated so
if we're going to have an input they're
going to ask us for an input where we're
going to have to input the different
passwords in a comma separated way so
let's look let's look at
how do we tackle this so for my example
i'm going to use these
examples in terms of these are my
password examples if you're going to
check if these are valid passwords or
not so let's copy this first of all
and now let's import the re this import
rd is basically the regular expression
module
now in this step is going to ask us to
input the passwords as you can see here
so i will just control v so since this
is comma separated what it will do is it
will split up each of these by the comma
and it will store them in a list so it
will take this as one password this has
another password this has another
password and this has another password
once i press enter
now if i want to check what's in list i
mean what's in items
what i can do is
just check over here what's in items
it's a list of whatever passwords i had
entered
each object is separately treated now in
this list
now i'm going to create a an empty list
called value first of all once i've done
that i'm going to move on to the next
step
so once i've created my list called
value what i'm going to do is now i'm
going to search and i'm going to check
for each condition using regular
expressions for whatever criteria that
we have initially so
if you see here what i'm going to do is
first iterate by each item in this to
check for each password now my first
check will be a basic check
for the length of the password if it's
lesser than 6 or greater than 12
then our
our basically our password is illegal so
we can't be using this and we will just
continue and we won't check for anything
else but if it is within 6 and 12 the
length uh 6 and 12 then we can continue
with our check so we can do we'll do an
statement for pass which basically moves
on to this
next block
now once we've done this
what we will do is
this this first statement what this is
going to do is it's going to do an re
dot search and re dot search as you know
is going to look for at least one
instance of
a letter occurring between
a and z so this ire.search
followed by this now this is the regular
expression that we have passed and what
this does is is basically the square in
the square brackets we're looking for
anything between
a and z in terms of small letters so if
um this is if this condition is not met
then again we continue and we leave this
particular search because one of our
criterias is not met
all right but if it is met then uh this
if not statement will not uh like we
won't enter this block and we can move
on to the next check
so
now now we move to l if not now again
we're using if not statement so this is
basically checking for
a negative case so any time one of these
cases have been met it basically means
that our password has been invalid
because these conditions are not being
met so we're trying to eliminate all uh
conditions all of these conditions so
that we get a valid password so again we
move on to the next statement which is
basically going to do the search for
numbers once again if we find a case a
password without any numbers we continue
and we don't
check this password no more because we
already know it's a it's a
an illegal password now next check will
be for capital letters a to z
um and the next check again will be for
uh these particular symbols the dollar
the hash and the at one of these three
symbols
finally we have a a search for um
we're going to search for a white space
character so if we actually do find a
white space character in our password um
that's an illegal password and we're not
going to continue checking for those
cases
so
um so this is basically all our cases
lower case letters
numbers capital letters these one of
these three symbols and the existence of
a white space so once we've done all
these checks
if if none of these have been passed we
move on to this else statement where we
just pass and uh what we can do is we
append the value
we append the value to uh we append p to
the uh
the i the list called value
so basically what happens is um just to
go through it again
if this condition is not met
uh and this condition is not met this is
not met this is not meant this is not
met and if this is
also not met
um then we're fine so basically as long
as we have small letters as long as we
have a number as long as we have a
capital letter as long as we have one of
these three symbols and as long as we
don't have
any uh white space characters we can
append e to this otherwise it will
continue and it will break out of this
for loop completely that's what the
continued thing the continue statement
at the end of each of these blocks
checks um anytime this condition is met
this if not condition is met then we
break through we break through this uh
whole for loop and we don't append p to
the value but uh if we actually get to
this stage then what we can do is simply
append
p
to value now finally what we are going
to do is we are going to print out all
the valid um all the valid passwords so
just by a quick look you can see here um
this is a valid password right so let's
execute this and let's see uh
what we get if you see here we only get
one valid password and let's look at why
some of these did not turn out to be
valid so if you look here all of the
conditions are met it has a capital
letter it has a small letter it has at
least one number and it has one of the
symbols either dollar sign or the hash
sign or the add sign
in this case we have two white spaces
one over here and one over here so this
is an illegal password similarly in this
case also we have an illegal password
because it begins with a space
in this case it's the same thing we
begin with a space and also it does not
have any of those symbols that we were
looking for the dollar or the hash or
the ad so again so these three are
illegal passwords and they do not get
appended to value however this does get
appended to value and that's why we get
the result for only one password which
is the only legal password
thank you all for watching this video on
python tutorial for beginners i hope
this was useful and informative if you
have any questions then please feel free
to put them in the comment section we'll
be happy to help you
thanks again stay safe and keep learning
[Music]
you